foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
world is here as well if everybody in
the world
love everybody in the world
what a glorious world
this could be it's the culture it's the
music the artwork
[Music]
Deutschland
[Music]
good
I was just looking for myself and then
Expo came and it makes me emotional
Liz come on and join us a new
and it's right here at Expo
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's game six it's day six for the 2021
feed a World Chess Championship what
will the world champion do with his
third chance with the white pieces we're
going to get into all of that right now
as chess.com's coverage begins
ah
one two one two
yeah yeah chess.com in the house come on
uh Harry Mack in the house come on yeah
turn your volume up right now y'all we
bout to make this happen look ah come on
my name is Harry Mack I had to hop on
camera and spit welcome to the feed day
World Championship under 35 years that's
craziness been going down since 1886
match format with 14 games many queens
won't be captured the kids will be slain
check out the way I'm unraveling the
Rhymes this is sure to be a true battle
of the mind just so it don't remain a
mystery I'll take a moment to walk you
through the history I said we gotta show
love to the Masters 27 years strong
that's a manual laugh good this next
name here is the honor said it's the end
game master Jose Copa Blanca can't
forget Alexander alicon hey yo it's
technique man just my style of rhyme why
is that well he's a master of the tag
and I'm the master because it's disaster
over trash but when he died who's gonna
be the next leader feed day came with
the three years features Soviet Reign
for 24 years Cold War pressure it had us
in fear incomes the Americas and Bobby
Fisher he had to get the crown I'm just
painting the picture I'd be in the
shadow straight blasting off I'll be
slagging my rivals like Casper Rob when
they come to spitting sign I'm about to
get it done won't stop till my rating
28.51 uh I'm getting loose with the
style that was the past let me take it
to the now coming off top with the
clever words time to introduce the first
competitor if you don't know this is the
reminder the end game magician Norwegian
grinder Triple Crown win to go hard for
him of course I'm talking about Magnus
Carlos sin is he the goat the greatest
son highest score ever 281 can anybody
test the crown well I guess so I mean if
anyone can do it then there's nothing
cause he's never been the one to be give
it up beyond the time to see the ill
Russian the one that's causing that
concussion people pay attention from the
moment that he's touching the First Pawn
making the move is dynamic intuitive the
way he's doing it yeah gonna be an
exciting challenge nepo bout to get the
game in Balance going down 20 21 by
chess.com we're gonna keep it two live
twitch exclusive so keep it live we got
Fabiano Carolina up in the spot my man
Robert has and Daniel Rancher yo the
gameplay guaranteed to be intense feed
day Chess Championship it's on keep it
locked right here rejects.com peace
[Music]
we hope everyone especially the two
competitors enjoyed their rest day but
now now we're back there is no rest for
the weary and right here on the edge of
the couch on our studio is of course the
man Grand Master Robert Hess Robert are
you feeling rested uh no because our
game of Avalon lasted pretty late but
I'm feeling good ready for game six yeah
we have to cap it at just like one game
in the future Fabi I know that you love
yourself when you're lying to us about
being Mordred but but I just want to say
I was actually not lying to you most of
the time
like maybe 66. the problem is you
started out with such a strong lie that
you were just suspicious for the rest I
think you gave him too much credit for
his chest success yeah okay well there
you have it now you know what we're up
to on the rest days throwing down with
some Avalon some coup all the things
that we do uh when we're just hanging
out but uh right now we are hanging out
with something very special we have to
give a shout out to the fact that
sitting on this table before us is the
world's most valuable chess set uh it
was brought here courtesy of the artist
and Alchemist Colin Byrne uh it's it's
it's amazing we we managed to catch up
with Colin yesterday we're going to play
that interview at some point for you
later in the show uh and at some point
today Fabiano is going to be making his
first move predictions on on the board
and hopefully not breaking any of those
incredibly valuable and beautiful pieces
uh anyone who's interested can go to
firstclasschess.com for more info on the
amazing art that went into this uh
this incredible incredible chess set
before your eyes so all right but before
we dive into the next game make our
first move predictions on this set make
our result predictions and try to set
the tone for all the things we
anticipate might be going down when the
world champion has the first move for
the third time it's time to take our
last look back at what was game five if
you happen to miss it this recap of
course is brought to you daily on our
YouTube channel and without any further
Ado let's take it away and see all the
drama that was our last game before the
second rest day
it's game five it's day five the 2021
v-day World Chess Championship rolls on
with the Challenger getting his third
chance on the first move
the first time we have an Italian right
now we're looking like we're headed down
a road of Bobby was right again he's
played this against LeBron with both
colors yeah I don't remember the year
but they they played this line and they
had very exciting games so Magnus
actually uh has experience on both sides
of this line massive experience
I think this is quite a tricky situation
for mags to be in and judging by his
reactions here I'm not sure he's the
happiest
almost impossible yeah to break Spanish
easily yes of it after all I'm pretty
satisfied with what I got out the
opening because
uh despite the advantage was you know
sort of a fading slowly fading but um I
believe it's quite unpleasant perform
here as black
I had a nice pressure but probably I
chose the wrong plan
felt like that opportunity for yawn that
you do not get very often because when
Magnus is well prepared and in position
that he feels comfortable in and good
luck beating him today felt like that
opportunity and Jan LED slip up
I had as you said I had a clear goal for
what I wanted to wanted to do and that
was reach the
um the Fortress that I had in the game
and in that sense
it was was job well done and that was
definitely satisfying
[Music]
your general feeling about the results
given the position that you had and the
potential opportunities oh of course I'm
disappointed
[Music]
well yawn may be disappointed but that
video did not disappoint the drama
always feels a little more epic when you
have that kind of solo music behind it I
don't know why
I digress okay I want to give a quick
shout out where everyone can find those
videos on our main YouTube channel of
course is uh youtube.com chess but we
also have chesscom live our new YouTube
channel where this broadcast is going to
live daily just so shout out if you
happen to be in that chat room we also
have a Cliffs Channel a lot of the funny
things that are happening on set a lot
of the best and most interesting moments
of the show and also some of the more
educational opportunities that we that
we capture like a Pokemon and we we put
them in a put them in a bottle whenever
whenever Fabi or Hess are spitting
knowledge are also often at our chesscom
Clips channel so go to go.chess.com
chesscom clips and you can get that as
well let's remind you of who our guests
are coming up I already mentioned that
we have Colin Byrne the artist and
Alchemist and the diamond chess set we
have before us amazing stuff fedoc will
be joining us again the big fish 1995 we
actually have some fun questions for him
today you're not going to want to miss
that interview and then perhaps the man
the most talked about man on the
internet this week with his absolutely
huge announcement that he is leaving
twitch for YouTube gaming which is
ironic because he doesn't play video
games as he said so himself but Ludwig
is joining YouTube gaming and he is no
longer a live streamer on Twitch we're
going to catch up with lud talk about
how how closely he's following the match
we'll get his breakdown of the world
Hess championship and see what he thinks
about Robert's performance so far can't
wait to hear lud's a very honest take on
that so tune in at the top of the post
show as we say every day when the game
ends our show is really just beginning
and that's when the fun kicks off so we
will see you on the other side of the
game but right now it's time to talk
about our first move predictions and
then our result predictions Favi you
have the honors of not breaking the
chess set before you and predicting the
first move of today's game well thanks
for not putting pressure on me down
so we just learned that Magnus knows how
the Knight moves so I'm going to make a
prediction
that he's going to move his night out
Knight to see through on the person is
that because it's closest to you that
also it also helps that that piece is
very close to me so I don't have to
reach across the board and risk the uh
Integrity of the chess set okay 93 is
actually an interesting transposition
move forward but do you want to actually
tell me your real prediction on the
first one my real prediction is that
he'll play E4 I trust you
okay okay that was super close E4 I'm
actually surprised by that I don't think
Magnus is going to go back for the Petra
but I want to hear Robert's thoughts
before I give mine well if you made me
choose between which of the two you use
chess Instinct so much rust
I gotta go Fabiano we actually had a
long conversation yesterday about
openings and where we think that Magnus
would go and the pet shop he can look
for some weaknesses in Jan's preparation
yarn has been very well prepared but
there's so many different options
available in the pet shop I think that's
where Magnus is going you're predict me
for I'm gonna let you do it no I I want
you to do all of me now yeah you have
the mouse during the show you you can
make them okay okay I'll do it for you
all right I'm gonna go with D4 because I
feel like what we saw in game three was
or I'm sorry game four when Magnus had
the white pieces was
which is not very impressive so I just I
don't know that even with the rest day
that his time has had his team has had
enough time to really break that down so
and I think I felt like John's
preparation was was really impressive so
I'm predicting D4 and another stab at
the Catalan
so we'll see and as as usual we would we
would probably trust Bobby's insects I
don't think you've been wrong yet
uh I I don't think I've been right every
time okay but I can I can explain and
Robert can attest to this that I was
checking the Catalan uh the last few
days and
I don't feel like he'll find any
productive ideas okay in that opening
interesting all right well we will see
very soon and uh before we before we
before we go to the
break actually after the first move
predictions now it's time for a result
prediction so we've talked about what
we're anticipating on the board what do
we anticipate the final result till B to
be Robert I have Magnus winning I really
think that he can test Jan in the pet
shop I think that Jan has shown great
preparation for the most part but he
hasn't made the most of his chances I
think today after the rest day is
Madison's time to strike okay Bobby I'm
going to agree with Robert on this one
wow I think that after we've seen a
bunch of draws and the tension start to
build that one of these players is going
to make a breakthrough and last game Jan
was close to having a good chance of
making that breakthrough I think today
is going to be the day we finally see as
decisive result okay well as someone
who's always rooting for decisive
results I'm going to predict a draw uh
hopefully usually most the things I say
end up being wrong so you're welcome
World by predicting a draw maybe we'll
get a decisive result I don't really
care who wins I'm gonna say that jokes
aside I actually feel like Jan has
actually been rock solid as black black
other than that game two in the Catalan
again the reason I'm predicting it I
don't know that he's even even really
shown a single a single crack or or
[ __ ] in the armor if you will and uh I
I predict that he'll hold yet again so
we're gonna head to a break right now
when we come back we will uh continue to
dive into all the things but before okay
before we go to break I'm sorry a little
bit off this morning I'm a little I'm a
little off this morning doing great
Danny thank you thank you appreciate the
encouragement I'm gonna remind everybody
we've now casted our votes and you can
go to chess.com events and cast your own
votes uh all you have to do is uh find
the direct link to the game head over
our one of our helpful mods is probably
sharing it as we speak head over cast
your boat it's getting it's getting the
pool of people that are still perfect is
getting smaller so we're getting closer
to finding out who might be winning
thousands of dollars just because
they've been playing along with us and
boating throughout the show but you
still have reasons to do so even if you
weren't doing it from the from the
outset because we are giving away
Diamond memberships daily all you have
to do is go to chess.com event find the
game click on vote and look at that
three grand cash money for those for the
person who takes uh the the top prize at
the end of this and of course we'll be
reminding the chat that they can vote
directly on whatever portal they're
they're watching from here in just a bit
but don't go anywhere when we come back
we continue to break down our
predictions of what will happen on the
board for game six it's chess.com's
coverage of the feed a World Chess
Championship it's brought to you by
coinbase and it will return in just a
few
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations
play a game start review and try it
today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I think it plays its own role
uh it's you know it's I mean if if
trying to be serious it's hard to
evaluate because I think in modern
Church you got to be
very Universal player if you want to be
successful my client with chess.com and
well we're back in the Expo media center
and we have another draw it's Groundhog
Day everybody's waiting for something to
happen some very important feature will
have to change in one of these men to
pull out a win now when the players
entered the press conference I must say
that both were down but for different
reasons Magnus not particularly pleased
with his play or his passivity he said
the only active moves he played were the
final few that ended in a repetition
what about Yan well he was really upset
about not playing this C4 move and
actually Magnus was amazingly candid in
admitting that C4 would have put him
under duress but you know I want to go
back to the prior World Championships
I've covered Magnus when he started a
press conference in a Melancholy mood he
would pretty much stay that way the
entire press conference but his sea
change in these press conferences has
been amazing he almost always ends with
a smile on his face even questions that
he doesn't quite think are worthy of a
press conference he thinks thinks about
and gives a funny answer to we had one
today about how one of the pieces moved
and Magnus honored that with uh well a
straightforward answer this was probably
the most down I have seen Yan simply
because of a missed opportunity not
because he was worse at all so we're
going to see how that mood is affected
because they don't play tomorrow thanks
to the 50th Jubilee anniversary of the
United Arab Emirates and finally much
has been made about Magnus playing
football and soccer he actually says he
does a lot of water sports although
weirdly he doesn't like being on the jet
ski he likes being towed by the
watercraft he likes tubing he likes
water skiing but I don't know if he'll
hit the water tomorrow he actually says
he likes wakeboarding which is a little
bit difficult and what about Yan I
actually asked him privately bat Sage
what other sports would he be really
good at as compared to Magnus and he
said well he's actually catching up in
basketball now how cool would that be to
have one-on-one for the world
championship okay it's not going to
happen but we're are floating every
other ID in the world we might as well
try this one there you go Mike Klein
from the Expo Media Center we will see
you for round six in two days
Robert how does the horsey move
say really great question an interesting
one in fact I believe it moves two
squares forward to the side and then one
square either up or over so yeah it's
hard on the Pearl and I'll be careful
yeah I'm nervous about that but that was
that was Fabiano suggested so two up and
one of the sides there you go side and
one up we do appreciate good one thing
about 93 it was actually played I
believe in a world championship
which one in the world championship
tournament Moore zevich played it
uh in I believe 2005. okay the world
championship against Judith Polgar I
might be a bit off on the tournament but
he well for those who don't know it
actually isn't it it's a it's sort of a
transposition trick because against most
moves white is actually following with
E4 and often it transposes into a ping
pong game of some kind I love how you're
trying to adjust it I'm just saying it
it is not the worst first move someone
could ever play that's true I don't
anticipate it but I think objectively
it's just as good as any other first
move well besides the very bad first
movies like G4 but Knight C3 is a
perfect Rob bro
yeah I'm sorry I'm probably angrying
some people in chat who love that
opening but not my favorite all right
well
um we're gonna we're gonna let Knight C3
sit there in honor of Fabiano's actual
first move ever played on this diamond
chess set but okay guys Mike talked
about uh the uh the sport that maybe
could decide the Chess World
Championship we've been talking about
rapid talking about Blitz everyone's
every every which way I could go for
some one-on-one basketball to decide the
World Chess Championship title
that would be pretty awesome but no
that's not gonna happen I do think some
of this conversation is overblown yeah
these players are playing great chess
they're playing accurate chess but
Magnus said in the interview he doesn't
really care about playing the most
accurate chest in world championship
history because the way the preparation
has gone especially with the increase in
strength and engines and neural Nets
over the years not saying whoever played
in the World Championship with all the
months of preparation would be the most
accurate but many people would have that
kind of accuracy they're not taking as
many changes as they could we know that
Jan had the biggest advantage of either
player that was in game two and he said
I want C3 to limit any danger in my
position so Jan's not making the most of
his chances and Magnus just hasn't had
many chances to speak of
yeah it makes sense and I I definitely
agree that the conversation seemed a
little bit overblown and we're all on
the same page that we would just be
shocked if we had 12 classical games
drawn a lot of 2018 let alone 14. I just
don't think that's going to happen this
time around I I don't think it's going
to happen either and I think people
start to
because of the past memories uh start to
read a bit too much into draws we were
already hearing things about this after
the first draw and it's just a normal
thing in modern chess that you're going
to have draws between two strong and
nearly equally matched players right
especially when in a world championship
match they're they're both extremely
well prepared more so than normally and
since there's so much at stake they
don't want to take many risks because
well one loss might right might be close
to the end of the match for them it
might put them in a desperate situation
that they don't want to be in so maybe
we've seen a bit too much caution so far
uh from the players they will of course
have to to step it up at some point one
of them will want to win a game and not
just let it go to tie breaks
but they I think they're leading a bit
more to this out of caution and that's
understandable yeah well someone's going
to win a game at some point and on that
day chesskid.com will be free for
everyone so we all want a victory
doesn't matter I want a victory even if
it comes at the cost of a defeat for
someone else
yeah that checks out uh because
chesskid.com will be unlocked on that
day for all users uh young and old and
if you haven't tried chesskit.com our
Scholastic extension is great for kids
best educational tool out there no user
generated content no social networking
totally safe and awesome so give it give
it h4i today all right I think we're
going to take one last very very short
break guys when we come back we will be
diving right into the players as they
take their seats and game six of the
2021 feed a World Chess Championship
begins
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
again
[Music]
ovich
and two special guests accompanying him
first the governor of the Huntington
autonomous region
Natalia camarova
apparently she will not be accompanying
us but she is there in the VIP Suite
so instead we will introduce from Moscow
the host city of the 2022 Olympiad
foreign
a few surprises looks like some
Novelties welcome
from Moscow the host of the 2022
Olympiad the mayor of Moscow Sergey
sobyanin
and the mayor will have the honor of
playing the first move Mr Mayor
okay
thank you Mr Mayor and with that let the
game begin
well we're going to find out we'll find
out right now whether it was a troll or
you guys were right I think I was right
LOL oh one win for Dan can this someone
let's make sure that is that is noted
and shared throughout all the interwebs
Danny I don't know what's more shocking
that the first move was D4 or that you
were actually right well they came oh
look at this okay
if he plays the London I'm gonna find
Eric Rosen I think this is suggest
the only reason to do this is to play
the London uh after D5 he will
play C4 and transpose here
but then why wouldn't he oh G3 oh wow
what an interesting
no no in theory
I could still be even more right I'm
already right but my prediction was a
Catalan in theory we're not fully away
from that possibility yet no you you're
pretty much spot on that so I suspect
that
he can play E6 here this is what this is
in line with what he did in the second
game
uh if white plays C4 we we get directly
to a Catalan there yep white normally
has no reason to place move order except
to delay C4 by playing E6 Bishop to G2
right
and
black can play Bishop E7
there are also moves like B5 at black
wants to get an independent game to to
stop C4 that's actually a fun line to
note yeah my magnets himself has played
that as black so it's a bit unlikely
that he'll go for that okay so the
question is after Bishop E7
and let's say White Castles black
castles what is White's plan to to avoid
what he what we got in the second game
which is C4 D takes C4 by transposition
this is what we
what we had already
um
so there are moves I guess like B3
that's the only
like most only other really sensible
move I can think of is B3 and so C4
and
of course it's not a very threatening
opening because black has a lot of
freedom there's not really much pressure
on black it's more of a slow positional
game
so
yeah the question is of course black
doesn't have to play E6 as well anyone
is thinking here for example Bishop to
F5 taking advantage of the fact that
there's no pressure on D5 yet so black
is free to develop a bit more with a bit
more Liberty playing Bishop F5 getting
the bishop out of the pawn chain
and uh black also has the option of G6
this transposes to something that
yanwood is certainly very familiar with
which is basically a groon filled with
G3 where black at some points plays D5
and we get a symmetrical structure yeah
Robert your thoughts on whether that's
exactly what Magnus wants actually see
that's exactly what I was going to say
is because right now Jan isn't thinking
about what move can he play he's
thinking what move should I play because
with magnus's approach he has been
non-committal he hasn't played C4 he
hasn't allowed any captures no tension
just yet and as Fabiano was suggesting a
move like Bishop F5 is possible but that
takes him away from the uh opening we
saw in game two and perhaps Jan wants to
get away from there but he doesn't know
what Magnus has in store for him so he's
playing without the full information of
magnus's intended repertoire and with
that in mind he is going to spend some
time here thinking what is Magnus
anticipating in this game what has he
looked at with the engine with his team
of seconds and can I avoid it and G6
makes sense and because you go back to
grunfeld-like positions but because Jan
has a long standing history by playing
the grootfeld perhaps that's exactly
what Magnus wants that he was looking at
the gravel prior to the match and so
going back from the Catalan lines where
they're very concrete variations very
direct lines maybe that's where yon
should go back because he's been doing
well with that approach with the black
side
we see on standing up and taking off his
jacket despite the fact that it's his
turn no it's a great Point Robert about
G6 because one of the things we talked
about coming in was the fact that Jan is
well known as a grunfeld player
but would he stick with that in a world
championship match given Carlson's many
months to prepare and he showed in-game
in game two that that was not
necessarily going to be what what he was
going to do if we talk about the fact
that in game two uh you know we had a
much more direct a direct approach which
was C4 E6 Knight F3 and then D5 yon
showing on move two in game two that he
had no intention to play the grunfeld so
but with G3 being played you have the
option to play certain variations of the
ground Pro that maybe aren't the most
topical these days although as we say
all that we now see Yan's commitment on
the board says you know what I'm willing
to get exactly what we had in game two
show me what you got big fella yeah I
think that this was the most likely
Choice from Jan yeah it's of course G6
is a good move and would be in line with
Jan's repertoire prior to this match
right but his repertoire for this match
clearly indicated that he's he's not
fianchetto in his Bishop he's more
playing the classical systems uh and and
this is exactly what he did in game two
so I think it's most likely what Magnus
expected oh it would be right that's
really interesting so now no Catalan so
it will I'll call it a wash we were all
wrong even though I got the first move
right I was convinced Catalan was about
to appear until B3 the reason I like
this choice is because it doesn't have
the same options in somebody else
there's no forcing variations that trade
off some pieces or say you need to go
down a certain variation right this is
the type of opening that Magnus is
suitable for Magnus I should say because
he likes to have wiggle room he wants to
be able to outplay his opponent over
stretch of time rather than just
concretely beat them by calculating a
six move series better because
janapamishi is one of the best
calculators in the world what Magnus
really thrives in is these positions
where you have to come up with plans
every single turn and you have four
different equivalent looking options but
he tends to pick his options better than
his opponents historically speaking so I
do like the move B3 Fabiano gave us that
is an option and I like the opening
Choice even though it's nothing special
just yet well it also seems from a
practical perspective in all the games
we've had so far at least the last few
games John has been able to play very
quickly he was clearly pulling on prep
this is the first game where it feels
like the tempo is changing a little bit
right John is already going to be a
little cautious with every move well I I
get the impression that and this is not
just based on the speed of his moves but
um I believe that people generally are
well prepared for Sidelines and so I'm
sure that he's familiar with his line
he's also playing quickly uh but
nowadays modern players they don't just
focus on the main lines they know that
also they can get uh they can get out
prepared or tricked in Sidelines and
they have to spend just maybe not just
as much but they also have to spend a
significant amount of energy
um analyzing Sidelines so this is
actually I saw that face you gave and
Robert wasn't on camera Robert gave the
same exact face bobbiano did no it's not
so if we go back a little bit because I
I was checking this recently uh if we go
let's say to a cattle on but let's go
from the classical move order not C4
okay so wait just from the start D4
Knight F6 yep C4 E6 or Knight of three
we'll go with what happened in game two
yep c46 Knight F3 D5 okay G3 Bishop E7
Bishop G2 Castle
and here there is a not a very popular
move but it's kind of popular topical
move B3
and
um black usually not always but usually
takes on C4
B Tech C4 and C5 and there's been a
bunch of high level games here and white
can Castle here
black takes on D4 Knight takes D4 and we
have a pretty much an identical
structure to what we might see in the
game if black takes on C4 uh White has
the split pawns a2c4 the advantage is
the compensation for that is the bishop
on G2 is extremely strong and limits
black from developing and here we have
some high level games for example Wesley
so played Queen to B6 I believe against
Sam Shanklin other strong players like
Lanier Dominguez played Queen to B6
um so this is this is one of the main
lines of the Catalan
and it's different than in the game
because in the game white side is on F3
Black's Bishop is on C5
but it will bear a lot of similarities
this is interesting one question I have
in the game continuation is you know
we're talking about essentially D takes
C4 as Black's main move which does make
perfect sense can white make a move like
Queen of C2 pinning the pawn on C4
trying to win it back and the only way
that I could see to try to like you know
maintain extra material would be like
very slow in terms of development now
this type of position black can just
develop and give back the pawn and that
should be all right right yeah move like
Knight C6 or
number of other moves but at least it
ask some questions you know to to yawn
though Fabiano's points still very well
taken um with these lines where even if
your pawns are split from White's
perspective there's still some chance of
long term but I think with the Knight on
F3 remaining there b takes C4 doesn't
feel quite as strong
as the other variation excuse me lost my
voice already often I'll finish your
point because it's a really good one
obviously in in the lines that Fabiano
was highlighting let's say from from the
Catalan is or sorry in the in the
Catalan we had here the pawns are split
but White's compensation is the activity
so Robert's idea of Queen C2 is
instructive because in theory if white
wins this Pawn back without having to
split the pawn and and in a later day
opens up this bishop white is sort of
having his cake and eating it too so to
speak you have this pressure on the lung
diagonal without ever having to create
the the isolated C4 Pawn weakness so
sorry Robert still your thunder but
finish your point I needed you because
agreeing with Fabiano I guess hurt my my
soul
I mean not be able to speak anymore uh
but no in all seriousness yes that is
the point that you don't necessarily
want to compromise your Pawn structure
as well Quincy also leaves Rook D1
available as a next turn and some of
these positions so it just puts the
question back towards black of how are
you going to proceed because the split
Pawns they generally speaking concern me
even though I fully understand and see
what Fabiano is saying yeah I think that
Robert's correct this is almost
certainly the idea in case black were to
take on C4 B Tech C4
um the structure might not be so bad but
the trade of Queens yeah and the easy
development of Knight to C6
uh makes black probably completely fine
um and black is not even forced to trade
Queens immediately but can keep the
tension when I just C6 and wait for
white to try to trade Queens right so so
Queen C2 looks like an interesting idea
um
the one important thing to note is it's
almost never good for black to play his
move but if black were to play B5 here
and usually you think it's just
generically not good because 95 or
something but here it's actually quite
important because here black can can
block an id5 it's actually very
important for white to play Knights G5
what's the difference
so The Rook is hanging so black has to
some in some way but what happens if I
move the Knight to D5 Fabiano
I'm glad you know how the Night Moves
in this case it doesn't help black at
all knowing how the Knight moves what
happens okay fine I'll just do it I
thought you'd be like well Danny okay
um no but it is really important and uh
that's again a tactic that you pointed
out in game two it is a thematic idea in
the Catalan to be aware of tactics on
both sides of the board because of the
Knight G5 Discovery whenever the queen
takes this diagonal go ahead Robert yeah
actually I was thinking of these if D
takes C4 and B takes C4 instead of Queen
to C2 it reminds me of some other
positions uh in the Catalan where we get
this exact Pawn structure and what white
wants to do is move the knight from B1
to D2 to B3 and then eventually even can
push this Pawn from C4 to C5 and so it's
almost like a transposition not exactly
but has similarities to another
variation it's a deceptive structure I I
agree with you guys obviously that as if
my opinion matters that I agree with you
but I agree the end game is it matters
to me it's not it's not going to give
white the best long-term chances but
that idea you're highlighting Robert is
really instructive because I think
optically when you first look at the
isolated Pawn you go
no good right but in this particular
Catalan structure because of the
combined pressure on the lung diagonal
this Pawn getting to C5 would be an
absolute Thorn and we've seen games that
look close to equally yet white has this
just nagging grind right the nagging
grind that doesn't go away and combine
that with what just looks like a move
order that has put you on a little bit
in the think tank here I'm already in
that practical Camp of you know so uh
once Robert started that sentence
sentence a sentence
no coffee's on the way guys what was
Robert star of that sentence I knew
exactly which variation he was talking
about yeah okay uh so let's let's just
show that line if we go back to the
Catalan okay main line again
Catalan
Knight F3 D5 G3
and so uh Jan played in Bishop B7 but
there is D takes C4 another main move
and after Bishop G2
one of the most popular moves is C C5
striking back in the center
and after Castle short Castle Knight to
C6 one of White's main moves if not the
main move is D takes C5
and after Queen takes D1
Rook takes D1 Bishop takes C5 white
plays Knight B to D2
and black in order to break up the
structure Place C3 Whitewater zavich
lives B takes E3 and this after Castle
looks very similar in some ways to the
the game the bishop is on C5 it might
get kicked by Knight D2 B3 and uh we see
something
uh rather similar but Magnus uh we can
see played played Roberts first
mentioned idea Queen C2 Robert's on fire
today you shaved you look good can we
get it can we get a close-up on Robert
real quick I think we should
you're looking great so I know I know
you shaved to try to change the momentum
here right yeah I thought that the
reason they weren't getting decisive was
because they had a beard yeah so I
decided I would shave that way maybe
I could try to regrow it and live up to
the expectations we have I'm trying to
be mvl but I'll get there one day but in
all seriousness I mean those
transpositions are very important to
recognize and when I saw the move C4 and
the possibly b64 I immediately thought
of that opening variation that Fabiano
had mentioned and I was thinking well is
that something that Magnus wants to go
down clearly he says Queen C2 let's not
trade Queens let's not get there because
those variations even though white does
have some pull it's been studied to the
nth degree and many players have found
ways to equal as Wesley so has so many
games in that opening so Quincy 2 it
doesn't liquidate it leaves more options
available and Jan is the one thinking
Magnus in an interview uh it was it was
in Norwegian but we had a translate he
was saying he Max likes his own time
management he thinks Jan has been very
well prepared and it seems like he wants
to get Jan out of his comfort zone as
early as possible because those direct
lines those trades those long opening
theoretical lines they have helped Yan
neutralize magnus's first move advantage
and right now even though it's still
early stage of the game John is the one
on the clock yeah and you want to put
pressure on your opponent on the clock
and on the board and Magnus is doing
just that right now we see you on here
at our in studio monitor and you know
Bobby let me ask this question as Robert
was giving uh that that advice there I
wondered just because you put the queen
on C2 is B take C4 out of the question
because this idea of Robert's Knight to
B3 you know transposing into the Catalan
idea with the eventual C5 thorn in your
shoe is that still a possibility I don't
think it's out of the question at all uh
I think if you were to be given an extra
move now he would probably take with the
queen on C4 but there are scenarios
where B type C4 makes sense especially
because that Queen on C4 it is active
but it could also come under some sort
of attack let's say if black were to
play the moves Queen E7 Bishop D7 and a
rook to C8 that Queen would be under an
indirect attack
um and actually Queen Seven Queen C4
Bishop D7 does seem like a pretty
sensible well actually Queen E7 is on
the board so you are all over it sir
so
I I do Wonder B type C4 that the thing
is if unless white is able to continue
his initiative then most likely black
won't face any problems and I think
after bc4 black can comfortably most
likely Play Bishop to D7
that's the only problem PC has and he's
willing to trade that Bishop ball let's
save 95
um then maybe bishop to C6 he's willing
to trade that Bishop off even if it
costs him to Bishop here because his
development is the most important factor
for him to complete and here I think
he's just equalizing very comfortably
that's a great Point sorry I was going
to say and this is exactly the type of
line where the bishop here is perhaps
less relevant than Black's development
and effective Rook to C8 hitting the
isolated C poor Pawn is coming quickly
and also we see in this position that
due to White's Pawn structure the split
pawns black has an outpost on C5 and
that Bishop is actually very powerful
there so all of Black's pieces look
quite good here
um
I I don't think he would face any
problems so now we'll see if magnuson's
tends to play Queen C4 and Yawn is still
playing quickly I actually think after
Queen C4 a very sensible move for black
maybe the critical move is to play E5
oh interesting E5 uh threatens E4
potentially threatens Bishop E6
potentially that Bishop suddenly gets
the problem of the bishop gets solved in
one move and also E4 is very annoying
um it might not be a big problem if
let's say Bishop to B2 then after E4
it's a bit double edged as well because
that pawn could is a bit extended it
could potentially become a weakness
but uh look at the move player I was
gonna say it's it's a hybrid idea of the
variations you and Robert are talking
about but with one huge uh what do you
call a sacrifice upon Magnus is
gambiting upon yeah this is this is a
fantastically creative idea
um so the critical move is C takes V3 I
think that we should jump into that yeah
it takes B3 and Bishop to D6 and I think
that white doesn't have anything
concrete it's just it's just
compensation Bishop to B2 Rooks D1 and
C1 and a very dangerous idea that might
happen is Knight to G5 at some point
that just threatens a Checkmate in fact
if I know his idea from earlier with
Bishop D7 that's the problematic piece
yeah Bishop B2 Bishop D7 you already
have Knight G5 ideas because Bishop C6
is the way you want to meet the uh
attack of the Pawn on B7 but Bishop
takes F6 ends the game on the spot
removing the defender of the Checkmate
on H7 I am guys
Can you feel it
I know I shouldn't call it Robert keeps
saying not to call attention to it but
Knight bd2
this is very interesting um if black
doesn't take that pawn
and let's assume for a second that Jan
doesn't know this position because I
have a feeling this is a super rare idea
maybe just a new idea completely
um so Jan might intuitively just not
want to capture material because that it
feels dangerous and you think Jon is
already going to be surprised by this
I I mean I I don't know I'm not an
expert on this opening but I would be
surprised if this is a known idea to me
this looks like a completely new concept
to tell your next one every opening
every single one no you know your
Fabiano caruana not quite enough no I'm
kidding obviously that uh okay well I'm
not you are Fabiano we'll talk about
that later but
um the point is it's it's always
fascinating I think for for the fans of
the guys in the top ten like yourself
when when we see Novelties on the board
that could indeed surprise them with his
release move tent right you go wait
um and to me this past year criteria
that if cb3 Knight B3 initially you go
okay black should be fine blacks up a
pawn but the more you give the engine
time to think and you just look at the
position you go wait
even even even the computer is kind of
liking White's compensation here which
just has has my Spidey senses tingling
yeah I I wonder what White's most
accurate move is here because when we
played Bishop to B2 we saw the eval bar
drop a little bit it's evil yeah so uh
the evil bar so maybe bishop to B2 is
the most accurate although it looks like
the most natural move it might get
blunted by E5 I'm thinking I was gonna
say your E5 idea strikes again and this
is a really common structural point in
these cattle lands where the where the D
and C but and a lot of variations of the
Queen's Gambit kind of declined and
accepted black changes the structure
with the Z5 move so maybe there's
something uh more accurate but Robert
what are your thoughts yeah it's a
fascinating moment here for young my
first thought is Will yawn accept that
pawn because Magnus went into this
position he's moving very quickly in a
way you know he kind of wants you to
take because you're in his preparation
and Jan is on his own I really believe
that young he has studied positions like
this but when you see Knight D2 he's
already spent nearly 20 minutes on the
clock and we know that Jan likes to make
his moves quite quickly in the opening
that he's caught young and it's not that
Young's position is lost so in that
position C takes B3 Knight takes B3
Bishop D6 those moves are very natural
and maybe even Force so you get here and
you're like well white has Bishop B2
white has Rook D1 uh to start with white
has Rook B1 that you could play just to
see how black is going to react but I
you know it feels like many of those
moves look appealing but I don't want
black to just play Knight C6 Bishop B7
and get out very quickly so I think my
focus would be on stopping that very
direct plan
I think it's possible that the bishop
should stay flexible and C1 because
maybe it wants to go to G5 yeah yeah and
it'll move like Rook to D1 makes a lot
of sense to me because this is a
generally useful move the the bishop on
D6 is a bit
um loose let's say it's not hanging or
anything and there's no real direct
threat with this but it's a bit loose so
Rook D1 should be a pretty natural move
what if you play Knight F3 to D4 instead
of Rook D1 because we know black wants
to play Knight C6 so I'm stopping you
directly your E5 move is well taken but
now if you play E5 right you can play
Knight F5 getting rid of your Bishop
pair and that seems to give white some
compensation in the long term with the
bishop on G2 and if not for Knight F5
because it'll also have gone Knight to
B5 maybe it's worth going after the dark
Square Bishop right in the light Square
Bishop so it's a position where white
has a number of options but we know that
Magnus has looked into them and so I'm
gonna trust whatever he plays and then
Yellen has likely not go ahead I think
this is actually important to the line
that uh Robert just mentioned so let's
say let's go and C takes B3 Knight takes
B3 Bishop to D6 and I'd have to D4 it's
clear Black's ideas to play E5 at some
point so Knight f2d4 is a very logical
move stopping that the question is if
black doesn't play E5 it's not easy to
develop you can move the Bishop from C8
because of the B7 Pawn your knight can
no longer go to C6 or it can but it's
sacrificing upon back
um probably it's going to lead to some
Advantage for right there uh the Knight
doesn't really want to go to A6 because
well Knights don't really like being on
the rim like that and if E5 I think
instead of Knight F5 which is the most
natural move Knight to B5 is actually
more dangerous because that Bishop on D6
it doesn't it doesn't look like a super
important piece but once it's gone
blacks dark squares will be super
vulnerable and let's say black plays
um a move here it's actually difficult
to find a move I was gonna say because
you can't you can't develop your
business if you move the bishop off we
trade on D6 and B7 Falls we're gonna do
a knight C6 Bishop takes C6 is a problem
because the rook and a is hanging the
bishop on D6 is hanging so I feel like
these kind of positions you're walking
on eggshells even though there's clearly
a move to survival black it's very I
actually think maybe the move well Queen
B7 there's Queen takes B7 Knight takes
D6 that just fails so
black has a way to survive here and it's
not entirely obvious what it is
uh people Bishop B8 no but then Bishop
A3 I think ah that was my first stop
because Queen Aid Bishop B7 traps a
queen and would probably be excellent
for black probably winning but Bishop to
A3 wins an exchange
so
Queen to E
eight
oh my gosh by the way this was really
fun because with the email bar but no
engine moves Fabi is really put to the
test in a position that just simply
makes no sense okay but I doubt we'll
get this but okay I think just out of
elimination yeah there was no other move
which wasn't losing and queen T8 it was
a funny exchange attack but it might
even be a relevant variation which is
kind of funny
um because we saw with the moves that we
made that uh the bar was sort of stained
relatively level
so but of course Black is Black is not
forced to go into this and Queenie it's
very hard to see from afar from a
distance right so in that variation
we've been looking at to get into that
position and then after Knight F to D4
you see that the Knight can go to B5
after E5 but you have to think about
this queen E8 move several turns in
advance even before taking on B3 yep
because this looks like a position you
don't want any part of and then you see
this ridiculous looking move Queen E8
that doesn't make any sense because all
your pieces are hanging you're working
the corner you're Bishop with D6 but
somehow it holds for black it's
difficult you don't have to calculate it
but look at the clock situation Jan's
already down 20 minutes so if he can
keep you on burning time while Magnus is
either directly into preparation or
within the realm of his preparation that
will continue to make yawn nervous here
because he was not expecting this
opening today
you can sense it there's uh this is
going to be a game with some tension and
uh for sure for sure at least at the
early outset some fireworks given that
the Challenger is uh uncomfortable for
the first time in several games not not
necessarily any game but really for the
first time in several games Yawn is
burning up clock in the first stage of
things and uh let me remind Chad really
quick before we dive back in that now
the Voting is closed at chess.com you
can spam the emotes and chat let us know
who you're rooting for use your channel
points cast your Bono but the result of
the game will be a little you have a
little bit of an advantage now because
now you're like oh feels like maybe
Magnus is going to have some pool but
either way cast your vote spam the chat
Be Kind Rewind Robert you see me with a
Jack Black and most deaf reference there
I I think I think I said on a show one
time like I used the term rewind the
other day and like like one of my kids
like didn't even know what it meant yeah
for a second because
but it's still used in culture like hey
rewind that moment but overall it was
kind of funny that that was a good one
but I was gonna ask Fabiano if you were
playing in this game you know that
Magnus wanted to get to this stage here
would you take that pawn on B3
well I my my instincts my chess
instincts are not to capture material
um especially this kind of compensation
where I'm under pressure for a long time
and especially when I know my opponent's
in preparation so I would try to play
something else
but the advantage of taking material is
you probably know that you're not worse
there because you know why it has
compensation but it's probably not
enough not more than an advantage
objectively and if you play a move like
Knight to C6 white might actually have
just that free Advantage by plane might
take C4 and then Bishop B2 and
um this would be my instinct to try to
play E5 and try to go for something like
this but uh I understand both approaches
I actually want to to point out a
parallel
between this and the second game because
in both uh games Magnus played Cat
Catalan sort of lines this is not a
direct Catalan but it's very very
similar and
um in both cases he sacrificed a pawn
early on and it was part of his
preparation and I think we're all
thinking of one player when we think
about Catalan and pawn sacrifices
slightly speculative maybe Pawn
sacrifices but based on deep preparation
and he's a player who also worked I'm
not sure if he still works with Magnus
but for sure he's worked extensively
with Magnus
um dubov is is known as exactly for this
type of preparation and for those type
of sacrifices it's sort of his
his uh calling card in the way
yeah it's interesting and that leads to
a whole interesting topic on the
influences that seconds have uh
especially with their everyone has the
same second we keep saying it's a super
jet engine strapped to a Lila backpack
with a stockfish 14.1 neural net water
bottle in the side of that backpack you
know and whatever else comes with it but
but it's the players who are who are
teasing out information and and how much
does the creative mind of the player
influence the engine the other way Bobby
like players who say no no I know I know
what they're saying but I let me push a
little bit right poke a little further
and get them into a position where
there's something unclear and do you
think that that's something that makes a
difference in in these types of matches
yeah I think the analyst is still the
more important factor because the
computer is a tool and everyone has it
yeah
um but the difference is made by who's
using the tool yeah and we could have an
idea like this which you know 99 out of
100 people would not really analyze
because computer probably says black is
okay with Knight C6 cb3 Bishop D7 E5 and
the Very variety of other moves and
people just put that down because they
think okay Black's good here computer's
telling me that or you some people will
think about the Practical implications
of this move and how it puts pressure on
your opponent I think that comes alive
with experience which Magnus certainly
has plenty of and he understands which
ideas might be unpleasant to face and
ideas where your opponent has a lot of
possibilities are actually a two-sided
uh coin right on the one hand it makes
your job as an analyst and as a player
more difficult because you have to deal
with this all this plethora of ideas
that you both have to analyze and also
you realize it makes it less likely or
sorry more likely that you will be out
of your preparation faster with white
because there's just too many things to
cover on the other hand it's also
unpleasant for your opponent
um if if let's say Jan had one clear
option here and every other move was bad
he would easily play that option right
and then deal with the problems later on
but now he has to decide between several
equal or equivalent looking options
there's Knight C6 or cb3 obviously
there's a move like C3 even
this is a difficult decision uh just
based on the amount of options that
black has what we've seen Knight C6 on
the board and so to answer Robert's
question would you take the pawn
Jan says you know what I'm not
interested in your in your silly game
silly Magnus tricks are for kids I'm
going to play the more logical move and
let's get a full close-up on yawn if we
can here in a second I just want to see
see that man pour his tea he just did it
he's not getting up despite the fact
that he made a move that already tells
you we're dealing with a yawn that knows
he might have his work cut out for him
today Robert well he's studying right
now yeah right he's not recalling he's
studying he's studying I like that and
that's important because Magnus caught
him off guard he's trying to figure out
this position and just because he didn't
take the pawn and he did develop doesn't
mean that the rest of the game is easy
for him right and we actually saw Young
when a very nice game from the white
side of a cattle type position in the
candidates against alexianco yeah where
he looked really sharp in that game and
yes Alexander made a mistake and got a
quite a terrible position early but it
shows that Jan may feel comfortable from
the white side of this position as well
and when you play certain positions from
both colors you have to sort of forget
your successful past with with either
side but particularly with the side
you're facing because that can make you
get in your own head you're like well I
remember when I won that game with the
white pieces and it felt very natural
for me to make my moves and black every
single turn was difficult and he goes
Knight C6 Magnus will in all likelihood
just take that pawn right now with the
Knight on C4 and his Knights are aiming
towards E5 and one thing you don't want
to allow in this position from Black's
perspective is that opening of the
bishop on G2 that Catalan Bishop is
typically White's advantage and you
could play E5 for black which is what we
talked about for Knight takes C4 yep
Pawn to E5 but that does leave behind
some light squares and you need to be
careful about this because E5 looks
great it opens up your Bishop on C8 so
it can become a more active piece but
there are times where white is able to
operate around that pawn and cause black
some problems yeah
again a typical idea probably pointed
out a while ago it's a typical idea on
all these structures that we've said
where the where the queen side Central
pawns have cleared but and specifically
because white doesn't want a knight to
come to E5 in these structures if you
can avoid it let alone the fact that
this bishop needs to play but
here it feels a little riskier than
normal for whatever reason just because
white has the move I don't know what
what would be the concrete ways for
white to play here though yeah I think
that between this option and black has
one other very obvious option or very
natural option is Bishop's D7 and
followed by a developmental Rooks to C8
and d8 I think Bishop to D7 is slightly
more natural okay
um
first of all because black easily
completes development here and also
because after Rook at C8 black will be
threatening uh the move B5 that Queen
and Brook are lined up and white will
have to deal with that issue for example
if we were to play Bishop to B2 here I
think the most natural move work agency
eight
and let's say we make like Rook F to D1
uh maybe Rook HD1 is a more natural way
but anyway B5 suddenly gets very
annoying if that Knight moves to E5 for
example that wouldn't be very very bad
void after Knight takes E5 Knight takes
E5 Bishop takes up two
and we see it was like the C file was
was occupied by so many pieces but they
all get cleared away away very quickly
so white would have to deal with the
idea of B5 and I'm sure there is a good
way to do that so
but it makes Black's play look pretty
harmonious because he's developing with
with Tempo in some sort in some sense
so you're saying you like Bishop E7 a
little more than the structural strike
yeah E5 the question is well Bishop B2
is very natural now and you
um you attack the E5 pawn and if black
plays E4 then suddenly Knight G5 is a
move
and this might not be bad for black for
some tactical reasons but it does at the
moment look like you're losing a pawn
you might have an id4 and something
something concrete two or Knight to B4
something concrete to save your Pawn but
it's not obvious to me what that
concrete approach is and you see Magnus
is uh
I think he's recalling Robert where Jean
was studying I think he's uh
he's recalling
he doesn't look happy though yeah I
wonder well I mean as Fabi has said you
know he uh
he doesn't look happy often even if he's
about to win so you know sometimes
Magnus just looks like someone stole his
cookies and
forgets that he's got plenty more
yeah I don't really unders like from the
way he's acting his body language and
the fact that he was playing very
rapidly and now he's stopping to think
it looks like Knight C6 was a bit of a
surprise
but I don't understand how it can be a
surprise I think he's maybe just
frustrated that Jan didn't go for the
sharpest variations of the pawn sack I
mean
yeah but anyway you have your
preparation you follow it yep I mean c
takes B3 yeah was obviously a move that
you analyzed probably the first movie
analyzed but the second move was
probably Knight to C6 because what what
are more natural than those tumors
either taking upon or continuing to
develop in the most natural way
so
a bit of a strange moment
um because obviously not deep bd2 was
his preparation yeah and it's like
everything that black did so far was the
most natural way
uh like we kind of predicted that he
that young would play E6 Bishop E7 that
he would play C5 we we mentioned this as
as kind of the most obvious move
I have to take C4 obviously DC4 is one
of the main moves but I can also maybe
play like D4 or something so so there
were some options to consider but it's
strange to start thinking after Knight
C6 specifically well he had Young on the
clock thinking John has thought much
more in this game obviously everyone
tuning in can see that here and uh we
believe the the the creative novelty
this move Knight bd2 was the first move
played in the game that had never been
played before upon sacrifice inviting
some potentially very dangerous
compensation in the open board on the
long diagonals but yon yon thought for a
bit if you're just getting here and said
you know what thanks but no thanks I'm
just going to develop and uh and see see
what you have from here and Magnus now
uh
now on the clock
yeah this is a strange moment and he's
either acting or he's surprised um how
much acting does occur at the high
levels like this I mean
there's a little bit of gamesmanship
there right because if you know the line
well
what's the harm in taking a moment to
try to remember it deeply anyway and if
that somehow tells your opponent that
you maybe don't know what you're doing
you know yeah he I mean people often
think even if they're in their
preparation and it's it's probably a
good idea to do so to some extent not to
just rattle off moves that you don't
understand yep like uh like a machine
but
still like it's just reading into his
body language a bit he just looked
frustrated
um and I I don't think Magnus is one to
act normally he he usually there are
some players who who uh do a good acting
job okay name them best actors of the
top of the top players you've played
over there well I think I already sort
of answered this question I think he
gave a couple of them
um but that was uh maybe distracting
Behavior but anyway no no it was it was
more like
well you know I
also players changed over the years
um but at some point
uh like Anish was it was almost funny
like it was it was an entertaining
entertaining thing he's an Entertainer
like he would let's say
capture your queen like with his Queen
and and you would capture back
you would capture his Queen back and
it's only moving the position and then
he would start to make faces like you
just
you know like you just took your pants
off in front of the board like you made
the strangest move ever and and so you
understand of course that at that point
like it's just some sort of
like either it's supposed to get in your
head a bit but it's just a funny thing
to witness
um but sometimes you know you you make
you make a move
and and he makes uh an expression like
like what what was that move what did
you just do right
um and it the idea is maybe to get in
your head a bit yeah um but I don't want
to sing a lot of people because he's not
the only one who's uh who's who's done
some actors no I think it's smart to
just continue to single out a niche just
let him let him take to the Twitter's
fear to get his revenge yeah we might
have some uh Twitter back and forth
after this but I I do want to say that
Anish and I are in good terms and yeah I
do uh well that makes one person who's
on good terms with the niche Robert are
you say one person's in good terms with
Fabiana
yeah I think a lot of people are on good
terms with Fabiano
um but yeah this deep dive here by
Magnus yeah it you know it feels like he
must have expected Knight C6 right such
a that's what Bobby was just saying
something feels off trying to figure it
out because he doesn't look pleased and
he didn't as soon as the move was played
and now he's really spending some time
here so I wonder what exactly that is
because it's Block's tenth move
preparation runs much deeper than this
temp move so I I yeah I don't know well
and the reason we're speculating she had
not to add unnecessary drama to a moment
although you know we might be the most
dramatic thing happening right now on
these on these shows so we continue to
to call it like we see it part of the
reason it's interesting is because
players at the high levels guys they
don't take time just to take time this
isn't like you know when kids are
learning clock management and your coach
says take this amount of time for this
many moves right if they're thinking
there's a reason for it right and
whether it's recalling preparation
whether it's calculating something deep
it's not unfair for us to speculate that
that there's something to this and so
when someone has been playing quickly
they they're the ones who surprised
their opponent they're the ones who
played the first novelty yet suddenly
they go into the think that Magnus is
makes you wonder it's just it's a
strange moment though right like this is
such a logical reply by Yan and Magnus
chose the variation so I don't know what
exactly he's thinking about what he
could possibly be surprised by yeah move
Knight C6 yeah I also think
um it does seem like a strange moment to
think because even if you were wanted to
make your opponent uh think that this is
a surprise for you like what advantage
does it have here sometimes you might do
that because there's like after your
move there's some sort of trap after
Knight takes before there's no trap
black just decides on the developing
move right either E5 or Bishop D7 both
of those moves are probably fine and and
there's like there's nothing that he can
try to trick him into by by making Jan
think
uh you know he's he's suddenly out of
prep
um the other thing is if you're if you
play an ibd2 and you don't play Knight
64 next why did you play Knight bg2 well
maybe he was giving black an option
causing him to think and then maybe you
can go B takes C4 like we were looking
at earlier yeah let's let's look at B
takes C4 here real quick because yeah
because after bc4 E5 I don't think white
is doing very well
but it is the structure that you see in
those other catalans is there is there
let's just go down the Traditions
Queen's misplaced in C2 uh because you
keep giving black ideas to attack that
Queen in many different positions so
it's not horribly placed on C2 it just
doesn't feel like the necessary move if
you started from the variation we looked
at earlier Quincy 2 isn't part of the
equation in fact the Queens get shredded
off and without the Queens on the board
it makes White's life easier to start
making inroads and putting pressure on
Black's position so yeah I don't think B
takes you for it is what he's really
wanting to do here
so then you just have to go and I take
C4 I detailed yeah population me after
bc4 E5 Knight B3 I I just specifically
don't like White's position after E4 so
um
because then a bishop comes F5
um yeah maybe there's not G5 Bishop F5
maybe you can take this this Pawn uh
with Knight C5 complete Bishop B2 maybe
you can play Bishop B2 but I don't know
it does doesn't feel like white is
playing for an advantage here so my
random idea town just to complete it was
well Magnus tried for a pawn sack that
excuse me didn't happen
yeah so he played he's taking the pawn
so okay I thought maybe he'll continue
to try the pawn sack but in hindsight
I was just looking for something here to
talk about in terms of why the world
champion was burning up so much time but
he indeed plays the most logical move
which is Knight takes C4
it's a it's a Slightly bizarre moment
um not because of the movie play but
because of how long it took to play it
because of the time he spent and also
because he he doesn't look happy and he
didn't look happy
playing this move and he now he looks
concentrated and
um
and I I just don't understand how
like you know it's possible to miss
things in prep all the time there's a
lot to look at a lot to be overlooked
but this particular move is a strange
thing to to not consider in your
preparation
um especially when you're playing you
know a new line you want to
and you let's say you have this idea and
you're you're happy with it you think
it'll put pressure on your opponent and
so you don't want to you know be out of
book right after he plays the most
natural move it's it's even a little bit
embarrassing over the board to start
thinking
and and not only that it's it also gives
your opponent some like Jan was worried
it gives him some peace of mind now
right that well maybe things aren't
unless scary as I thought unless Magnus
is trying to get nominated for an Oscar
unless he's acting
I don't get that sense but maybe it's a
good time to start his acting career I
mean okay if he's actually now I mean
right so he he's been a Porsche
commercial he's active he's he's acted
some was he actually the voice in the
symptoms or was he just a character
don't know I never actually saw the
episode if I'm honest
yeah Queen E7 was officially the first
novelty in the game although it was
played so quickly and and seemed so
natural uh Fabiano suggested it right as
John played it it didn't have a shocked
obviously Knight bd2 a much more
head-turning move to sacrifice upon uh
and uh potentially be all in on on a
Gambit idea but yeah Queen E7 the first
official novelty in the game although
again probably after Knight bd2 Knight
C6 and Knight takes C4 whether we got
into this position
via some sort of novelty
it uh
yeah yeah it is obviously not a very
novel like idea necessary the structure
now looks very familiar it looks like a
very typical Catalan position
um for me the most interesting thing is
Will Young go for the more aggressive
approach E5 we considered Bishop D7 a
bit but let's have a look at E5 okay
because White
can play Bishop B2 but it's not the only
move another move which makes sense is
Bishop to G5 okay well so E5
Bishop to G5 is what you're saying it
makes it certainly makes sense it's
basically saying I'm going to give up
the bishop pair
um black my play H6 white takes on F6
black takes on F6
and white maybe can play a move like E3
basically white just wants to say okay
so E5 you weakened your structure a
little bit you weakened Your your long
diagonal my Bishop now has huge scope
and if I play Knight F to D2
um your Bishop on C5 is a little bit
blunted maybe the bishop pair doesn't
matter so much in this position and
maybe E3 isn't the most accurate way to
go about that but it's an interesting
idea yeah but this is some sort of idea
for for why the other thing was of
course Bishop to B2
instead of Bishop to gg5 is a very
natural way to do it
but in that line you were looking at E4
although again after Knight G5 Bishop F5
well here yeah so let's see this is
interesting because black sacrifices
upon but certainly gets compensation
after it takes up six let's say yep
queen of 694 and maybe Queen to G6
it's hard to say there's also Queen E7
but
um the pin is a is a bit annoying to
deal with it's hard to break that I
noticed that white has a tactic here of
Knight to E4 yeah I was just about to
say that's one way to get out of
everything here is a big simplification
and and maybe white ends up a healthy
Pawn up here
black probably has
you know well I think instead of Queen
B2 okay
we'll equalize uh there might be like
Queen to D5 Rook ft E8 Queen to D5
and
um black takes E2 y takes B7 it ends up
a pawn up so this is a good outcome even
though it might remain very drawish just
because a lot of pieces have been traded
off
uh so some possible lines I feel like at
some point black
had enough compensation in this whole
variation
but yeah it's it's a responsible
decision for Jan to play E5 to sacrifice
upon you have to to look quite far ahead
and be committed to to betting to
playing with the two Bishops against uh
against White's Pawn advantage over that
end game where white has a pawn but
you're comfortable and that you might be
able to hold that seems like a bad idea
though yeah specifically that final
position we saw I think isn't very good
for isn't a very good idea because
well let's say you're roughly equal here
objectively you don't have to to go for
a position where you're something like
this or you're worse and then you just
fight for a drone for the next you know
four hours or whatever it is so the key
point is that you have to be willing to
play this position a different way than
perhaps with Queen E7 so maybe Queen t7
yeah to not allow that 95 tactic and
a little more long-term compensation now
with the bishop pair this would be a
Magnus way to play down a pawn with but
with the bishop here
yeah black will white has to deal with
the the problem with this pin
um I think like E3 is very natural
because I want to stop Knight to D4 but
yeah the pin the pin is certainly
annoying wide will at some point play
Knight c2d2 to deal with that so maybe
E3 and Knight c2d2 covers
covers that option
it's difficult to say there's also well
maybe just Knight C2 C to D2 immediately
is uh which gains a Tempo is a sensible
approach doesn't like it computer really
doesn't like it maybe bishop to B4
um
will uh everybody's under Fire yeah
there's some threats there are some pins
um actually I see a move
I don't know it doesn't quite work I'm
trying some tactics like Knight to A5
but but after Bishop takes E4 it doesn't
seem to work out which position instead
of Knight C to D2 some Knight moves like
Knight to A5
I would I'd love to do this yeah father
you crazy in this case yes
Bishop takes before I feel like Robert's
rubbing off on you you're you're giving
away pieces that aren't your own
son of a great commentator
oh sacrifice at will these pieces are
not yours
speaking of commentators we've got
Yasser watching on Twitch thanks for
thanks for being in our comments section
time for the counter-intuitive 11b5 in
order to neutralize the long diagonal
counter-intuitive 11b5
Yaz Town population yes sir well so this
is interesting
um
because it gives white an option of
Knight F to E5 Knight C to E5 is the
most normal move but there is also
Knight fte5 which probably doesn't work
out after Knight to D4 I think that's
important the queen will move
and the question is where does it move
it's not so easy actually Queen B2 B
takes C4 I just want to point this out
oh okay Bishop A8 C3 look at that
nastiness and uh yeah that would be well
I'm not losing my queen just yet I can
go here it would still be a very short
the four the fourth the fork is a
problem a forking problem if you will
um here I think black is probably
winning with many moves I was gonna say
Bishop A6 looks fantastic or Knight
takes E2 Yeah by Bishop to B7 creating
some sort of tempo here and 92 check is
coming okay wow what a line that could
be
um so B5 Knights C to E5 is the most
natural move yep
and black can play Bishop to B7 hero
whoa I believe risk wait Knight C6 and
B4
uh yeah that's
that's very unfortunate for black
there's a piece
and Bishop takes up three Bishop takes
up three to work on A8 is suddenly
hanging maybe black has Bishop D4 but
probably not very good for black yeah
they don't want to align all your pieces
up on the C file so after Knight C5 what
does black want
there is just Knight B4
most likely Knight to B4 it's not that
interesting interesting oh no there's
1966 that's the problem okay
but not to be for
looks like a good move the queen let's
say goes to B1
or B2 it's it's difficult to say I think
Bishop B7 and Bishop B7 and then and
Black Knights will
be nicely well Bishop B4 is an idea here
but also Black's B4 and I can safely go
to D5 where it's a very strong piece
so this looks like a good option 11b5 oh
is it on the board yeah oh my gosh yes
there's Sarah one strikes again in the
chat
um
credit to yawn that credits yawn that's
an aggressive move right there it's one
of those moves you almost never want to
play but you want to play it exactly
when it works yeah because this could
lose you so many games especially for
people in the audience who are newer
chess oh I'm gonna attack your knight
with B5 but the bishop on G2 that
Catalan Bishop is incredibly strong and
just because my Knight's under attack
doesn't mean I have to move that night
and there are oftentimes he moves in an
F3 rather than Knight on C4 just to take
advantage of that exposed diagonal here
it doesn't actually work in White's
favorite it's moving in F3 because of
the Knight D4 ideas we're talking about
so B5 is a great shot and it's if you're
a yawn to promise you fan if you're yawn
himself it's so nice that he wasn't
unnerved by this opening because he was
really sitting there thinking trying to
figure out what men wanted from him and
he said well I don't have to play this
game on magnus's terms I'm going to
strike forward with B5 here and that's a
really good move however in certain end
games if we get there that move is very
committal and there will be holes on the
queen side for black that can be taken
advantage of by White's pieces that's
not really relevant at this particular
moment but of course when pawns move
forward they can't move back and so B5
in certain positions can be a pawn gone
too far I think you make a great
practical point that it shows is it the
nerves we've been looking for Robert
these are I won't go as far as nerves of
Steel but to play B5 when your opponent
surprised you first we saw how Jan was
managing his clock right he was clearly
showing just by his behavior that he was
the one with a little more to solve in
the in the first 10 moves but now he
feels like he's found himself and this
is the most aggressive way you could
ever play this position right here yeah
and I think that Jan had this in mind
when he played Knight C6 he spent a lot
of time and Knight takes E4 was the most
natural move so he had this move
um already
plans in advance and Magnus I don't
think is very happy about the outcome of
outcome of the opening now uh because it
looks like young has knows what he's
doing
um he's decided on this on this uh we
can't really call it a defense because
it's quite active but he's decided on
this
um this move and it doesn't look like
Magnus is familiar with it yeah I'm
wondering if maybe Knight C to D2
is it looks strange to go back but maybe
the Knight is actually quite well placed
there
and if Knight c2d2 I think the most
natural way to continue for black is
Bishop to B7 now okay
and after Bishop to B2
it doesn't look very active but white
has some ideas of Knight G5 and
um the Knight on D2 rather than E5
doesn't block Black's Bishop oh it
doesn't block White's Bishop on B2 this
long-term kind of fun little hedgehog
re-maneuver Queen to the battery on A1
yeah that's exactly what I was thinking
if blackplayers were created C8 yeah why
we'll play Rook a to C1 and then the
queen will drop back to B1 where it is
safe from any potential
uh discovered attacks or any attacks at
all and then why we'll try to play
Knight G5 but it also feels like white
is not really
playing for an advantage here and it's
probably quite close to equal
objectively one thing to think about is
instead of retreating with Knight to D2
the first move that we're talking about
Knight C to E5 oftentimes in these
Catalan structures the Knight on D3 is
quite powerful right so Knight B4 is a
good first shot to make sure that Lexus
get in trouble and I think Queen B2
might be more accurate than Queen B1
because this bishop B7 Bishop B4 move
said if you play Bishop B7 perhaps I can
kick your knight away with A3 bring my
knight back to D3 and then you see this
position where the Knight on D3 is
really hard to dislodge and even though
the queen on B2 is awkward because the
bishop probably wants to be there it's
one of these positions where you just
kind of have a game where both sides are
now tasked with coming up with
um some serious plans and all these all
four minor pieces are on the board only
two pawns have been traded per side it
gives a lot of wiggle room for each
player
yeah I think this is the most probably
the best way for black for white to play
is actually it looks like all the moves
that we just made are are very logical
and
it's not of course there's many
possibilities so it's not certain that
something like this happens but it's
very likely something like this happens
I think that's cdg2 not a terrible move
but probably not uh not the right way to
play it so Knight cd5
feels right and before feels right and
queen to B2 I think is probably the only
good Square for the queen because Queen
to B1 runs into Bishop B7 and Bishop to
E4 so why why wants to avoid the queen
getting kicked around too much
the B2 Square feels a bit weird
uh on first glance because the bishop
seems like it should be there but maybe
it has a home somewhere else yeah the
bishop could easily find a home on G5 or
D2 or some other Square
um I'm wondering
you hear anything Knight to E4 is enough
okay yeah so you actually have to be
careful there so I was thinking of white
moves the night maybe Knight to D4
actually it both attacks a pawn
and frees up uh and protects the E4
Square
so but the Knight also looks a bit loose
there maybe after a simple A6 there is
um
there's no real point to the night being
there
it's a very weird position to just like
Robert said it's just a game right it's
going to be a game where both sides have
the opportunity to outmaneuver and out
play the other which we always say those
types of games favor the world champion
he has been the best chess player in the
world now for quite a while and and and
uh he tends to outplay his opponents but
still you again have to acknowledge Jan
for what he's achieved
with this with the second move with the
black pieces here right you have to
acknowledge the position he's managed to
get it might be the best move John has
played in the World Championship that's
why I use that the nerves term right he
wow this isn't the best position he's
had yeah but in game two which he had a
serious Advantage there it was kind of
Magnus just making a big mistake that
was uncharacteristic of him not to take
anything away from Jan who played an
interesting opening gun position that
was hindsight this 95 was best 95 was
very bad and uncharacteristic of the
world champion but here this is yawn in
territory that he's not familiar with
just playing this B5 move striking so he
doesn't get a passive position it's
hitting kick White's pieces around to
fully develop his pieces and then now
we'll see how he plays from there
because this isn't the end of the story
you can't just be content to say I
played B5 I got out of this opening on
Skate there's plenty of game left here
and now they're gonna have to continue
finding ideas it is not the end of the
story indeed not even close our show is
just beginning here chess.com's coverage
of the 2021 fide world Chess
Championship game six is going to
continue to roll on you're not you're
not going to go anywhere I know you I'm
watching you I'll
tens of thousands of you are going to
sit tight we're going to take a very
quick break when we return chess.com's
coverage which is presented by coinbase
continues
[Music]
hi Jonathan corable here from Expo 2020
in Dubai with another trivia question
about World Chess championships
during his match with capablanca
Alexander Al yankin switched his
citizenship to France now despite having
a rich history in chess
there has only been one world
championship that took place on French
soil name that match
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes we can discuss it on
[Music]
the first game of the 2021 video World
Championship in one minute
foreign
lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready
yeah I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in a free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
thank you
[Music]
as we went to the break there you all
saw today's trivia question let me
remind you how to play all you got to do
is quote tweet the trivia question from
the official chess.com Twitter account
with the answer if you are among the
first to do so you will win a one year
not one month a one year Diamond
membership that thing is more and more
valuable by the day so play along with
us and quote tweet your answer for a
chance to win a lot of you gave us your
answers in regards to who you thought
was going to win our our percentages
were 59
Magnus wins in the chat 11 draw and over
on chess.com events though it was it was
actually closer uh to to the rough coin
flip we have 38 thought Magnus was going
to win 54 of you thinking a draw I think
we're gonna as we get into the potential
for decisive results guys we're going to
start seating seeing that vote chess
competition at chess.com events Whittle
down to only a few people in contention
for those several thousands of dollars
right now Magnus is still on the clock
after B5 Robert and uh you called B5
maybe the best move Yonder Palm Nashi
has played in the World Championship
thus far so it's a great understanding
of the position he's not allowing
himself to get in the bind that Magnus
Carlson thrives in and so he's forcing
Magnus to come up with moves here and
we've been talking about these
variations Knight C4 to E5 eventually
bring that back to D3 I think those make
sense but even once you visualize that
position where to go to next is not that
easy for Magnus so I think is a great
move practically speaking by yawn he is
not going to struggle without a fight of
his own so I'm really kind of happy to
see the move B5 I think Jan showing
great understanding of the current
position
yeah I think b-power is an excellent
move and obviously Magnus is not very
pleased at the moment he's spending a
lot of time I think that he will decide
on move Knight C to E5 because other
moves simply don't look very promising
for him
and so I think it's very likely that at
least the next three moves will be
Knight C to E5 Knight B4 and queen to B2
I think that is
um almost not it's not a certainty for
sure but it's something that we can
comfortably predict and
after that I was actually thinking about
the line that we that Robert suggested
first and that we were considering a bit
ID five night before Queen B2 Bishop B7
is by far the most natural move A3 is
not forced but the 914 is super annoying
and black will not voluntarily leave
that square with the Knight so probably
why will at some point have to kick that
Knight back and
Knight B to D5 is is the first moment
when I think black has a very
um difficult choice because Knight C6
also just trying to trade off some
pieces
then ion D5 looks very good but it's
also vulnerable to at some point an E4
uh push kicking it away so black might
also consider
trading off Knights uh we're Knight to
C6 which looks like you lost some time
but on the other hand did you really
lose time that night uh spent too much
to get to the same square on the other
hand wide played A3 and queen B2 with
those two moves and those moves aren't
particularly
um
particularly useful let's say my client
made a groundhog day reference and
you're asking did you really lose time
this is getting philosophically
complicated well we have Knights C to E5
so it might be about to get concretely
complicated here uh if we get the
variations you guys have been predicting
it as you said Robert it's anybody's
game and it's going to be a real
real maneuvering battle which I'm
excited for I think it'll be interesting
to see I'm just wondering what took
Magnus so long to play that yeah because
it was the most natural move
and Knight back to d2s Fabiano
highlighted earlier it doesn't feel like
it's you're taking a step in the right
direction retreating you're not you know
you may have some ideas later in the
game but does feel like black should be
happy to see that move so nice to see
the E5 felt like the intuitive response
but maybe there were other options that
Magnus was exploring I mean we can't
discount even moves like Knight to A3 we
wouldn't talk about it but Knight to A3
which is a very weird looking move the
points the C file has all sorts of
issues here and okay clearly it doesn't
work out but I'm trying to get into
magnus's head I'm doing a bad job well I
think also sometimes you know when
you're in that position you're not just
calculating of course nice cd5 but maybe
trying to go as deeply down the rabbit
hole as you can before committing to it
but I I agree the magnus's time
management started out fantastic but
ever since Knight bd2 was met by Knight
C6 it's been rather curious well I think
that's a good point that you just made
because
we wonder why he's spending time but
even though we know that this is the
most natural move and he he it's the
first move he considers very often the
most natural move is not the best one
and if you rush through these decisions
sometimes not in this case but sometimes
you will miss better moves which are not
uh not quite the most natural right and
the time he spends here is going to be
useful later on because he's calculating
through lines that will happen when he
calculates nice cd5 he is looking
through the variation in which
um which we're starting to see on the
board and that will save him time later
on so this time is not wasted just
because he used it on a move where maybe
it seems like an obvious decision and
concretely in the line that we were
considering Queen B2 Bishop to B7 A3 and
Knight B to D5 not force move I should
mention again but let's just say that he
does this Knight to D3 at Bishop to B6 I
was thinking about a move here which
looks interesting we were mentioning
Bishop to G5 Knight to D4 Brews like
that but I'm wondering about the move A4
he has a b takes A4
group takes A4
that E4 move is a threat and if let's
say black plays Rook a to C8 now to
threaten Knight C3 potentially
Bishop to D2 covers that nicely and
again black no longer has Knight to E4
here because of the Rook that Rook on A4
is actually a fantastic piece and
although this might be seem a bit crazy
imagine black plays Bishop C6 here I
want to show these lines yeah go ahead
I'm thinking Rook to H4 is potentially a
very dangerous Rook there
it looks like Rook still belong on uh on
H4 but that's an attacking piece
especially if ideas like E4 are to
follow maybe both Knights are kicked
from the King side and who knows how
quickly the white Army might might start
attacking over here so this could get
double edged yeah and the Queen and Rook
on E7 f8 if the bishop gets the A3 f8
diagonal and E4 kicks the Knight away so
you can play Bishop B4 next there are
many tactical threats here in the
position so this A4 move is really nice
honestly for white and we're probably
going to recommend it because you're
also turning A5 to kick the bishop off
its very strong diagonal and black and
play A6 to clear more room in the
diagonals of A5 Bishop goes back to A7
that's safe and sound and if you trade
on B5 well it's just a pawn trade
doesn't seem to be the end of the world
uh for black but you are putting
decisions into Black's hands and some of
them may not be so simple yeah I think
A6 is probably the likely response but I
really love that idea of of just how
effective a rook along the fourth rank
might be in a in a surprise way yeah I
think AC 6 might be keeping the position
pretty much equal and probably maybe B
takes A4 is also equal but A6 feels like
a safer option is why you don't want to
give your opponent all the fun yeah at
an active Rook on A4 that could swing to
the king's side right even if it doesn't
at least it's performing a useful
function and stopping Knight to E4 and
preparing E4 so if we see A4 in this
position
then I think we'll very likely see A6 in
response the other move which I was
considering and actually I can do this
with the inclusion of a46 or the move
before is Knight F to E5
that I just looks pretty pretty good
there it also stops Knight to E4 so I
can play Bishop D2 and although I don't
think E4 is really a threat it could be
a threat one day especially in
conjunction with Bishop to D2 E4 Bishop
to B4 exploiting that skewer of the
queen and Rook on E7 f8 so Knight ft5
also a very natural move
um
I don't know what black will do in
response maybe Rook F to d8 that looks
like a good response just you know
putting the Rook on an open line and
also why it's not on F3 was defending D4
now it's no longer defending D4 right
one day you might see a D4 tactic yeah
Knight C3 actually could be you know a
move for black in the near future let's
say white plays H3 some kind of random
move like ideas with Knight C3 are
possible in many positions because it's
Bishop D4 tactics right so you just have
to keep an eye out on these things in
such a position but yeah that looks very
reasonable for black and it goes back to
your earlier Point Fabiano that Knight
B4 to D5 after A3 right that's move
seems very sensible you bring your
knight to the most advanced retreating
Square possible but Knight C6 as well
because now you're not allowing both the
white size one firmly entrenched on D3
the other coming to E5 and so both those
moves have their appeal and that's why
oftentimes these top players you know
Jan and Magnus both here spend this time
and they're trying to figure out which
will allow my defense to be easier which
will give me more chances to try to play
for a win so these decisions are not
easy even if both of them or maybe
especially because both of them have the
same evaluation and the players are
using their internal evaluation function
their brains and is that the internal
email bar in your brain exactly even
with the eval bar live on the screen two
options that both say zeros or maybe
like 0.1 better for white whatever it is
how do you choose between them they're
both equal right they're both level
positions but they have very different
Dynamics
not just a hat rack it's an eternal
email bar sometimes if you have two
moves like that and you can't really
decide between them because they look
roughly equivalent you can think what
would my opponent rather see rather see
and I think that Magnus would actually
rather see Knight B to D5 because it
allows him uh more options after Knight
to D3 Bishop to B6 we already saw A4
Knight up to E5 these looked like
interesting moves after Knight C6
white doesn't really want the trade of
knights because that would pretty much
liquidate any potential Advantage like
Knight takes C6 Bishop takes C6 I don't
think white is playing for anything here
it's going to be equal but that's that's
the best that white will have no longer
any tactics on the C file of course
because the queen is removed from that
file and we see a bishop E7 is already
on the board so we'll keep analyzing
because we are probably
right on track here as they're about to
get the lines we're anticipating and
after Knight C6 if white plays Knight D3
Bishop to B6 I have a feeling tonight is
slightly better on C6 than D5 it doesn't
get hit by E4 and black has a very
simple plan here knight uh Rook a to d8
or we're gonna have to d8 potentially
and then Knight to D4
not only trading all the knights but it
would be very difficult to capture on D4
because it would open up pins the skewer
again on the queen on B2 and work on A1
so
here it seems like black has a slightly
easier plan while with the Knight on D5
he has to worry about that E4 coming at
some moment which he would rather not
allow his pieces to get pushed back like
that
what we see A3 has been played so you
guys continue to play the role of of a
prophet here looking into that crystal
ball
Magnus continues to uh to work hard at
the board
even when it's not his turn
yeah I mean
the more I think about it the more I
like Knight C6 because there's this
notion of Superfluous Knights right when
Knights are competing for the same
squares ideally for black you get one
night to D5 one Knight to E4 but as
we've been discussing White's not just
going to allow that and so I do think
Knight C6 gives black a little bit more
freedom because it doesn't give white as
much flexibility so I do agree with
Fabiano that even though Knight bdd5
feels like the the blitz chest reply let
me get my knight to the most advanced
Square possible
I think Knight C6 actually makes Black's
life easier yeah I think this is also a
bit of a psychological thing we don't
like to move pieces back to where they
just came from it feels like we're going
we're not making progress or even we're
we're regressing but sometimes
pieces going back to their the squares
that they came from in this case two
moves ago is not a bad thing and
although Knight bd5 looks like progress
and the long term it might actually turn
into getting pushback because the E4 is
coming counterproductive when your
pieces are on squares especially when
they can't hold those squares right or
they're not controlling or preventing
your opponent's desires so yeah it's for
sure that being said live btd5 looks
like a perfectly legitimate move too and
Freon I think this isn't a moment he
needs to take too much time on because
both of his options look like good ones
and the main thing is they're going to
have difficult decisions at some point
in this game and they do have a slightly
unforgiving time control yeah no
increment means that time trouble could
be disastrous yep so when you have these
moments which with roughly equivalent
options maybe it's better to save your
time and energy for the moments later on
which will be more critical I love that
advice was given to me once by Gregor
kaidanov when I was struggling with time
management in a period getting my self
and time pressure he said well unless
the move you're about to make is the
losing blunder then you probably haven't
reached the critical position yet so
just make a move and keep some time on
the clock for that critical position
it's good advice yep and in this
position I think maybe the distinction
is that one can lead to a quicker path
to equality whereas one leaves it more
ambiguous I think Knight B25 keeps the
position more ambiguous and Knight C6
makes it so that we're already
threatening to trade off a bunch of
pieces if those trades happen we know
that for a fact the position should be
level whereas if all four minor pieces
remain that's where it becomes a
struggle where both sides have chances
and that's good right for a combative
game but on the other side we've seen
the players sort of try to minimize risk
especially young with the black pieces
yep coming into today he had already had
three whites to Magnus two maximum
Advantage having the first move is an
edge we know that's statistically
speaking and so if he says my goal today
a was a come in just play solid chess
this isn't a position where he needs to
risk anything because it is a solid
position for both so if Knight C6 he
sees that that direct plan is five and
we're saying Rook d8 Knight D4 let's
trade a bunch of stuff I think that is
the best plan for Yan today
well I think that Magnus was hoping to
put serious pressure on you on today
um he he had an interesting idea but
something went a bit wrong in his
preparation he shouldn't have been
surprised in at the moment that he was
surprised and although we can't speak
yet about the result of the opening
because it's still in the opening phase
and neither side has made a mistake or
made a some sort of brilliancy that that
has led to an advantage or change in
evaluation so so we're still waiting
let's say to see the end result of the
opening I think though we're all hoping
and I don't know if I can speak for all
of them for chat Howard you to do so but
I think we're all hoping for Knight B to
D5 because that will keep more pieces on
the board right and we all want to see
although it feels like this is a
position which could potentially get
simplified and become a bit less uh
exciting for the moment all the pieces
are on the board right except for two
poems which means that there's a lot to
play for here to be fair Knight to C6
doesn't have to be met with an exchange
if we bring up the analysis for it
obviously as all the points you guys
made fantastic and I'm leaning your way
as well that it feels like Knight C6
from yawn's point of view uh with the
black pieces makes sense to offer the
liquidation but white white can play
other moves here not not just maybe the
idea of retreating which I agree doesn't
optically look as good as it did with
the Knight on D5 but you could also
develop the bishop and leave the tension
if uh never mind never mind you don't
want to do that so that might be a good
move but we will see a lot of trades in
the center okay although the movie you
just points out Bishop's at four okay
has an idea that after Knight takes E5
the bishop on E5 is super annoying okay
maybe it's not something I was worried
about some 9h5 idea or something to hit
the bishop but maybe yeah Knight H5
could be but again white uh White can
move that Bishop to another Square for
example uh White can take on C6 and then
play Bishop to E5 oh yeah or there are
moves like Bishop to G5 so Knight H5 is
a bit of a responsible decision moving
the Knight away from the action okay
just to move the White's Bishop to a
potentially better Square because E5
might actually be a better Square than
F4 and if you're going for that sort of
approach maybe Knight D5 is a um a more
natural way of doing it because the
Knight feels better on D5 rather than on
H5
okay so maybe you just made my point but
better my point was white doesn't have
to
go for the forcing exchanges whether
it's Bishop F4 whether it's again Knight
D3 some moves are are available for
white to build on this tension rather
than break it
Robert yeah I mean Bishop report is an
interesting choice right because it does
once again Ask black to figure out the
resulting position but I'm still
thinking that Knight C6 makes Black's
life easier because they're already
pieces staring at each other and even if
we go forward in that position right
Bishop F4 Knight E5 Bishop E5 Knight E5
sorry yeah yeah here Bishop B5 oh white
doesn't really have a threat because if
you take an F6 yes black gets double
pawns but you get the bishop pair and
blacks moves Rook d8 Rook C8 these are
all quite logical and natural moves and
if you move your Rook away from F1 maybe
there's a timely Knight G4 right and so
I think black's moves are pretty
consistent in such a position whereas
with the Knight on D5 and that potential
is five minutes for E4 fewer trades
happening that leaves it a little bit
more difficult for blackened these
decisions right they actually change the
entire game where
on one hand the evaluation bar Still
Remains level I just really firmly
believe and you know I mean I don't
often take a super strong stance but
here I'm taking a very strong stanza
Knight C6 will make Yan's life a bit
easier than playing Knight D5 and
there's a reason he's spending what like
the last seven minutes he's been sitting
and thinking because he knows that while
it's not critical in the sense that
there's Checkmate coming up he and there
we see it as we say it I think I'm very
impressed by the way Jan has played this
game we're only 14 moves in it doesn't
look anything special for people who are
saying there's been no change in the
scent upon evaluation right he's made it
so that there's no change incentive
conversation so many decisions were
quite hard B5 in particular not taking
that pawn on B3 before getting to the
moment of B5 and then here retreating
the Knights of C6 all very instructive
very well played and as we see in
magnus's face he's like where am I gonna
get an advance he's digging deep
but good luck when you're playing yawn
to promise you in this kind of form
yeah I I feel like the opening it seems
like a success for you on
um now they've
you know sort of equalized or close to
it on time yep uh that's a good sign for
you on the position is roughly level uh
that doesn't mean so much because a
roughly level position
can turn into an advantage for either
side potentially
um and I think that Magnus knew going
into this that the lining plate is not
objectively better for white for sure
but he probably was hoping that Jan
would have more difficult decisions to
make and that B5 move is yeah it was an
excellent one for sure it from an
objective point of view solve all
Black's opening problems I think that
we're going to see an ID3 here though if
white if Magnus doesn't play Knight T3 I
don't imagine any sort of Hope for an
advantage for him right at least you
keep that Knight on D3 and importantly
the Knight on C6 is at least still
blocking the bishop 1 B7 you'd rather
keep the Knight there rather than trade
it off for a piece which doesn't block
any Bureau like the Knight on D3 is
simply a good piece it doesn't get in
the way of any white avoids pieces it
also gains a tempo right in a sense
because black doesn't want to give up
that bishop or trade off that Bishop on
C5 for the Knight on D3 that would lead
to a two Bishop's Advantage we saw the
importance of that two Bishop's
Advantage even for a pawn in the first
game yep uh Magnus obviously values the
two Bishops so don't give it to him for
free and I think we'll very likely see
Bishop to B6 there let's let's look at
Knight D3 and because I want to come
back to the idea you mentioned earlier
which
it not as effective as it potentially
was when the night was on D5 but what
about your A4 idea again is this still
something to consider obviously it
doesn't threaten A5 in the same way
because the night Bishop are here but
the other points to the move in regards
to gaining a little bit of potential
space adding some tension The Exchange
here of course would bring the Rook to
maybe an even more dangerous spot now
that the knight's not on D5
maybe this is this is a plan Magnus can
go for although I wonder if black can
ignore it and play with like Rook to d8
because that's a rook say fdh it's gonna
give me it takes B5 Knight D4 you can't
take my knight on D4 because then I
skewer your queen in your Rook with the
bishop and otherwise I could take back
on B5 I'm threatening to take on F3
which would win a piece well Robert one
small tactic yes uh White could actually
uh take on D4 it's true uh Bishop takes
D4 and queen A3
and white is upon up it might be very
close to level anyway because it was
double pawns and and the bottom B5 is
going to be tough to defend for white
right but it's something to consider uh
White does keep the pawn at least
momentarily here but this is an
interesting idea because black is
interested in concrete play
um he's he's happy to force the
situation not rather than play a long
game and we've seen this uh as an
intention of young in some of the games
that he goes for Concrete Solutions
rather than playing a slow maneuvering
game against Magnus uh we have action
and we do have Knight T3 have Knight to
D3 Bishop B6 and I think A4
is the most natural maybe maybe even the
best move for white
um at least you give that decision to
Black because I think V takes A4 work
takes A4 is a slight Improvement for
White's position yep it's not a
structural Improvement but it's a piece
activity Improvement that work on A4 is
developed without having to move any
wise pieces out of the way it's just
developed on not a starting square but
basically
um on right I swear that you normally
don't develop books to right you
normally expect you play like Rook ac1
Rook ad1 you don't expect the Rook is
developed via A4
although I respect that Rook lift so
much that I I don't want to allow the
activity so that's why I'm still
sticking with that Rook d8 move I really
believe that if you know you put on your
calculation cap that this position even
with Queen to A3 black and play Queen D7
perhaps and just say I'm not going to
trade queens and your Rooks under attack
B5 is hanging with trade light Square
Bishops and it seems like we're just in
a level position we both will have Five
Pawns remaining two minor pieces and I
think that if yon could find a way that
he doesn't have to have questions
remaining he'll go for that and this
seems to be a variation that succeeds
unlike you I left my calculation cap at
home I didn't want it to mess with my
hair did so
um your thoughts Bob well your hair is
looking your hair looks good you're
looking fresh thanks Jenny
besides that I just wanted to go a bit
deeper into the variation we were just
looking at
talking about Robert all right 19th
Freight played go ahead go ahead Bob so
in the final position we just saw
Bishop b7a4 Robert's line of Rook d8
okay 94. you're looking so good man all
right Queen A3 Queen D7 I I mean I I
totally agree that this is equalizing
for black and it's probably the best
approach for Block after A4 but we
should consider the line a bit longer
just to see what John has to calculate a
bit Knight C5 here is a move
and now black should play Bishop takes
C5 Queen takes C5 so white still keeps
that pawn for the moment but after
Bishop takes G2 King shakes G2 Queen to
B7 probably among other moves
I was gonna point out that maybe even
the end game is fine I know there's B6
there the Acron spin okay there might be
multiple ways to game I'll show my
brother because Robert looked at me and
he I need to I just for the for everyone
else you know
maybe Queen to B7 is not even the most
accurate because of Queen C6 I I just
noticed but there there's probably a
very
um very concrete way of getting that
pawn back and simplifying to a position
where
you know the minor pieces have been
traded off the a pawn is a bit weak but
the B3 Pawn will also be weak yeah so we
might see a roughly level position here
but I think Queen to B7 is not isn't the
right move
um can you just go over V8 Rook D to B8
yeah yeah that that will get the phone
oh maybe there's B6 actually Queen for
two rows B6 Queen to B7 yeah you give a
check first I'm still wondering is there
Queen to C6
what a weird move can't take with the
Rook cause A8 hangs can't take with the
queen because the past pollen remains
well you can and you can take on B3 but
the that's C Pawn that c Pawn looks
dangerous yeah so oh and you know what
if you Queen B7 which is like I'm just
gonna try to win that pawn you might
have like Rook A5 and just yeah hold on
to that pawn for dear life
you know this uh potential of a past
seep on reminds me of a dream that
Fabiano had last night you want to share
with the with the chat tell us how deep
down this commentary Rabbit Hole you are
normally I I don't dream about Chess but
last night I had a chest dream and it
was about this game
and my dream my dream
Jan won okay and the way he won was I
don't know why I laughed at that but
okay
Magnus simplified to a King and Pawn
andina and it was like white has King on
C4
um in the dream for some reason Jan was
white yeah but let's ignore that
why the King on C4 black had like a king
on A8 and white had Pawn A2 and Magnus
was like all right to draw it's a draw
but then Jan played the move A2 to B3
and Magnus looked surprised but he was
like okay I played King to B7 and then
Jan played B2 to C3
I just moved up on over
um it wasn't exactly like that I just
realized that that what I just described
was the draw but in any case Jan moved
his Pawn from the a file to the C file
and Magnus suddenly looked really upset
and surprised and he just resigned his
analysis we're going where did this Pawn
go it went from the a file to the C file
which is why I Remember by the way when
you pick up your your fellow
commentators at about 3 50 a.m these are
the things we talk about hey Bobby how'd
it go well I had a weird dream last
night so all right Robert go ahead get
us back to the chest no I got nothing
for you you know you've already made a
clear you just want to talk to Fabiano
okay I'm just gonna sit here style name
you know I've uh been trying to predict
the moves yeah I called some of it and
you're doing great honestly you've been
you've been all over it
and you've been complimentary of yawn
and his aggressive play honestly because
in game two when he did have that
advantage and he said in the press
conference I was afraid of some things
and and that made me worried for his
overall chances because you can't play
Afraid against Thomas Carlson right but
here he's showing that he's not scared
he entered an opening that he wasn't
prepared for and yet that's what happens
when they're super Grand Masters at play
they can find amazing moves over the
board and B5 shocked all of us and
Yasser Saron was there calling for B5
but it's really a strategically
counter-intuitive move when there's a
bishop on G2 staring down the length of
diagonal to play that that's really
impressive stuff and then he goes Knight
C6 of the retreat and it's not just
because I've been advocating for the
move I think he's really making sure
that his life is not going to be
tremendously difficult and
we're at a position where Magnus is the
one struggling to find any semblance of
an edge
yeah if you're just tuning in we'll
bring up the second board real quick
just to show the critical moves that
Robert uh was just talking about it was
this move 11b5 that was played by yawn
that again was called for and called
counter-intuitive by Grand Master Yasser
sarawan in chat and he was correct
Robert called it maybe the best move Jan
has played at this point in the world
championship and from here on out it's
been all the best moves that Fabiano and
Hess have been predicting and uh and
Jan's been finding them has himself in a
yet another like Bobby you said it's too
early to call this an opening win yet
for for Yan and his team but are you
ready to say now that Black is Black
clearly did fine after the first stage
yeah I think we can comfortably say that
Jan did very well in the opening
um mostly through good play because I
don't think that he was ready for this
line yeah but Knight C6 B5 these were
both good decisions and good moves and
even nice E6 earlier in fact I should
mention that you're right because the
novelty from Magnus was this Pawn
sacrifice for those who just tuned in
but John said no thank you just let the
poem be taken back and then B5 so yeah
go ahead yeah I think it's important
that they're not only good moves because
C takes B3 we might say is also a good
move because right it doesn't lead to a
bad position for black right likely but
Knight C6 is a good decision
because it takes the game into a
position which Jan can more easily
calculate and we know that he he planned
B5 in advance when he played Knight C6
he thought a lot about Knight C6 not so
much about B5 right so so he he had this
in mind and he knew that it was and look
at the time he spent on all the moves
after that he played extremely quickly
nothing so he was ready uh everything
was was planned in advance when he
played this Knight C6 move
um now we see Magnus playing rather
quickly Bishop to G5 which
the first indication is that he's ready
to give up the bishop pair to slightly
damage black structure for example H6
here
um oh Rook dates already been played you
haven't played too quickly for me to
even analyze and now after Rook d8 with
the same line you could we'll just go
for the line you were saying yeah if
white plays professional six here which
I think is
maybe a bit premature we have an ending
where black has a bishop error uh but
has a slightly damaged structure on the
king side not a huge not it's not a huge
um
uh Pawn weakness these double pawns on
F7 F6 but it's slightly worse in fact if
we were to take all the pieces off the
board being a king and pawn indeed this
can get rather dangerous because White's
King can March from G1 up to H5 H6 and
that hole was created by the double F
pawns and we we actually seen that in in
some famous examples that King and pawn
endings were won with that King marching
up the board like that of course now
we're talking
pretty much a fantasy variation because
way way into the future when all the
pieces are traded off and this specific
instance uh black is of course doing
fine but White's goal
here is to trade Bishops like as a
bishop pair white would love to get
those lights for Bishops off the board
so the way to do that is to play for
example Knight to D2 opening up that
diagonal and then hoping someday to
trade those Bishops problem is of course
well first of all the bishop trade
doesn't necessarily mean why it's better
and also black doesn't have to trade the
Bishops for the moment
and something I was going to say is when
you have the bishop parrot and it's five
minutes indicating you want to trade off
the light Square Bishops but what
remains behind in Black's position is
because the pawns on B5 some of those
light squares that D3 Knight in
particular can jump into moreover the
Knight on D3 is very hard to dislodge if
you are left with a dark Square Bishop
because you can't attack it so the
Knight on D3 it's seen in actually a
number of Catalan positions and it's a
very strong piece it blocks the default
from The Rook on d8 it um you know
covers many important squares and it can
still jump forward later including a
score like C5 you can play Rook C1
Knight C5 and so on to try to go after
that pawn on B5 and some of the looser
squares so I'm not saying that white is
better because I don't believe that to
be the case but there is some long-term
potential with the Knight against the
bishop and you know Bishop G5 Rook d8
quite quite quickly by Young I've used
to go back to this position if Bishop F6
it's not the question that young keeps
the Queens on the board and plays G
takes F6 because now C5 is already
covered maybe with the Queens on the
board white could potentially have some
excuse me black enough kind of attack
and white is not attacking Black's King
you know pieces over there yeah and so
it does seem like a position where
instead of just saying I will trade
Queens because I know I can hold the
balance maybe I can play for a little
bit of something that's a fascinating
Point Robert that to me is such a modern
modern way to play the position normally
you would think opening your own King
you have to get the Queens off the board
but assessing the concrete position of
all the pieces white white is in no
position here to attack the black king
and keeping the Queens on the board as
the evil eval bar agrees probably
definitely a little bit better than
taking them off actually going going a
bit deeper into this variation because I
think gf6 is an excellent move
um and the main problem is of course the
queen on B2
is sort of like where do you put that
Queen black right now is threatening
Knight to D4 exploiting the that Queen's
awkward position with the Rook 91 and I
was wondering why do I plays Queen to D2
oh you're gonna say Dan you are wrong
trying to get into H6 at first I thought
well E5 here
that's really scary for white because E4
is coming now Queen to H6 uh E4
I like that before
I don't think Knight H4 I'm not sure if
it works there is not H6 at the end of
that line maybe that might also work
okay we'll do your lines
okay maybe not to H4 was was a better
option maybe my maybe my idea was better
yeah the whole point everyone at the end
of these lines is we'll just highlight
Bobby's pointing out that there are
positions like this where perhaps
there's a little more than meets the eye
to that open King okay so and just a
funny Checkmate if we continue that
final position okay just for uh
Knight to H4 just for two more moves
Just for kicks and Giggles Queen F6 H5
black deals with the threat of the
threat of Knight H6 or Knight H6 that's
what he thinks King H7 Bishop to E4 and
that's a rather funny mate
um not when you see various
not one that Jan wants to see
but uh black is not obligated to play E5
of course after Queen to D2 black might
have simply King to G7 for example
just stop being that Queen to age six
booth looks quite sensible
um the good thing for for black and I
think Jan knows this and it makes his
decision make it easier is that he knows
he has a wide choice on every move of
good options that means that he can't
really make very serious mistakes
so if he plays natural moves he he knows
that these are almost like the decision
between gf6 and queen F6 he probably
knows that both of those moves are going
to be roughly equal which actually
um eases his decision-making process
and I think one important thing is
whenever black plays E5 with those
doubled f-pawns you give that F5 Square
which is what we've just been looking at
so E5 is a move that black doesn't play
lightly because now the the square in
front of double Pawn which is usually
the case right if there are double pawns
the square in front of the double Pawn
is really important to keep defended and
that's why E5 is a very risky move
because your Bishop on B7 will not be
able to reroute to cover that square and
that could be a disaster so I I do think
that it looks like we have Bishop takes
F6 by the way is it oh yeah he's already
played okay there we go Bishop takes up
six I did not see that
how long would you spend if you were
young here
I would probably spend some time
um my first instinct would be Queen
takes F6
and then after Queen takes Pawn takes I
would think the movie mentioned Rook
adc1 or maybe Rook out to C1
um is is probably the only real real
idea I would consider for white
and
after let's say Rook agency one let's
just try that that Rook
um Knight A5 it looks like it attacks a
pawn but then Knights D2 this idea we
already saw
would both depend upon and trade Bishop
so this looks like a decent outcome for
white but after Rook a to C1 I would
think that black is fairly comfortable
playing simply Rook a to C8
and what's the point where adc1 was sort
of preparing Knight C5
but if we do it now
black takes two Bishops are gone but
tactical considerations are more
important Knight to D4
and if work takes C8 Knight takes E2 uh
Intermezzo check winning a pawn and
black is probably winning the game so
white can't play Knight to C5
which means of course white has other
moves
um even maybe a move like B4 is not a
bad one
but most likely black is doing
completely fine here and equalizing
comfortably so for yawn this is actually
an interesting moment he he knows queen
of six is pretty much equalizing and
also the safest option and G takes F6 is
probably also okay but it's a very sharp
option uh so this is an interesting
moment I I would suspect he will choose
Queen takes F6 because
well
it's you know it's a world championship
match and you you might shy away from
the super aggressive options when you're
playing with the black pieces I don't
know the way he's played this game so
far
I really like how he's using his time
Knight C6 really important moment to
retreat that night which Square to go to
here you could play Queen takes F6 he
knows he's not worth there Jan could
just play it and they'll say all right
I'll be all right I'll probably be able
to hold but the fact that he's thinking
here shows a willingness to compete for
a win even at the cost of exposing your
king side wearing double pawns risking
an attack that white can build up so
even if he does not play G takes F6 I
like that he's digging deep and thinking
about it this really has been the most
impressive game Jan has played and the
engine evaluation bar will not show that
compared to game two we often use that
as uh the quickest way to see how well
somebody played oh Jan had this big
advantage in game two but that really
wasn't his own doing so much as magnus's
misstep yeah whereas here this has been
good move after good move for yonda
palmistry and I feel like honestly in
previous days I've been a little bit
harsh onion because he's had good
positions but has not been able to
actually take advantage of them and
Magnus said as much he's like preparing
well but then he's not making the most
of it right here I feel like he was in a
very tricky spot after this Pawn
sacrificed by Magnus he's handled
everything with care and now we're at
this critical moment where he can just
play Queen F6 get those Queens off the
board you know just say all right we got
this liquidation or he could take with
the pawn and we'll see if he wants that
fight I wouldn't blame him if he just
trades Queens he came in this game
Thinking let me just neutralize not
necessarily let me win but he realizes
that this is a moment where if he's
really feeling the position
he could take with that pawn leave the
Queens on and now we have it being
anybody's game
I'm on the edge of my seat here I I
agree with Fabi that the more likely
result or the more likely move here is
Queen takes F6 but I wonder what Chad
thinks if we can throw up a poll we are
going to find out what chat has in store
for Fabiano and ifan here because right
here at the end of this break hoey fun
four-time women's world champion is
going to join us subscribers will have
an opportunity for their questions to be
answered by Fabiano Annie Hess is going
to take a quick break he's working hard
over there and so we're going to let him
take a quick break but ifan is about to
step into the studio with Fabiano so
again subscribers give us your questions
keep them good whether you're on YouTube
or twitch let us know if you have any
thoughtful thoughtful things that you
would like Fabiano or ifan to answer to
and we will get to those questions right
at the top of the break it's chess.com's
coverage of day six from the 2021 video
World Chess Championship it's brought to
you by coinbase and we just had G takes
F6 played on the board don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
guys I was here Robert
is here no way it's here dude hold on
hold on
and boom
we did it yeah baby it is the world Hess
Championship
that's what I'm talking about this one
has the copyright C what is that Danny
but you get it look at it look at it
you'll see you'll see here there's a few
others
here I want that one you see it Bobby
you get it now you see it no I have no
idea what no his face there's missing
C's all right
Robert you want to explain it you know
my name the game you play It's called
chess right and there's no word
Championship it's Championship so
there's a c you know
yeah yeah
no
I mean I think it's I think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this now I don't think
anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest you've ever
seen in my life
well holy
you think it's too late to send it back
I ordered a lot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we are back now joined by four-time
four-time women's world champion Holly
Fawn Fabiano caruana still with us
remind the subscribers right now that
your questions uh will be and will be
asked and answered to both both of these
wonderful commentators here today we're
looking for them now although we've got
a lot of just get into as well Yvonne
thank you for being with us and how
excited are you about what we have here
in game six
uh yeah I mean why is all this move G
takes F6 right before I joined I saw
that that's going to be a wild game I
mean relatively because uh at first I
was thinking that the little bit queen
of sex apply they will be more or less
in conversation but uh the more I look
at the position I realized GK F6 is a
very interesting but also a a very brave
Choice under the match yeah
back all the way back when when you were
the Challenger we know you were
obviously uh defended your title many
times but can you can you recall back at
all to the nerves of playing a move like
that a risky move when you had an option
of course to go for something that is
probably just equal but you uh you you
go for the Spice your choice perhaps
making a double-edged position you might
lose what is what is what are the
feelings that yawn will be feeling in a
in a game like this
well I think this movie is actually
making sense at the first we thought
that of course we want to trade up the
Queens uh but with the doctor Bishop on
board the one who I do not have the best
of the hair uh the king shouldn't be
that weekend right if we look at the uh
the the location of white pieces and
also the c39 is better placed in the end
game compared to Middle game it looks
like but uh unless there will be some
noise for Knight H5 in the future after
F5 but now black also keeps this
flexibility to push support E5 so GTX F6
maybe just like it looks scary but maybe
it's very very stable as your kc1 still
do not have the move like rock C4 right
so uh the Europe can also not maneuver
to the king side therefore maybe this is
just a move both
um let's say once in real game but also
May being able just wanted to avoid
those end games you know probably he
might might even worry for a slightly
worse a question from chat for both of
you peaceful nights wants to know would
you have played G takes F6 or would you
have played Queen takes F6 Bobby for you
oh it's difficult to say from the
sidelines you you really only come to
this decision after calculating
intensely at the board
and although we are calculating here we
don't have that same sort of intensity
not only of looking at the variations
but also of the decision-making process
because for us we have nothing on the
line sitting here so when we suggest
moves
we don't have to worry about the
potential result of the game
um I mean said I I understand G takes F6
and
um now that I see it more and more
I I think that it's a more attractive
Choice than Queen takes F6 because here
it feels like black can also take over
the initiative
and after Rook ADC one
uh it looks like black is kind of
spoiled for choice there's moves like
Knight to D4 looks like a very
interesting move because that A3 Pawn is
sort of hanging and there's also the
move well this is a very risky one but
there is a move E5 and I wonder what
Magnus has in mind there it's probably
going to be Knight H4 and we're going to
see a mess but from Beyond's point of
view it's not just about drawing if he
wins a game he will suddenly become a
favorite in this match
if on your thoughts on that would you
would you have also played G takes F6 or
or been happy for the end game
I just thought about Quan thanks F6 when
I see this position and also didn't
really think seriously about this GTX F6
um until I saw this move on the board
yeah so we seem to have a move on the
board uh Fabi mentioned that Jan was
spoiled for choice and he chooses Knight
to D4 we're pretty spoiled for Choice
with all the questions keep them coming
subscribers on Twitch subscribers on
YouTube I've got many I actually I'm
just going to say now we're probably not
going to get to all of these um but uh
please keep them coming Bobby your
thoughts on the uh the choice of Knight
T4 here well I think this is sort of
asking why to play Rook F to D1
because if Knight takes D4 Bishop takes
D4 White Queen will probably have to
place itself on a very sad looking
Square the A2 Square which might not be
bad white has some structural advantages
here long-term white has good chances
but short term black is way more active
so I think we're more likely to see the
move work F to D1 a trade on an F3 at
some point
also a bit damaging white structure but
still we could say that white has a
slightly Superior structure most likely
but it feels like black is doing
completely fine even here there's Bishop
D4 move that Queen has to go to to a
square doesn't really want to go to
because of the weakness of A3
um yeah I think Knight D4 was a good
move and neon is is doing doing
excellently at the moment
interesting stuff
I'm uh I'm almost a little I kind of
wanted even more of a spicy move like E5
Knight D4 does offer a little bit of
liquidation just feeling a little
nervous I certainly don't want all the
pieces to come off the board regardless
of the result but perhaps John feels
like Knight T4 is more of a two result
chance to kind of
really really ask white how he intends
to deal with this
yeah it looks like Jan is
he's playing ambitiously but he is not
taking a lot of chances in search for
the win let's say if he was in a must
win situation if he was down a point and
this was the last game of the match I
think we'd more likely see E5 than
Knight D4 so Knight D4 is
um sort of
in between ambition and safety
okay well let's uh we'll let it pause
for a second I'll give you guys some
rapid fire questions a fun one from
George jublina on YouTube wants to know
in a must-win situation would you ever
play The King's Gambit
well you find you take that one first
no
no
um King's Gambit so far I like this
thank you thank you George on YouTube
Bobby your answer I I also like to keep
my pawns for the most part at least on
the second move
so I think I would shy away from the
Kings again but but in one of the most
impressive Armageddon games I've seen
recently
um farooza was playing I think it was
young I think Frugal was playing yanden
palmushi in the arm and Norwood in
Norway yeah that's right yeah he played
the king's Gambit and he totally crushed
him it was over in like 20 moves so we
have we have exchanges now so you're
saying you can play The King's Gambit
under the right circumstances it can
work beautifully well as we saw
um
but yeah I don't know if that that would
be my choice interesting Knight takes D4
was magnus's choice and after Bishop
takes D4 Queen A2 this was sort of the
line you were predicting and uh
Jan is in control with the bishop pair
at least for now until the Bishops are
traded a very good Bishop on D4 as
compared to the Knight on D3 ifan you
made a really kind of offhand I think
instructional point that in the middle
game the Knight on D3 is not nearly as
good as it might be in an end game
because it it lacks squares if it goes
to other squares maybe it just gets
kicked around but now that the pieces
are being traded over the last few moves
your evaluation maybe changes a little
bit because this Knight on D3 should
more pieces come off it's going to have
decent options maybe to outplay the
bishop in the end game is that true
uh well actually you mentioned a very
good point that I was also thinking
about because after a few places has
been traded off the board and now I saw
the welder maybe Queen Knight who has
some very good uh coordination because
uh seeing this position suddenly
reminded me that I actually lost at
least one or maybe cover of similar
positions with black pieces like Queen
Bishop versus queen and knight
uh I don't remember exactly if the pawn
structure was like double F4 or even my
phone was on G file
when both of the Rooks were off the
board I felt like that when playing was
black I I faced a bit pressure
at some points as this bishop looks
active well if that's imagine why it put
his pawns on life squares what's this
bishop for but here the the black spaces
are more active and also the screen on
A2 is kind of stuck in here so maybe
some Queen B7 check and trying to uh
let's activate the pieces maybe that's a
different story it looks like more
pieces being traded here
it looks like Queen B7 is is a good
option okay at least you you know Wise
king would rather be in G2 than G1 so
you force white to put the King on a
slightly worse square and the queen is
very good on that diagonal
um I think at some point Magnus will
play A4 as as ifan mentioned the pawns
belong on the light squares and white
would like to get this C4 Square
potentially for The Rook so the trade of
Pawns would be good for white but black
might just respond with A6 and uh and
keep that pawn on B5 where it performs a
very important function stopping white
from taking some extra light squares of
Rook C4 so what's the line we're going
to look at here so Queen to B7 check
King G1
we might see an active move like Queen
to E4 even
it doesn't attack anything but it's just
sort of an active piece
and uh
yeah it's hard to say
maybe here
sorry which way did you suggest you
phone
Queen to D2
looks also like a sensible move yeah and
maybe King G7 yeah we might see some ah
but you're preparing maybe the queen
trade with Queen to F4 yes
yeah that was the original intention but
I'm not sure I mean actually I was
curious whether things like trading
coins would be in favor of white or not
but here would be
would be good for white yeah
but maybe black will play F5 Forest
white to trade
more circumstances
oh we have Queen B7 check
um or can we take
it
okay
yeah I think we'll say see King to G1
rather quickly
um I mean F3 is a move but
I don't think white wants to weaken the
king like that
maybe after Queenie for a while you
could try to double the record and see
the root to C2 is a
nice
looks like a good option
now the queen
but I'm wondering what do you do with
your Rooks on the C file because if
black at some point plays
let's say even if you invade with Rooks
to C7 black can always play Bishop to B6
to kick that Rook out
so I'm wondering even if black plays H5
here and just starts going for some King
side counter play you know I love that
here comes Alpha zero
it's funny because this is obviously not
a lot of pieces on the board but there
are some outside chances actually that
H4 could be a little dangerous for the
white king yeah especially because that
Queen on A2 is just so out of Play It's
like in a completely different Universe
the queen should be on G2 or somewhere
where it defends the King on the king
side
well critical moments building up here
in game six of the 2021 fideo World
Chess Championship Howie Fawn and
Fabiano caruana bringing us the Dual The
Duel commentary
actually I I like your suggestion uh
suggestion you found of Queen td2
because I really think that Queen is the
main factor for white the queen needs to
get away from its Exile on A2 yeah okay
so we go back to that by the way King G1
has now been played so we're on track
here
let's say queen E4 is played in the live
position by Jan Queen to D2 prepares
maybe Queen H4
and how to
yeah but the point is actually now if
after for example it's quick King G7
Queen foot maybe it doesn't work if so
what line are you saying King G7 here
um
King G7 oh sorry you can't do seven
having trouble hearing okay Rook D7 it's
actually funny to D7 specifically allows
Knight to C5 oh nice Fork because the
bishop is pinned
and if Queen to D5
if Queen to D5 E4 yeah Knight takes D7
would lose the queen so Bishop takes up
to discover check so you play E4 first
and the queen is defended followed by
capturing The Rook on D7 so very nice
stuff all right so no blunders there so
but King to G7 instead of seven queen of
four
well then Queen takes E2 is what ephon
mentioned okay this loses the pawn on E2
so why can't so can't quite so easily
play Queen to F4
thank you
yeah it's interesting
well Yawn is now thinking after the move
Kingda G1 interesting question from
twitch chat from dripman 13 wants to
know how much opening prep can the
players reasonably have in these sort of
obscure openings obviously Bobby I know
you commented at the start that players
are spending a lot of times these days
on these Sidelines but Yvonne I'll ask
you maybe in terms of opening
preparation how much time did you spend
on openings like this versus let's say
the mainline Catalan against your
opponents or did you spend a lot of time
anticipating Sidelines like Magnus
Carlson did today
um not really I mean to me
uh I think I spent most of the time and
attention to the main lines I'm not
talking about exactly the main lines
like most people are flying but the main
lines means that this move is more like
okay in a way more reasonable and even
some Sidelines let's say less people
play but less it's making sense but PS3
seems like just a kind of normal that
wants to reach a kind of structural
position and maybe this will uh let's
say switch back to the position we knew
right because later on after dcc4 is
just some catalog uh position so I think
that I wouldn't pay so much attention in
this kind of Sidelines because maybe
sooner or later it will reach to some
position you know so uh I mean if I have
more time of course I'm very happy to
study this but if the timer limited
maybe prefer to focus on some more and
the tricky lines let's say those lines
that you need to be very specific make a
concrete otherwise you might just get
into your opponent's preparation and
lose without or make a resort without
any interesting serious play uh oh we
saw Queen we now have Queen E4 on the
board so the line that has been
predicted by both of you is continuing
to uh
to come forward another interesting
question here from twitch Chad I'll ask
it to both of you because it was
directed at Fabiano but given that you
both played in World Championship
matches
house commentating on a world
championship match I know you're going
to say commentating is better than
playing in a world championship match
right no I'm definitely not gonna
okay
um so that being said
it's it's not it's bad it's not it's not
a close second
but it's still pretty good okay good
Yvonne how much are you enjoying
commentating versus uh versus when you
were playing in these in these World
Championship matches
uh wow it's different so and uh I would
say that I enjoyed pretty much to be one
of the commentators as that would also
like kind of force myself to really
follow the games otherwise probably I
would check maybe the next day or
whatever so it's a distance also to
discuss some ideas but you know maybe
when more commentating job you're doing
for example at that quite some recently
and you'll miss the following Emmanuel
so I thought that's maybe a kind of
balance would be good but I like I enjoy
the balls but uh nowadays when I play
less especially the ultimate events that
will be really missing the whole I know
I do back Monday well obviously I hope
that I'm commentating on world
championship matches that you're both
playing in the future I don't know your
plans on that ephon but I've got big
plans for Fabi in 2023. so you have big
plans I got big plans for you man all
right I can't wait to hear about it
you're going to be playing in the world
championship match
that does sound pretty good it does
sound pretty good and I'll be
commentating on it because obviously
you'll have invited me to be your second
and I'll have declined because I have
previous obligations that seems like a
very likely outcome okay we're teasing
but ifan what are your plans uh there
was a question earlier about I forget it
was from YouTube so I apologize I didn't
get your username about you balancing
your studies and your professional
career along with chess do you have any
plans to ever return to uh to competing
for the for the highest titles in chess
again
uh well just uh to continue with the
conversation you just had maybe I think
they're more likely that I might join
Danny to commentate to the next match
with uh with with Fabi let's say his
matches I think that's most likely than
I play let's say some well to be honest
I have no idea maybe or maybe knowledge
really depends but I didn't have any
let's say a very serious chess
tournaments for recent maybe one or two
years since last yeah I think my last
major one I mean a very serious one shot
back to uh 2018 tell us still probably
so that's just a comment from Max
headman in YouTube wants to give a
message to you how we fun I don't know
if you'll see this but your play has
been an inspiration for me over the
years thank you so much and it's awesome
having you commentate this match so some
love for you from YouTube epon
uh
that is great to know yeah is it more
likely that ifan returns to to winning
the Women's World Championship or that
Fabiana carwana chooses me as a second
let's have let's have chat vote on that
I'm not going to ask you to don't give
me that look Favi
all right we have Queen C2 so a little
bit more analysis before we let you go
we found Queen C2 played not the queen
to D2 idea initially suggested to trade
Queens but maybe a similar one and that
the queen does threaten to go to C6 in
some lens I think that the idea is to
trade Queens but not with Queen C6 I
think he'll he wants to move the Knight
I see possibly to F4 possibly to B4 but
he is looking for a trade of Queens uh
and black can does have ways to water
trade the Queens once the night moves
black queen can also move uh black has
another option which is to put the part
on F5 and then tell white well if you
want to trade Queens you have to put my
Pawns in the center to do so
yeah what's the line like that just to
show if something like this happened
maybe night to before yeah maybe bishop
move somewhere here it's hard to know
which diagonal I want because I kind of
want to keep this Square in mind I feel
like Bishop's a B6 because in the end
game the it's of course difficult to say
but
again something like this could be
advantageous for black white would not
probably not want to trade pawns because
this looks maybe it's not a big deal
this the structure but it takes away the
D3 Square from White Knight
so now after A5 for example the Knight
will get kicked to an uncomfortable
Square
okay Yvonne your thoughts on where this
game's gonna head here before we before
we let you go Queen C2 played maybe a
little bit harder for you to make a
prediction than previous games but not
just on the result give us a little bit
of insight in terms of how you feel uh
neponishi should maybe be approaching
this position as black to maintain
maintain some decent chances
well I think actually it might be a
critical moment because the black needs
to decide whether uh like the line that
Fabi just showed like F5 maintain this
or maybe there will be some other
interesting uh option like proxy 8
trying to uh convert the game to a
different stage which I thought that
white would would take on CA that is
Queen versus pair of rocks uh but the
good thing is like the Rocks commit
coordination with Knight wouldn't be
that dangerous and the black spaces are
uh let's say well placed there's Queen
E2 they're also like Mansion H5 H4 and
maybe F5 F4 like these kind of threats
and I think the F1 drug would need quite
some time to bring to the seventh
seventh Rank and parking F7 and also the
special could return to B6 defending the
square so I don't know if this could be
an option but this is a very let's say
uh let's say a critical decision because
it could be like a resort that's an
interesting Dynamic not something you
would first consider to invite a tuberex
for the queen exchange normally better
for the Rooks but this this idea of H5
H4 adds adds an unbalanced Dynamic here
right yeah I think this is uh one thing
and we've learned with our modern
understanding of just
is that even though numerically we
consider two Rooks more than a queen ten
versus nine uh points sometimes the
queen in open positions when it has a
lot of targets can be more powerful than
the two Rooks if they don't have open
lines if we imagine that White's two
Rooks were to be on the seventh rank C7
D7 this does not work out very well for
black because well Black's king would
get in trouble
but because White's works are rather
passive for the moment
and we'll find it hard to get active
uh black probably has his his fair share
of chances and and it actually seems
easier to find ideas for black rather
than white like you mentioned H5 some
some Pawn breaks or even played on the
queen side maybe A5 A4 things like that
so so this looks like a legit strategy
as well which is really interesting and
I like ephon's Point too that
the fact that this bishop can always
Retreat especially if you keep the
opponent A7 it's going to make it it's
going to make it rather hard that the
Rooks would ever get doubled on the
seventh rank right I don't see that
happening this is this is a really
interesting idea Yvonne I
I want to see it I hope we see Rook to
C8
for the unbalanced Dynamic of the queen
versus the two Brooks if not Rook FC if
not Rook ac-8 excuse me what other
options are there is H5 right away still
a possibility or at that point the night
the Knight removes itself from the
diagonal and offers the queen tried and
maybe maybe not what you want I think
that's sort of asking for Knight F4 yeah
it also puts a Target on the H5 Pawn
yeah so black probably doesn't want to
do that in this situation okay
uh the the funny thing is I'd have to
Rook a C8 white isn't really forced to
to take on C8 and white plays Queen D2
it feels like a lost tempo but maybe
white is happy to trade those Rooks off
yep
that's a good point yeah well
interesting moment give you guys the
last couple questions from chat let's
see another one from twitch despite
draws what's your favorite game in the
championship so far
if I'm what was your favorite game so
far
um
chosen between the I said last game and
game two probably
okay probably game two probably
uh I I don't want to be super critical
of the players they played really well
overall a very high quality chess
but there hasn't been much of note in
terms of outstanding ideas so I can't
really pick a favorite game yet okay
you're you're punting on it I like it
all right last question here another one
from from YouTube what would be more
like what would be a more likely way for
someone to be Magnus outplaying them in
a position in a positional game or out
calculating them in a technical game
uh sorry what was the question it's
right there on the uh I kind of misread
it a little bit I went to the school for
kids who don't read good
I'll let you read it
what would be more likely way that
someone can beat Magnus out playing in a
positional game
or out calculating him in a technical I
think technical is is meant to say a
complicated game uh you know a game
technical not necessarily the most
um accurate term
like so my from what I feel
is that the way
I won against Magnus was usually in Long
technical games which sounds a bit
surprising but
um the wins I remember against him were
were in slightly more technical fashion
okay
well what did it take to beat you if on
someone trying to outplay you in a
positional game or a technical game
uh wait there's a question being changed
say that again
what would you struggle more against
someone trying to outplay you in a long
positional maneuvering game or something
with a little more of a technical
accurate calculation battle
uh I'll play me or if you want to tell
play someone sorry I didn't get a point
sorry okay no because I always prefer
for this because there's something I
thought I didn't understand the meaning
of this this question okay uh well
unfortunately I've never been Magnus so
far so I don't think that I have this
credit to answer this question but I
could try to let's say uh make a
conclusion from the games I've played
with him especially the uh let's say the
last games uh I think most of the games
I lost due to this long-end game with
very uh accurate and the subtle play so
I guess if uh try to avoid that kind of
position then might get more chances so
uh get back to that question should also
be something like more complicated ones
there you go uh we have A5 played on the
board and so the the chances for for
yawn remain we won't get a two Rook for
the queen offering but it looks like
there's still plenty of life ahead
Yvonne we're gonna we're gonna to let
you go and and say thanks again for
joining us we'll obviously see you
tomorrow
for uh for game seven hopefully in
another complicated battle and uh we
appreciate your time
all right great thank you
all right everybody uh we're gonna take
a quick break but before we do want to
remind you how you can register yourself
to win a chance for a private group
lesson with Fabiano caruana 10 lucky
people will have the chance to do so and
we're going to tell you exactly how how
that happens uh at the top of the break
what we're going to tell you right now
there you go which is of course you can
solve a video Lesson uh and uh and tweet
or Instagram proof of it register
yourself to win 10 of you will have a
chance to help debut our new feature
classroom in a private group lesson with
Fabiano caruana don't go anywhere we
still have a lot of action here in game
six when we return Robert Hess rejoins
the sofa boys on the couch and
chess.com's coverage which is presented
by coinbase continues
[Music]
thank you
Mike Klein here with chess.com what's it
like to be a v VIP well we have entered
the chamber follow me to this very
luxurious Suite there is French wine
from Bordeaux there are fancy chess sets
and there is an exclusive view of the
action from right on the stage I think
I'll just hang out here for a while
Danny do I get the day off go ahead and
book it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations
play a game start review and try it
today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I think it plays its own role
but uh it's you know it's I mean if
trying to be serious it's hard to
evaluate because I think in modern
shares you got to be
very Universal player if you want to be
successful and so you can't rely on the
intuition alone
so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example a player a royal Chamberlain
would be the best intuition ever is
Mikhail child but
I guess he also had you know he he had
to calculate a lot yeah and for example
today if you you could try to to stick
to his playing his childhood
sometimes it will be very costly to to
your performance I think yeah the
intuition is it's always good but
sometimes you basically can't choose the
move
because of your calculation or
evaluation and you need to for example
sometimes you are giving like two
similar opportunities you you you get a
big one and okay probably hear the
intuition comes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sleeping mood or something and then I'm
listening to some you know some hard
rock music or something so to to feel
the energy and feel the power but I mean
in general it's
I mean it really depends on the mood and
the mood can be different from from one
day to another
it's not some kind of a ritual line
trained
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to chess.com's coverage of
the 2021 fide World Chess Championship
thank you for being with us I think we
are I think we are going to have quite
the day ahead here let me remind you of
who we got the man the only Hess Hampton
Robert Hess you can't spell chess
without him he's here Bobby on a car one
of the last man to challenge Magnus
Carlson for a world championship title
back in 2018 if you missed the memo he's
been bringing it every single day I Am
Yours Truly Danny wrench here to try to
keep this keep this ship sailing no
matter what happens and you can get at
each of us on Twitter as you saw there
below let me remind you on the rest days
we have the SEC days the speed test
Championship yesterday was another fun
one we had Richard Rapport versus nihail
sarn and coming up on Monday our next
break day you will have a double header
things kick off with dingley Wren versus
Lavon aronian uh bright and early it's
going to be exciting and right after
that we have Hikaru Nakamura versus
Anish giri the match that has a lot of
people talking obviously Hikaru the
favorite is this is this the year that
that someone someone throws a wrench
into those plans if you will is it going
to be a niche Gary does he have the
right tools sorry
well anisha's always talking so we we
know that he's gonna let his play speak
for itself but Hikaru Nakamura I mean
that's just the guys from the last three
speeches championships yep good luck to
anyone he faces and uh the man to beat
Magnus in last year's SEC was outed in
the first round by Fabiano caruana so
it's been a wild year if you have not
been watching seriously the speeches
Championship not a single match has not
been great now there was a weird double
negative but every single match has been
has been swell well Danny we were
watching it on the widescreen
yesterday morning the previous match
between nihal and and Richard
so it's very exciting to watch them yeah
even if you're playing in them even if
you're playing them it was exciting to
watch you we're excited for this game
here it's you know obviously deadlocked
again the uh the eval bar shows the
computer thinks it's uh it's a roughly
level position but as we keep saying
don't let that fool you in regards to
the complexity and the variations the
players were calculating where we left
it at the break Queen to C2 was played
unfortunately we did not get ephon
suggested to Rook for Queen in Balance I
really loved that idea but young plays
The Logical A5 to restrict the Knight
prevent things like Knight to B4
and after Rook to D1 we see the move
King to G7 Robert you've been you've
been gone the longest give us your fresh
take on on what's happening on the board
here well when I initially suggested G
takes F6 rather than Queen takes F6 this
was not the position I would have wanted
from the black side yeah I feel like we
had a few too many trades not enough of
an initiative gained for black and I'm
actually starting to be a little bit
concerned because I've had games where I
felt like I've equalized everything is
fine and then my Bishop as we go to the
live position yeah the bishop on D4 it
looks great it's centralized it's
staring in all directions but it can't
really attack anything especially if and
when white plays move A3 to A4 you have
your Pawn the light square that means
that the bishop can't tag it so the
bishop is staring all across the board
for an empty space whereas the Knight on
D3 it still can't be kicked off that
square and it's a very useful Square to
be on so something about this position
feels like it can start turning into to
an edge for white yeah so I actually
um wanted to point something out because
I got excited for a second okay because
I was wondering for a while
uh what's the undoing what does he want
to do against E3
and because it looks like white has done
everything that he wants the bishop
let's say drops back to B6 why plays
Queen E2 puts it on F4
why is Happy the Queens are on because
Black's King is the weaker one Black's
Bishop is blunted and the queen side
pawns are potentially a bit hanging so
white is better here but then I notice
after E3 the move Bishop to B2
oh wow and I think this equalizer it
might be zoo and you protect the work on
D1 oh oh no LOL
even even World Championship Challengers
can blunder that that's uh that's
unfortunate
all the oh so in that case E3 looks like
Magnus is starting to push a bit
I agree
because well the bishop should drop back
then
um
the same idea with Bishop C5 which I was
thinking about loses a pawn
that was like my first kind of iteration
of idea yeah to fabi's idea taking
advantage of an awkward pin doesn't work
here the queen can take and and queen
takes B5 and white has a solid Pawn up
so the bishop probably should go to B6
Queen to E2 I feel like white is is
pressing somewhat here
um I would rather be white for sure it's
uncomfortable but yeah I want to come
back to the point Robert made because I
I agree and it was something we were
discussing uh at the break as we all
quickly grabbed a snack G takes F6 was
the aggressive Choice the the more
Dynamic Choice keeping the pieces on the
board we were applauding it excited to
break but the immediate Knight D4 even
though obviously it was one of Black's
many good choices
was was not suggestive of the reasons we
thought GTX F6 would play there were
other moves here whether it was
Fabiano's albeit kind of risky but
aggressive E5 still a little better for
black even just a another move that just
sort of builds up the tension on the
position as as ifan pointed out Robert
while she was here as long as we're in a
middle game the Knight on D3 is actually
not a great piece right but as Pieces
come off the board the Knight on D3 gets
better and better absolutely and that's
exactly what's happening so it's weird
Knight D4 being the follow-up choice to
G takes F6 with every passing move we're
getting closer to a position where that
Knight on D3 looks like it might be the
better minor piece in the end game 100
and you know that position with E5 I
understand why Jan refrain from making
that move but it's kind of like you say
a then you have to say B and E5 makes
sense but I like we talked about you
want to take control of the square in
front of double pawns Knight H4 could
look a bit worrisome for a block to deal
with that you don't want allow the
knights to come to F5 and if you play
Knight D4 after Knight H4 I wonder if
the movie E4 is available here because
it's a very strange position it's
Dynamic we see that the bar is now
dipping but when you first look at this
position it's not entirely clear like if
that Knight can get to B4 and D5 it's a
fight for the light squares for white
but black has some beautifully placed
pieces and the bishop on B6 particularly
happy because the last thing that Bishop
wants is a Pawn on E3 like we might see
in the game whereas here it's fully open
and can make use of the diagonal so I'm
wondering here if maybe the reason that
this isn't good for what is because of
F5
what and okay Knight takes a five loses
a piece because of that hanging out on
D3
and E takes a five there's Bishop takes
G2 King G2 Queen B7
potentially it looks it looks at least
pretty double edged
um and there was also E4 ideas but yeah
I I would definitely be worried
tactically speaking for white here
interesting it's funny because how much
time did John put into calculating E5
did he play G takes F6 just with the
intention of of playing Knight D4 all
along we don't know but what we do know
again just to catch up is the
simplification here is is leading us
into a moment where
it's because the the lack of the lack of
tension on the board makes it makes it
so a knight that can maneuver a knight
can switch colors poke and prod and back
and forth those are the types of things
you want in an end game where all other
things are roughly equal the bishop as
Robert said is optically pleasing but
kind of empty in terms of its purpose
right unless you somehow cinch this Pawn
to a dark square or somehow manufacture
tactics on the king side there there is
still this outside idea by the way then
this bishop is not going to have the
same long-term chances that a knight
which can flip back and forth and poke
at different weaknesses will have so um
Magnus really taken a second to think
here I think it's the right time
management yeah this is a responsible
decision because he can play
the pardon A3 is potentially weakness
and he can play A4 to stop to deal with
that weakness uh right away if he plays
a what I suggested would E3 Bishop B6
Queen to E2
then black can play A4 and sort of fix
that pawn on A3 but after B4
although it's fixed and black has a dark
silver Bishop that dark Spirit Bishop
has no way for at least the immediate
future to ever attack that pawn and the
B5 Pawn is also fixed as a weakness in a
sentence because now why let's say after
Knight F4 that part has to be defended
by a piece it can't it can't move
anywhere so there are things to consider
here
and
it just feels as though that E3 is the
right move at least from my point of
view there may be maybe a better move
maybe it's a premature to do it right
away
but it feels also like his last move Was
preparing that Rook after D1 if he had
made it the previous move instead of
Rook up to D1 it would lose a pawn to
Bishop takes E3
right so this would be very bad for
white uh so it felt to me like Rook 51
Was preparing this E3 move directly and
now he's starting to consider I guess
the implications of it
interesting stat by the way Carlson has
a very good record in his in his game
sixes of the World Chess Championship
two wins both of them coming against
visionon in his two matches against uh
the former world champion from India
and then two draws against karyaka and
carwana so not bad three out of four
all right great I'd take it it looks
like mags is hovering over his Rook on
D1 so he may be thinking about doubling
with Rook to D2 and what the other thing
that Rook D2 does is it allows the
Knight to move from D3 and we keep
talking about how great the Knight is on
the Square but let's say you play Knight
F4 right now we'll show why that's a
blunder Queen takes C2 Rook takes you to
another Rook on D1 is left hanging so
Bishop F2 check wins The Exchange and a
pawn for black this is a winning
position so Rook to D2 and it seemed
like he was hovering over the Rook that
allows white to play Knight F4 next
um if we make it's like Rook a to BH
it's a waiting move just to show the
point now Knight F4 is possible and in
the event of a queen trade you can
choose which Rook to take with you can
take over the C file or you can compete
for both the C and the D files at the
same time and that allows us to enter an
end game where not claiming that white
is better but at least it allows men's
to transition into the end game if
that's what he so chooses
I'm with you this is
started out uh a very a very successful
game for yawn maybe his most successful
game for the first stage really in terms
of what he came up with at the board but
now you're getting that feeling that
this is going to be a long Affair where
white might really have those Magnus
carlson-esque winning chances I think
he's starting to see some possibilities
that in a long game he can outplay black
because black doesn't have very obvious
counter play and white has ways to
improve his position as Robert mentioned
if you start to take over one of the
files then there are ways that you can
invade and that Bishop on D4 if it gets
kicked back eventually can be a bit
loose let's just imagine that the bishop
goes to B6 and then a rook on C6 starts
to attack it which doesn't seem like a
very important factor but a loose Bishop
is a far worse piece than a stable
Knight but a knight on D3 is for the
moment stable it might even find
stability on another Square for example
F4 right now for the moment as uh Robert
mentioned the tactic Bishop takes off
two wins for black
so yeah he's considering his options
Rook D2
it doesn't look like the most natural
move at the start but it might actually
prepare maybe not even Rook D1 but Queen
to D1 is also an idea because that PIN
potentially is very annoying and the
queen to D1 could at some point jump
into G4 it doesn't look like that way
like it's that way now but if y plays E3
Knight F4 the queen could jump to G4 and
potentially attack some stuff on the
king side the other thing Rook D2 kind
of prepares is ideas of Queen C6 at some
point you keep talking about this idea
you can't do it right away as long as E2
is is on pre
but Rook D2 is one of those really
flexible moves because E3 is good as it
is to kick the bishop back what does it
do it permanently undefends that square
of the Knight right and we see how
important that has been to magnus's
setup so Rook D2
kind of just opens the door for a lot of
things whether it's Roberts Knight F4
whether it's your queen to D1 whether
it's Queen to C6 all kinds of things
on the agenda
and you keep challenging black to find
the plan because King G7 was a very
useful move it protects F6 preemptively
it also covers the H6 square of Queen D2
was ever on the agenda so I do like to
move King G7 and that like the question
what is Black's next turn like if we
hand the black a free turn right what
would the move be and A4 comes to mind
well I was gonna just answer it with
with the phone suggesting because I do
think that
I do think that's it's not as good as it
maybe was because the Brooks are more
coordinated but Rook a to Seattle
nodding oh that feels so good when he
looks at me and nods Robert well I was
not even give me like the chills I was
nodding about the second part
why it's White's Rooks are more
coordinated here and I think that makes
a difference so you were nodding at the
dismissal of why this is not as good
yeah I think it really because the last
time the Rook was an F1 and that sort of
forced white to play Rook C2 and get a
bit more passive but but even here like
this is this still might be okay for
black but I would be a bit concerned if
let's say Knight F4 is coming
potentially
now this may allow a Perpetual with
Queen B1 Queen E4 or something like that
but uh but if White's able to get E3 and
a rook to d8 that King is yeah is sort
of under attack that's how you lose it
might not be really weak
but yeah I don't know if I I'm feeling
this one so much for black
okay the interesting thing is that also
after
we asked the question of what's Black's
next move H5 was very often mentioned as
an idea and Rook D2 deals with that idea
by now Knight F4 is very strong the
trade of Queensland H5 is a problem
black has to deal with
uh maybe you can play King H6
but at least that pawn is a bit of a
weakness for the moment there's no real
reason
um for him to play H4 yet in fact one of
the things I noticed from
the SEC match yesterday uh between nihal
and and Richard was that in one of the
games
uh rapper played H4 and nihal played G
takes H4
and then Robert played A5 said Thank you
and he helped like B takes A5 but he
kind of wrecked his structure in a way
but he he won a pawn or in that case two
pawns so sometimes uh sometimes it's
okay for blacks to sacrifice upon him
this way sometimes it it simply ends up
that white has an extra pass pawn and
even if you lose the first or the most
advanced H Pawn there you're left with a
second one that's an outside pass Pawn
because black has the double pawns many
of these end games will be problematic
for black so I like Bobby suggestion of
taking that pawn it isn't the first idea
we come to because in a position like
this when you open your king sometimes
that can be a problem but with the
queens of the board there's no real
danger and I I like the look of just G
takes H4 in such a moment so if we go
back to the live position one of the
essential questions that I always ask is
what pieces do we want to see traded
Rook C8 is a move that tries to distract
the White Queen from the E2 pawn and I
get that but does black want to trade
one pair of Rogues does black want to
trade two pairs of Rooks does Black is
Black okay with the queen trade and if
we trade the Queens do we want both
pairs of Rooks on or just one or none so
these are really difficult questions to
answer especially in advance of those
trades being offered but you know that
Jan is sitting here thinking what trades
can I afford to make happen it doesn't
seem like white is in any danger no
matter the trades with the exception
being the two Rooks for the queen that
could get white in some danger otherwise
it's just a series of Trades which
leaves white perhaps with some chance of
the press or a level position but that's
what both players are really
deliberating right now is what trades
are acceptable in this position
to be clear Jana's not sitting there
thinking he's actually done very little
sitting and thinking but he's thinking
he's thinking for sure in his head
obviously I'm kidding so surprising me
thing for me is that Magnus is thinking
for a long time here and I understand
Rook D2 is an interesting move but
is there like I don't feel like this is
a hugely critical moment and you have
this very obvious move E3 you can save a
lot of time
of course I you know it's possible that
Magnus is really going deep into the
position and will come up with with a
very good idea
but
they might potentially get a bit low on
time soon I think this is a moment when
it's
possibly more practical to play E3 Queen
E2 and I mean it's certainly not worse
than other suggestions of like work to
D2 or equivalent moves and it's the most
not sometimes the most natural way to
play is the best way yo
I think Magnus also is appreciating the
moment though right I mean he doesn't
want to let another maybe his best
opportunity slip it's funny to say that
in a position that's kind of tame
looking but the truth is we we know just
what magnets can do with one imbalance
in the position a knight versus Bishop
all things being equal according to the
engines doesn't mean all things equal in
terms of the results whoever plays
better wins and Magnus Magnus doesn't
wanna doesn't want to commit to
something that he doesn't feel leaves
him with very good long-term chances to
squeeze this one
it's true and I like the E3 move as soon
as it was suggested by Fabiano I think
it just opens up many different Pathways
for white to press for more and that
pawn on B5 right we loved the move when
it was played I was especially enthused
about it but now in some positions it's
a bit of a Target but I'll give you
credit even when it was played you were
enthused about it but you also pointed
out right then that the the one thing
about the pawn on B5 was what the end
game leaves you in situations where any
pollen you've Advanced they there there
is no way home right and and that makes
them more
uh more easily accessible targets
so I'm thinking one reason why he maybe
doesn't like this E3 Queen E2 and this
is a bit speculative okay we'll look at
it it's after Queen E2 and maybe bishop
B6 is actually not the right move there
is also Bishop to E5 it looks a bit
funny to put the bishop there but maybe
after E3 Bishop to E5 it goes to D6
and it attacks that pawn A3
this might be some sort of idea for
black but let's just say that he plays
the most natural Bishop to B6 Queen to
E2
and if he tries E5 here
um I remember we were speaking about
this idea and it potentially creates a
huge hole on F5 on the other hand the D3
Knight yo is an important piece if it
gets to F4 it will be better placed on
D3 at the moment on D3 it's a bit it's
wondering where to go you know it's no
longer supported by a pawn so it's a bit
loose so E5 does
um
ask why the question of what do you do
with your knight and it also if black
gets really aggressive potentially
prepares F5 F4 some sort of like
aggressive
um Pawn breaks in the center
well I can still play Knight E1 here
and and that's why it's kind of risky
for black because imagine the Knight
gets F4 and then to H5 uh sorry to F5
um we're already speaking about white
having a decisive attack without even
sacrificing material that's why E5 is
super risky but it's something to for
white to consider also you know it'll
start to get very concrete it's black in
time or is white in time
yeah E5 feels very risky because as if I
was saying 91 the 993 no longer has the
stronghold there the B5 pawns under
attack Knight G2 or Knight F3 to H4 all
these moves are pretty obvious and if
you get their G4 will come and there's
nothing that the bishop can do right
this is what we've been talking about
the bishop often is good it plays on
both sides of the boards long range
piece but the F5 score is a light Square
the only way that Bishop can defend the
F5 scores eliminate the knights path to
F5 so the bishop could somehow take away
the H4 square and capture another gets
there but that's not possible the bishop
is all the way over there on the queen
side so there's tremendous amount of
risk and not to mention that A4 at some
point can open up the C4 Square so even
though instead of Knight E1 sometimes
there's like Knight B2 and A4 and trying
to get the Knight to C4 or Rook C4
something like that so black needs to be
careful on both sides of the board
because as soon as you give white A
light Square to venture to you can't
take that decision back
agreed agree to Greed this is a very
rich position
yeah this Magnus is treating it like it
is as well he's really making sure he
takes the right approach here it looks
like a simplified position but it's far
from that yeah it contains a great deal
of potential risk
for black less so for white but in end
games it is actually possible that the
A3 Pawn becomes a bit of a weakness and
there is some potential risk for white
too
it looks like Magnus wants to make a
move he's kind of reaching for people
several times but uh it looks like he
has a move in mind but he doesn't
probably see any advantage after it
and that's why he's hesitating
just remember Magnus you are your best
moves
was that as cringe as it sounded in my
head oh gosh LOL
you need to give him a stash with that
too just you know to make sure you cover
up that slow down I'm sending him a
couple mugs for his birthday so it's
okay he'll remember
just don't send him a mug with that
phrase oh I am
probably 20 in the office you want one
too no I don't think so okay
good talk
there we go there we go the second time
he just hovered there it almost looked
like he was gonna play A4 so he was
hovering at least it seemed to be a
different spot to the board but Rook D2
he at first legs didn't grab it he went
back to thinking and now does play Rook
D2 and maybe he's leaving the
possibility of e3 open for later keeping
the Knight firmly defended for now on D3
allowing himself to midnight F4 Knight
E1 night somewhere it's trade Queen
safely and Jan is back at the board
quickly and he's up now
13 plus minutes in the clock
and that's a serious time Edge but the
position I think is more difficult to
play for black
100 agreed and we'll continue to
highlight that because at move 25 which
is where we are the players still have
15 more moves to make so this is not
dire time pressure but let's let's
remember everybody the time control for
the world championship is not what it
once was at different stages with
increment if these players are are down
really get down to to trying to reach
move 40 there's there's a very good
chance that uh that the game is decided
at the turn of the turn of the time
control
no increment coming
yeah I although this move makes sense
Rook to D2 it maybe opens up a square
for the queen or for the work on D1 or
prepares Knight F4 it still feels a bit
unnatural I don't know if I really like
this decision especially with how much
time he took
but it's difficult to criticize this
move because it's probably neither
better nor worse than civil White's
Alternatives now the question is what
will Yan choose let's say
because he didn't play Rook ASCA before
so he probably wasn't sure about it's a
super committal decision he wasn't sure
about that trade of Queen for two Rooks
right let's assume that he's still not
sure about it and doesn't go for it okay
especially since white isn't forced to I
can play Queen Z1 there and I don't
really see a downside to the trailer
works for white
um
a very natural move for black to me is
to actually get that Bishop away from D4
to play Bishop to B6
because that Bishop at some point will
risk getting kicked away from D4 anyway
so why not open the rook's influence on
d8
um
well I can still try to trade Queens
Knight F4 for example
but maybe the trade of Queens is is not
anything special for white should we
train with Queen C6 instead of Knight F4
perhaps possibly Queen to C6 it is their
F5 in some of these positions so but
okay Queen C6 this is more forcing
because you attack maybe this is the
downside of Bishop to B6 because the
bishop
I
we mentioned earlier that the bishop is
a bit loose and here we see that black
has to spend some time and get a bit
more passive like Rook a to B8 uh
play a bit more passively to secure the
bishop and then rook dc2 and white has
gained the C file a solid Knight on D3
not a huge Advantage but definitely an
advantage this is exactly what mine is a
nagging Advantage where black could make
one inaccuracy and then the position
kind of collapses because black has no
active plan here you're certainly not
playing E5 E4 in this type of position
because there's a rook on C6 by playing
E5 you open up that Rooks stair to the
F6 pawn and you're not playing E5 E4
you're just leaving squares behind as
soon as you push Pawn so this would
actually be very dangerous and it's sort
of the standard Catalan Advantage if you
can get this Knight on D3 against a dark
Square bishop and I was hoping in a way
for a knight on D3 for a long time ago
and at first the unhandle it well but if
you get to a position like this black is
in serious trouble because every single
move there is a difficult one that could
cause your position to collapse or
you'll have to push upon that you don't
want to push and any light square that
white can get is a square that Nike can
get to and the bishop cannot contend
with Yellen is uh
yon is now taking his time taking his
turn
we see him kind of leaned in there at
the board and and to continue to show
the line that uh
we were talking about this would not be
ideal and for those who couldn't see
Robert Hess on camera I could when this
position was here he he gave me give me
quite the face that said this is a game
Magnus wins this this position is is
this is the dream for me this is this is
what he's been hoping for all game
pretty much he's won with so much less
than this before and it's just one of
these positions where black struggles
forever and if you play 100 accurate
chess you'll make a draw in many of
these positions but you give white
tremendous potential and it's no fun it
is a miserable defensive task yeah and
the other thing is a general thing is
the longer the game gets drawn out in a
position where black is slightly worse
or or why slightly worse the uh more
chance there is for that advantage to be
converted right uh because the it's
easier to play that's in this position
it's easier to play for white not only
is it an advantage White's moves are
easier black struggles to find ideas
which means that
over time those difficult decisions
build up and build up and at some point
uh it will lead to a mistake Maybe not
immediately but it might be on you know
move 60 for example right so no I mean
it's a position where like like what
does black do right white owns all the
Avenues you can you can bring the king
up comfortably try to create weaknesses
on both sides of the board you maintain
long-term winning chances because of the
broken structure and and there's ways to
poke at this right I mean here black
weights that's that's what black does
black just waits around Black's just
sitting and which is that's why young
did what he just did yeah went for Rook
C8 okay here we go the offer of two
Rooks for the queen is on the board and
boy would we have fireworks if Magnus
chose to welcome the imbalance it's uh
that is a free result game one that we
have been waiting for I'm like I'm like
Mr burnsing my fingers together here yes
yes here we go we will have decisive
chess that wasn't awkward at all yes
um well you made a good point that
Magnus does not have to take on C8 do we
want to look at that line I think we
should be one let's give Queen do you
want a shot yeah let's do it so here we
go Queen to D1
so is
most wonder if there's like Bishop C3
yeah I think I think actually this we
can rule out oh that's actually a really
good Bishop C3 Works C2 B4 she just
leaves white with zero space sorry for
my tone that's actually a really good
move it's actually a really good move
but yeah I was looking at this actually
I was thinking about some other
positions yeah this B4 Bishop C3 right
depending on how white played and it's
very committal of course because you're
leaving some light squares but the
Knight can't move on D3 yeah this is
like White's Frozen this is the opposite
of how Magnus would have been feeling
about the Rooks on the Rooks doubled on
the seafoam so good news for us that
means we're even more likely to see
Magnus take on C8 his hand is almost
forced here why it has an easy decision
here he has to take on a C8 otherwise
he's just accepting a worse position but
if the decision is so easy why is men's
thinking about it
so I'm probably unsure about the
position here and he's just calculating
it because he hasn't moved on to other
other moves yet he hasn't even
considered moves like Queen D1 because
he's he's a bit concerned about this
position understandably so it's very
complicated and uh if he started with
other moves he would probably realize
well I've got to take but I assume he
will
in like the next 20 seconds take on C8
shout out to ephon who's not with us
right now but she's joining us daily she
was the first one to suggest this
variation for black and of course it was
uh recommended as a potential option all
the way back here you can see the the
Highlight we had in the on the board is
still there in our notation
maybe it was better for black then but
what's changed now is the a pawn
Advanced and the King coming up you know
Robert oops you highlighted that
or maybe maybe it was Fabiana who
highlighted the risks of of this
position for black or maybe even greater
because of what happens if the Knight
moves and if this bishop gets kicked and
the Rooks get going over here it's the
black king that could get in trouble not
just the white king because of the
centralized queen of Bishop
yeah but let's see because black is the
one who gets the chance to start his
play first okay I'm wondering about the
move H5 here
we looked at this and you said Knight F
yeah but yeah I mentioned Knight F4 but
if Queen B1 King G2 Queen E4
I mean F3 Queen E3 looks pretty awkward
so maybe just a perpetual
okay and yeah I guess black is not too
upset with that outcome right so after
H5 of course you're trying to push that
H Pawn up the board some more if white
plays H4 there's the risk of the G3
um Pawn begins in trouble because the
pin but that pawn H5 is now cemented
there which means Knight F4 later in the
game or very soon could win that pawn
because how are you going to defend that
Pawn King H6 is could always remember a
rook h8 check or something like that uh
bring your queen back to the defense
doesn't look very enticing so what
happens here so that's why I was
thinking after H4 maybe black can play
this move I suggest in a similar
position E5 a new look at us because or
we've worked together the more we finish
each other's sandwiches
leaving me out again so this is what's
happening today
um all right you know I can go
uh all right so no if I I knew where you
were going with it Bobby go ahead so the
one thing is that why can no longer
really realistically use the F5 square
right the night is too far away and also
white has no peace besides the Knight to
cover that square right so the queen
will always cover it and one important
thing is E3 here not very good Bishop
takes Bishop takes E3
uh take Queen takes and why it has to
move the Rook to F2 and then while loses
D3 don't take your first yeah don't take
your first but dude sorry every time the
email board does that I go do oh look at
that we have a dude on the board Magnus
moves the queen up game on ladies and
gentlemen we have action in game six of
the 2021 vide World Chess Championship
dare I call a decisive result today dare
I do it pretty sure you're the only
pretty good drawing what did I say at
the top of the show is the reason I said
everyone loves proven Dan wrong
that's what I said your nickname in
Heist everyone was proven damn wrong
whoa Queen D5 instantaneous so the
Tactical point is of course Knight F4
would be a great move if not for Bishop
takes F2 winning The Rook
uh the other point is of course B3 is
hanging so white has to decide how to
deal with that
what a quick move to play I mean
probably evaluate so you mentioned
quickly when we had iPhone here that a
centralized Queen an open Queen with
Targets on both sides of the board can
typically compete in the modern
understanding of how the queen battles
the Brooks right yeah so that that makes
sense for him to play 25. that's sad
that's a very quick move to play When
the queen was already on a pretty good
Square so your thoughts evaluating the
dynamic of the two Rooks versus the
centralized Queen and Bishop I think Jan
is getting ambitious because he sees the
following line occurring B4 is the most
obvious move and he wants to play A4 and
his idea is long term that A3 Pawn is a
weakness Queen B3 is an idea and he's
going well potentially blacks past A4
Pawn not past at the moment but if A3
Falls that A4 Pawn is a super dangerous
pass Pawn white probably has a way to
deal with this but it looks a bit
annoying
um by the way we have it on the board
but Magnus plays B4 and then pauses
before writing the move
usually that's a sign that
like am I missing something that kind of
looks good for me but what's my
opponent's idea
um or that could just like Magnus does
that often he pauses before writing the
move that could also mean absolutely
nothing
Robert go ahead and the big problem for
white is the ways we saw magnets trying
to continue Knight F4 E3 both of those
moves look shaky for the time being
metaphor just losing material as we were
discussing E3 there's this pin on the D
files the queen on D5 is perfectly
placed and centralized
yeah this makes a lot of sense but the
thing is for what as well you can't
easily move your piece you would like to
make them like 91 get your knight to F3
work on that pin Bishop but anytime you
have the Knight you drop the F2 pawn and
The Rook on D2 so can you go for a
checkmating attack for white can you get
both your Rooks on the eighth rank seems
very difficult Ken white retreat with
Rook C8 to C2 that way you can free up
your knight you have to watch out for
Queen B3 and things like that going for
the A3 Pawn but white can actually take
a passive defense in some of these lines
like if you bring a rook back to C2 okay
and even if your Rook ends up on A2 it's
not very clear how black proceeds from
here and so well hold on what's so Rook
C2 what's the line so Queen B3 okay I
was thinking you go Rook A2 and it's
like let's let's bring up the analysis
board it's not appealing right you don't
want to have your Rook on A2 you're much
happier on C8 but where does black go
from here not saying that white has
anything clear to do next but I'm just
trying to figure out if white goes Ultra
passive and then eventually tries to
push E3 or reroute the Knight or you
know King G2 first and try to figure out
things later what is Black's plan
Bobby your response do you have a well I
think that black will probably start
pushing his pawns E5 okay I know I'm
repeating this move a lot it feels like
the most natural way to try to get some
some play
um I'm not sure if black immediately we
want to play E4 because that gives a
knight to square on F4 but also what's
whites do what's what is white doing
White's the one who has to try to you
know play some sort of idea here because
White's the one who's very passive for
the moment you don't just want to play
Rook C2 Rook D2 and shuffle for the rest
of the game because then you're
admitting then okay maybe it's still
equal or a draw but Black's the one
having all the fun here so yeah maybe
Magnus will be forced to do this
I if I were him I would not want to do
this for sure I'm wondering after A4
about the movie E3
uh the question is if like Bishop E5 did
white gain anything from this
one
because you can bring the book back to
C2 now
and then maybe try to take this bishop
on E5 yeah and I think if we saw
something like this like Robert uh we're
saying Queen Rook C2 Queen B3 Knight
takes E5 F takes E5 Rook A2 here we're
just talking about a dead draw either
side will make progress I was just about
to ask that as you recommend this change
throw it out throw it over to our man
Robert has to talk about the
instructional thing you often highlight
what happens with the Knight versus
Bishop whose chances are increased here
you've got weaknesses on A3 but you also
have a weakness on B5 right who has the
better chances long term
well the Rooks against the queen that's
going to be the dynamic that's dangerous
for black because what can happen is
let's say all of those Queen side pawns
get traded okay then white might just be
winning yeah so that's what I'm trying
that's a really I think educational
instructor point so if we visualize not
just the Knight and Bishop coming off
but everything on the queen side why are
the Rooks much better than the queen for
Magnus long term because Rooks they're
two of them they can team up on a square
whereas a queen can maybe attack the F2
Pawn but you can't attack it with
anything else right so the roofs can
line up in the seventh Rank and then
even if the Queen and King are
protecting it you can just take that
pawn right because once the queen trades
back for those two Rooks white ends up
upon a head right so black does not want
to trade those Queen side pawns that's
in part why he played A4 because he
could have taken on B4 which would have
left the pawn on a dark Square
but you don't want those trades you
don't want all those pawns to come off
and one other thing I was considering
unless I was wondering if the E3 here
for white can black even try like Bishop
B2
because the Knight is pins you can't
take with Knight and if the Rook takes
on B2 then we get Queen takes D3 and now
A3 is under attack and you can't protect
it because Rook A2 Queen B1 check and
that's an issue so this Rook on D2 being
loose is such a problem in my estimation
that that's why my instinct was to bring
this Rook back to C2 and just say I know
it looks weird we have such a
beautifully placed Rook on scene maybe
going for an attack but sometimes the
best way to go forward is to First cover
your base is and then later in the game
move forward so if we just show Rook C2
again Queen B3 Rook A2
and then that move E5 which we were
talking about for black like this type
of position
if white can somehow strike with Knight
C5 and
try to take over some of the light
squares black does not want to take that
Knight we couldn't show why this is how
you lose you lose immediately Rook
behind pawn and push done done so if I
can play Knight C5 and you have to move
your queen back well now I'm really
happy because Here Comes Rook C2 and you
win a piece because the queen only is D5
and P3
but the point stands that I'm starting
by retreating just to protect everything
and then once I go Knight C5 black is
left with these really difficult
decisions because you can't really take
that Knight on C5 yeah and then you have
to be concerned you want to just cover
everything probably but the longer this
game continues and white tries to
operate in the light squares or tries to
trade pieces maybe that gives white some
chances I'm not saying that black
doesn't have chance of his own but those
are the things that I'm considering in
this position well I think you made a
really concrete point sort of
hypothetically but we kept looking at
this idea of e3 but the moment you
recommended Bishop B2 we became clear on
uh yeah actually E3 is probably just not
an option Bishop B2 the Knight again is
pinned because of the rook and if the
Rook takes Queen D3 but here here there
is still the move Rook to C5 which
probably keeps it oh wait so playable
for white E3 there should be two Rook to
C5 because the queen has to stay on that
on that file so it should go maybe to D7
and now white has gotten the extra move
Rook to Rook on C5
um the other thing is that if white
takes on if black takes on A3 the bishop
could sometimes get trapped oh that's
interesting yeah like for example Queen
to D7 I'm looking at Rook 5 to C2
Bishop takes A3 Rook to A2 I think that
that Bishop gets lost
yeah that was a problem that looks like
a big problem E5 E4 or something maybe
E5 is saving but they're still e fourth
white but in any case the point is clear
yeah well E5 you can just move your
knight C5 yeah Knight C5 is window
so but I I the more I I see Robert's
idea of just putting the work passively
on A2 the more I like it because
once white plays an ic5 like in the line
we we just recently saw
uh then after E3 Black's Bishop will
sort of be trapped in a sense it can
take on C5 but that's a very risky
endeavor
uh or it can stay on C3 where it's
suddenly no longer defended by anything
and a bit hanging in mid-air so let's
say queen B1 here King G2
and why we'll next play E3
and the bishop will well probably can't
take on on C5 at any moment but if it's
on C3 then it gets attacked rook dc2 and
it's sort of it's not really trapped
but it's it's an uncomfortable situation
Let's Go full screen Magnus as he leaned
over and he looked like he was about
to make his move he only has 10 minutes
to make 12 more of them we're going to
keep you updated on the time control and
the move number as we get close to the
threshold where both players get more
added onto their clock which is move 40
here it comes he's about maybe about to
make his 29th move this time pressure
could play a factor today guys this is
this is the first time we've really had
many critical decisions left to make
before before the next phase this is
real because there's no 30 second
increment yeah until the final time
control yeah so normally in a position
like this one which move 28 12 moves to
go and you get 30 seconds added per
movement it's a total of six minutes to
your clock that's plenty of time but now
we're under 10 you don't get that
additional time when you hit the clock
and for Magnus here he hasn't seems
super confident like he had some
decisions like after that move Rook to
C8 Queen takes C8 he could have snapped
it off because at that point he didn't
really have a choice and now he does
play E3 instead of Rook back to C2 and
young can play Bishop B2 we just talked
about how that could actually backfire
he can retrieve Bishop to E5 which I
don't love at first sight because the
trade of Knight for Bishop may cause
block some problems but Jan
he doesn't seem too worried right now in
fact he seems quite skeptical of yeah
he's got a confident this is a yawned
upon Mishi body language that uh
suggests that
he's confident often when he's moving to
and from the board
man fun looking tight sorry Bobby go
ahead I think that um
Bishop B2 is the critical move yeah and
if Jan is you know he has some
Expressions that indicates surprise
then probably he thought Bishop B2 was a
problem with E3 so after Bishop B2 white
I think is forced to play Rook C5
yeah we'll show again Knight takes loses
The Rook Rook takes loses the eight Pawn
yeah so and this would be losing for
white most likely yeah so Rook C5 the
queen has to stay on on that D file d a
doesn't make any sense D7 we saw the
problem because of Rook 5's and C2 and
the bishop gets trapped so Queen D6 is
the last remaining possible move for
black
and if you give black another move he
might be able to throw an F5 which
vacates a new square for the bishop but
more concretely the A3 Pawn is okay is
it is an issue so
I was so you made such a uh an impact on
my subconscious by trapping my Bishop
earlier I sort of dismissed that I can
still take it but that's why the queen
on D6 is so important you once you take
A3 the queen and Bishop will line up on
the beat oh okay very good I'll just
make a move just to show that something
okay oh yeah even if the Rook comes back
yeah yeah so The Rook C2 this is such a
big difference that now after rookie two
Bishop takes B4 you take the bishop the
queen takes back two extra pawns on the
queen side is going to be most likely
winning for black so Queen D6 is
actually like a strange move in a sense
because protecting the B5 Pawn with
Queen D7 is very logical but the queen
actually needs to put pressure on B4
here and if that's the case and we see
Rook takes B2 so you don't oh so no it's
fine Rook takes B2 so we don't drop the
pawn well now we have an issue where A3
Falls but so my B5 and we were talking
about that Dynamic if white can trade
all those Queen side pawns black is the
only one who can get in trouble and this
should be held by black but there could
be a moment where those Rooks line up in
the seventh Rank and then black needs to
be extra careful well I think this line
continues with probably an only move for
white Rook B to C2 because that Rook has
nowhere else why not to prepare for
Queen takes A3 and that's attacking the
work on B2 so that Rook has to go to a
square where it's no longer attacked
right so Rook bc2 Queen A3 and Rook B5
now the question is can black push that
pawn through the most obvious move is
Queen D3
you attack both Rooks
I think Rook B to C5
A3
and now I think white plays Rook to C1
and then the other word goes to a file
and covers that A1 square with both
Rooks so black can no longer push up on
through and I think that this kind of
thing is leading towards a draw what was
funny is but it all it may be only white
can win because of Robert's points if
these pawns disappear we have seventh
rank problems there's one important
Point here and then if you don't go Rook
C1 just the half step ago if you go Rook
five to C3 hoping to get that pandra
Queen D1 check King G2 and A2 now is a
big problem
oh yeah end up winning the rook and that
is Bad News Bears for white so
this position still has some life in it
both sides can go wrong but it does feel
like in the two Rooks against Queen
position black is the one who just needs
that extra caution because you don't
want those Rooks lining up against your
pawns wow yawn plays Bishop E5 another
perhaps suggestion that
if we are going to have peace it's not
going to come easily yon yon played this
move G takes F6 much earlier if you're
just joining us
he goes for Rook a to C8 inviting the
queen versus two Rooks and balance and
now it doesn't go for the forcing Bishop
B2 but instead Bishop E5 he's
maintaining the tension you know what he
might be smelling Robert roses
you smell what Young's cooking
what was it it's on the clock I think I
think he's looking at I think he's
looking at magnus's time pressure with a
little bit of uh a little bit of blood
in the water
well although the time is a bit scary I
think white is an absolute safety after
for example the movie Works to C5 okay I
don't think there's any risk for white
um because probably black will play
Queen to B3 there
why we'll take on E5 take on B5 and we
have a very similar position to the one
we just saw where White's Rook drops
back to uh
to D1 let's say Rook B5
uh black might even have a perpetual
yeah don't don't take their Rook D1
looks like the right move
Queen somewhere B2 B3 Rook to F1 The
Rook is completely secure on F1 of
course the other Rook will go to the a
file at some point
uh let's say A3
we might actually see this four against
four Rook two well maybe not working if
I beat this though because the rook's
coming over oh no queen bee here okay
yeah let's say Rook to B8 you wait for
A2 and then you play Rook A8
and now now you have the line I was
looking for although I actually see like
you're a queen queen B1 in the end I
actually realized the available bar
suddenly went a bit Haywire
and because rookie was a mistake because
of Queen to A4 I think that's the reason
we day four and that pawn actually kind
of pushes through why we'll lose the B
Pawn to cover that pawn but instead of
Rook B8 a better move
Rook to B6
if Queen A4
now B5 and you have Rook A6 yeah Rook is
better on B6 going to A6 and we'll see
A2 Rook A6 trade upon I think that one
is is a draw though it's almost like
you're 2800 or something that was that
was impressive uh we are regularly
impressed by the uh the commentary here
from Fabiano caruana and Robert Hess
remember everybody we are going to have
other guests joining us regardless of
the result uh at the top of the show
when the game ends the show here on
chess.com just begins coming up we have
the artist Colin Byrne Alchemist of the
world's most valuable chess set that we
had here in studio earlier today Fabiano
made his first move prediction on it we
also have Vladimir fedosev joining us
once again we'll talk to we've got some
fun questions for big Vlad maybe about a
particular Blitz match that went down
between him and Magnus Carlson on
chess.com a little less than a year ago
we also of course will have young love
the camera but we also have
maybe the most talked about man in
streaming right now Ludwig aggren who
just moved over to YouTube he is no
longer streaming on Twitch very huge
news coming down this week we're going
to catch up with Ludwig talk to him
about his chess career obviously asked
him to evaluate his chess coach Robert
hess's performance so far uh for the
world has championship and so much more
ahead all right we're going to take a
very quick break right now so that we
can stay locked into the action as we
get into time pressure so don't go
anywhere we're going to be right back as
game six for the feed a World Chess
Championship continues
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be larger oh
[Music]
magic magic
with music with architecture with colors
magic with celebration with your safety
From Here There and Everywhere for six
hormones day and night join the making
of a new world starting October 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we have action these guys are diving in
already analyzing it and I gotta say
hold your horses so that the fans can
hear what you're discussing Robert has
Fabiano caruana Danny wrench with you
thanks for being with us for chess.com's
coverage which is presented by coinbase
get at us on Twitter maybe maybe you
tweet something special of Robert maybe
he gets back to you probably not maybe
not all right but okay you guys started
analyzing and now we're gonna do it so
H4 was played by Magnus a big commitment
but even bigger Jan just immediately
responds to H5 Robert your your thoughts
first yeah my immediate thought is Rook
C5 was a movie we're talking about
anyway and Max really does not have a
lot of time so yeah he needs to get to
move forward at 10 moves from now in
under three and a half minutes but Rook
C5 what I'm wondering is if Queen B3 we
just go through the sequence Knight
takes E5 Pawn takes E5 and what if I
take Rook takes E5 so I don't think the
B Pawn I take this Pawn I guess it's
just bad for white but I was wondering
like if somehow you could try to like go
Rook D4 but it might be too slow to get
the Rooks behind well you can't take
this poem which is key because of this
move so that that kind of is the problem
I guess so when right before we came
back on the break Robert said I have an
idea I was trying to figure it out and I
actually thought the idea might be king
to H2
and and he just made the move and I'll
explain his move because we're probably
going to see stuff like fly by pretty
quickly now since they're getting low on
time what happens if Queen to B3
now I think white can play Knight to C5
Queen takes A3 Rook 2 to d8 oh
and let's just say queen takes before
let's say black keeps getting greedy oh
yes don't don't give a check okay maybe
Rook Jade also wins but I think they're
both making some E4 in the end okay okay
but yeah yeah that's probably no oh oh
Queen takes four oh no okay but work
yeah you give checks in E4 in that yeah
that okay
or actually just Rook takes H5 is mate
okay or Rook takes H5 all right we're
all good
um so so I think this is his idea to
play Knight C5 here and it starts to
look like a dangerous because if let's
say queen B3 and Knight C5 Queen takes
A3 Rook
2 to d8 if F5 you run into this Knight
D7 stuff yeah maybe maybe rookie at
first maybe 97 first there's some checks
here by the way but maybe that Bishop
cover is h8 so actually black can move
the bishop or even move the queen to B2
and then the king finds refuge on H7 or
h8
maybe if I go well here though
just to show the line probably is
talking about the king can hide here and
suddenly black is actually in much
better shape than that looks like this
is I mean if Magnus in time pressure is
committing himself to an idea like that
by the way ah I mean we see we are at
move 31. this is this is how you lose
games when you when you are in time
pressure and you and you and you try to
go for aggressive ideas like that
because it's the opportunity to
miscalculate something yeah and I mean
the idea that I was trying to drum up
for white as we're suggesting was
instead of taking the B5 Pawn but saying
E5 because the pawn H5 is also loose
that means the black king could be in
some danger but it doesn't seem like
waking up both the Rooks like around in
time so uh it's a tricky scenario
um
well this move doesn't commit Magnus
because after Queen B3 he can go back to
that same Knight takes E5 and Rook C5
because with the King on H2 there's no
Queen C1 check so that King H2 is a
general useful move to get away from the
checks on C1 on A1 that might
potentially Fork so let's talk about
that again so King H2 even if we go for
this
nail lines like this and again it's not
force I'm just illustrating your point
and it looks like it might actually be
fine the whole point is at the end of
lines like this there's no longer a
queen C1 check picking up the Rook there
may be something else there is Queen C3
and you can't bring your Rook to A2
because Queen C4 man Queen C1 is better
but the point is you can't get your Rook
to eight
could be it and now you're struggling to
stop that pawn that's very annoying I
would have to go for some Rook D7 stuff
but it's just like I mean this is where
like you go for it and even if one Queen
better queen of one hitting hitting the
rook and the pawn
yeah so uh so I Magnus is playing a bit
risky because he had a very safe option
Rook C5 at various moments yeah and he's
going for this which maybe his idea for
Queen B3 is he wants to take on E5
like maybe it's his Knight C5 stuff
maybe he wants to take only five take
and Rook to C7
Queen oh I'm sorry sorry first rookie
seven Queen like three is a Black's only
idea Rook uh two to D7
and and he's going to say well your king
is in a significant amount of danger
because let's say queen takes B4
Rook takes F7 if the King goes back then
we have that potential like Rook D Rook
to D7 and then
um or maybe Rook G7 first
and then uh let's say King h8 Rook G to
E7 wins right yeah you can't stop it so
so we have that potentially and if the
King goes forward which I I suppose it
has to do to G6 well then we have Rook
G7 suddenly the King has to try to run
King F5
but you know there's like F3 here oh oh
you know we're already talking about
white has a drawn hand at any moment and
black has to find accurate moves to draw
yeah I'm just showing them no like yeah
no of course yeah prior to this point
King to H6 I think is still a drop to
Rook G7
but yeah it's it's not something you
want to go for with black because white
can just repeat at will if he wants or
he can if there's something that he'll
find it right so black hat is the one
who has to take care although because
it's so forcing and if there is the draw
that sort of makes Jan's life easier but
that said
given the time situation John might
really be thinking I can try to steal a
victory again because this is not a
normal even even for online chess these
days most of the big online events have
some sort of increment right I mean this
is three minutes sudden death yeah this
is don't make move 40. it's over this
this is super exciting because Magnus is
playing for win here yeah uh his with
his last two moves H4 and kh2 he he has
broadcasted that and
um his only problem is time and that
will make Jan think well maybe I'm also
have some chances to win because he'll
see that clock but that clock can be
can also be a bad thing for your arm yep
because you should be focusing on the
position not on your opponent's time if
you start thinking oh I have to flag my
opponent
maybe you'll destroy your position in
the process and Magnus is a great Blitz
player too and a bullet player as as
well so he can easily make a bunch of
good moves in time pressure if he needs
to the energy though it's palpable you
can feel it it's chessual Robert I wish
you didn't throw to me right there but
um you know playing for a win sometimes
involves playing for a loss and Magnus
is living on the edge because he has
three minutes left to make some very
important moves whereas for Jan if he as
Fabiano was saying goes for the kill
because he sees Magnus time that can
really backfire some of these lines we
sell the Rooks teaming up and queen B3
is you know that's the move that he
wants to play like John wants to play
that a move some of mags's next moves
will be quite easy and I takes E5 or C5
or you know Rook C7 Rook d70s type of
ideas but if you're on calculates which
he has the time to do and figures that
leads to a minimum a draw for him then
that makes sense to go for
it's move 31 so that means that
nine more moves to make Before Time
control and as you can see three minutes
for Magnus
16 minutes for Yawn is also not a ton of
time for the record
um especially given that yon could face
critical decisions of his own in a few
moves he also doesn't have so many
logical moves besides Queen B3 yeah I
was just thinking what about the move
Bishop to D6
you want to prepare Queen B3 but in a
bit of a slower way but then White's
Rook drops back to C2
Bishop G6 Rook um Rook 5 to C2
and now if Queen to B3
we're looking at this Knight C5 ID again
that we saw before if Bishop takes C5 B
takes C5 that pawn runs through so uh
maybe black has Queen to be one after
Knight C5
yeah you can't take the bishop because
the Rook that's actually probably the
only move it's going to be one wait was
there Knight C1 instead of yeah I was
wondering Knight C1 Queen to B1 your
queen is sort of stuck down there so
like the thing about this is oh maybe
maybe not Knight to E2 is is quite
strong
but I was wondering like what's your
next move I guess you have Queen A1 at
some point yeah but it feels like black
is kind of stuck so maybe I can bring
the king in and try to like trap the
queen eventually it looks it certainly
looks dangerous for black there
Yawn is correctly taking his time though
here right we're all we're all nervous
here and excited especially with uh
magnus's time pressure but we should we
should give credit here Robert again
this is a poised you on right now right
he's not rushing this decision that's
what time management is all about making
sure that you Leverage The Clock as a
weapon when the critical moment comes so
he really should use whatever he has
here to make the make the best decision
yeah if you play too quickly you might
just lose in a couple moves so he knows
that Magnus is more than quick enough to
make it to the time control and he does
not want to just play for Magnus
to falter you have to really come up
with ideas yourself so Queen B3 is what
we keep talking about he's just working
through those lines of Fabiano point out
with Rooks on the seventh rank barreling
down at Black's King but if he sees that
he can just make a draw in that position
that's what he should go for I I
actually am quite impressed with how
Magnus although we see the time and uh
we're thinking that well this is a scary
moment for him
he was for most of the game Magnus was
uh never better really objectively and
at some moments most likely slightly
worse oh well he goes in for Bishop B2
the second time around
that is surprising and Magnus quickly
responds Rook C5 we know time pressure
is real and Magnus was ready
to make his next move Queen D6 is forced
now I think he'll quickly the line we
looked at with Queen D6 it's it's the
line we looked at with oh H5 H4 and the
King was on G1 before now it's on H2
this might not make any real difference
okay let's show real quick on the
analysis board the line that we looked
at uh before our last break Queen D6 the
key is you can't take with the Knight
because the Rook is hanging and if you
take with the Rook the queen can take on
D3 we have trades of pawns for others
but another really key point is that if
a move like Rook to C2 is played the
bishop does not get trapped in these
variations because the queen actually
attacks B4 and can get
the bishop out of its tight box it's
starting to wonder after Bishop A3 here
okay and I go Knight F4 can I go for
your king side like I understand I'm
risking a lot by giving up my A and B
pawns but that H5 Pawn is quite
important to defend the black king yeah
F6 to fall next maybe I'll bring my Rook
up to D4 and swing it along the fourth
rank over to G4 wow like the black king
is really not that safe and Fabiano's
idea of Rook D7 Rook C7 Knight takes E6
all of those are in the air and Black's
King could be in some serious dangerous
I I have to say this is terrifying for
black now that I see it this is an
excellent idea
um like let's look a bit deeper into it
because Magnus has time to think he
doesn't have his own time to think but
he's got his opponent's time to think
and John is thinking so now let's see
black should probably I don't know if
black should play Queen days before but
let's just say black does it now I'm
thinking Rook to D7 yeah
because we don't care about the material
we care about Checkmate and that
contains the idea of Knight takes E6 or
Knight takes H5 is always on the cards
but more importantly I think Rook to C7
yeah I was going to say this is and
there's no way to defend that pawn
that's just hitting there it's
fascinating two Rooks in a knight is a
checkmate and as soon as that point we
were looking at a previous line with H4
H5 included and I'm saying that pawn is
cemented on a light square and Knight F4
comes even more Force because you're
winning a pawn in the process and a line
that I had a mistake earlier when I was
trying to take on E5 with Knight Indigo
Rook takes E5 I was just looking at the
king side for some potential attack and
Fabiano's point is so well taken with
Rooks on the seventh rank could be
absolutely devastating because that's a
blistering attack you just get both
those Rooks up there with the knight's
help that will likely lead to a check
Manning attack and the bishop on A3
Queen on B4 that configuration of pieces
is nowhere near your king which is under
Fire
forces will move like Queen E5 but then
the Rook comes back to C5 yeah Queen
five allows Rook C5 but I think that
you're you have the right idea that we
shouldn't allow those Rooks on the
seventh ring maybe Queen to E7 is the
correct move
giving up the H5 Pawn but preventing the
most dangerous thread of all which is
the mating net there's the second most
dangerous idea which is Rook to C8 and I
think that's still super dangerous oh
wow Bishop takes B4 Rook to d8 this is a
problem that King cannot escape and
actually it's because of the structure
imagine Black's F6 Pawn is on G6 that
can easily escape to F6 yep but because
of this structure
Black's King is sort of boxed in by his
own pawns and after F5 there's always
going to be Knight takes H5 so if we
just continue the line Bishop takes B4
and I think why he's already winning
Rook two to d8 let's say F5 might take
Knight takes H5 King to G6 okay I think
Rook h8 uh probably among others will
Rook to h8 at the very least and Rook to
ga next that's Checkmate yeah that's me
that's guys has young blown this was
Bishop was Bishop E2 a a blunder
but what are his other moves here he
only has moves on the on the D file
right Queen to D7 Rook five to C2 is
winning a piece
yeah again everyone the reason this is
the only line we're looking at is
because moves like Bishop B5 are maybe
other things but F4 is is is it looks
like it wins material yeah and even if
not the material then you've Knight C5
Rook D7 yeah you didn't even lose the A3
Pawn right and you're still continuing
your attack oh my God
looks nervous yeah and and magnus's
quick response to Rook C5
showed he was ready and I think
I think he's feeling it and we were
talking about this as soon as it
happened once the queen was captured as
two Rooks it felt like black was in
danger he just brought his Queen back to
D6 Rook D1 whoa
Rook D1 by Magnus instead of Rook C2 in
the e-bell bar does not like that move
I've never been so disappointed
came as a glass of cold water what's the
idea
he just wants to play Bishop A3 Rook B5
I don't know
um shocked well especially because he
had time to he was thinking that whole
time on John's clock yeah I don't know I
mean this idea of Rook 5 and C2 and
Knight of four wasn't immediately
obvious
but Rook D1 is a weird move and this
looked really good I mean this is not
immediately obvious but it is it is an
idea we've been looking okay wait a
second we've got rapid fire move so we
got to stay with the live position
Rook takes B5 that's moved 34 Magnus
officially under the three minute mark
I'm very surprised and you know at the
start of that position once the two
Rooks were captured I'd mentioned the
Rook coming back to C2 we're treating
moves are often the most difficult to
see in chess but he you know stopped in
C5 he was getting active Rook back to C2
though it connected all of White's
pieces the harmony was there to take one
step back and like three steps forward
into the attack so I understand what
he's doing H5 can follow the Rook can go
to A5 I don't think that white at the
moment is in that series of danger but
if that Queen can snake into the
position yeah and keep that past a pawn
going that could be a problem the bishop
on A3 is locked over there so even if
white loses the B4 Pawn for you know you
trade off the minor pieces and black
guys keep the a pawn I don't think
that's a gonna be winning chances for
black because white can use the Rooks to
Circle that pawn yeah it
it's not obvious what Black's next move
is
um
E5 I know I've mentioned this move a
bunch of times E5 still comes to mind
for me Knight F4 is no longer an idea
and E4 is a threat well that's what Rook
is unprotected so you still can't move
the Knight oh you have Knight B2 yeah
Knight B2 but it's very tactically
awkward because let's say let's just say
that white plays Knight B2 here Queen to
A6 Rook to A5 and queen to E2 wins
material that's a problem so
E5 looks a bit awkward
it's like I don't I don't know if Rook
C2 and Knight F4 was uh was winning for
white or better for white or just equal
but it was exciting it looked it looked
pretty good I mean are we just taking
for granted that I mean regard maybe
we're taking for granted
how obscure this idea was I mean we
found it but we've been analyzing this
position had the luxury of three people
plus an email bar maybe this idea was
just really obscure and Magnus just
hadn't considered it yeah it's it's of
course difficult to sacrifice your whole
Queen side we have Queen to D7 from yawn
looks makes sense okay um
he's like he's trying to freeze Bishops
over Rook A5 there's Bishop takes beef
yeah I was gonna say all the show Brooke
takes H5 you win the you win the pawn
and the Knight is still pinned to the
rook and that now that apong will start
to run so maybe Magnus has to play like
Rook to B6 and Rook C5
oh okay and this is Rook C4 Rook D4 yeah
he's just trying to deal with that PIN
so Bishop takes B4 Rook C4 Bishop goes
somewhere let's say f8 Rook to D4
Queen goes somewhere in white might
start with the bishop on f8 protects A3
so this is not it has to start Knight F4
he has to start his counter play now I'm
just gonna say it's not a foregone
conclusion that you're corralling this a
pawn as long as I've kept my Bishop no
the a pawn lives the a pawn lives yeah
the apron lives this is really dangerous
let's just say A3 here I have a nice
shot and I take Z6 yeah oh very nice and
here white probably wins
uh it's okay basically Magnus is uh
accepting things have gone out of
control
yeah that was Rook D1 was a big big deal
I was a howler
there was a moment where this is a clear
illustration of a moment where being
able to talk through your moves can be
very helpful because Rook C8 back to C2
was my initial passive plan and at that
particular moment it was just like I
said one step back just to be passive
for a moment then you can strike forward
with getting the bishop out of play and
connecting your Rooks with each other so
the Knight was free to go and Magus
doesn't have much time the pressure's on
him whereas we can sit and ponder about
all these different moves but that's a
moment that can make or break a world
championship right
and he's he's in some danger right now
no he's in he's in real danger I mean I
it's Magnus so I'm I'm I'm always giving
the you know Magnus bias itis here
suffering from it for years I assume
that he'll figure out a way to set up
some sort of Defense but black is the
one pushing for a win yeah I think his
time was not such a huge Factor when he
had safety and he had safety for for
quite a while yeah until he made this
work do you want to move now there's no
longer safety because black actually won
that Queen side and and Will Come Away
with and
a past Day part why we'll get his
counter play there's still two Rooks at
night which are very dangerous and very
sharp and Tactical
but now it's out of control and his time
puts him at serious risk especially here
Robert you made a really good point we
were initially considering that Rook
retreating idea as as you said just
almost an instructive point right about
how sometimes you have to coordinate and
Retreat before you can go forward and
the more we looked at it the more we
were like hey there's actually something
very very strong about that idea but the
Rooks being protected frees up the night
and all the ensuing potential tactics
against the king but I feel like we were
almost in our own Echo chamber we were
convinced this was the idea maybe in
hindsight Magnus clearly didn't even see
this idea it was the city moves are
difficult yeah they always are yeah and
he's trying to take an active defense
right now he's going to lose the B4 Pawn
he can put his Rook to C4 maybe he's
Rook to D4 but
it's getting close it's getting close to
big trouble for white if we go back to
that moment where he could have played
Rook C2 and Knight F4 yeah let's analyze
it real quick
um
right here King H2 yep uh Bishop B2 Rook
C5 Queen D6
Rook C2 Bishop A3 at some point I think
they'll start making a lot of moves but
let's say Knight F4 Queen B4 Rook D7
maybe black has the move E5 that's the
only move I can think of that he might
have here because he has to somehow deal
with
I see the eval bar is uh says white
going way up
um
there is probably something very strong
maybe it's simply Knight to D5 and Then
followed by what comes in but yeah the
queen on f8 actually defends things and
if Knight H5 King G6 that's why I
thought things weren't so easy
um well what y'all did not
let's see the game take the pawn 1965
was the answer though so at least we
solved that but all right E5 instead of
Bishop takes B4 well we mentioned this
on the previous move as an idea
and the point is the Knight the Knight
cannot move anywhere besides B2 at this
point because the Rook is hanging so as
much as we're looking at ideas like this
not possible
and so what if Rook to C4
is it going to be Queen to D5 there
looks like Queen D5 might be a very
strong response
why can't coordinate yeah yeah why can't
coordinate you know why E5 is so strong
it's exactly the type of move you play
when your opponent's under time pressure
rather than going for Bishop takes B4
the forcing lines that even if Magnus is
worse these are forcing lines that he
probably calculated and is going to do
his best to then coordinate a knight F4
E5 with Magnus only having two minutes
to make another five moves is an
absolute nightmare it looks like a good
practical chance
um it's not easy to find the move
forward yeah exactly I'm wondering if
Knight B2 is an option that's what I was
thinking just Retreat the Knight to B2
but there's Queen F and then just go
back because there's no E4 there I'm
wondering if I mean something you have
to consider even Bishop takes B4 things
but uh that's a bit sad if you have to
start playing Knight B2 and Knight D3
and hoping your opponent has no we have
moved Rook to C2 is on the board after
E5
black can still take the B4 Pawn as the
Knight remains pinned to The undefended
Rook on D1 so what does he want after
that
I don't see an obvious maybe Knight
beats to then I mean it's Queen still
yeah or yeah Queen F5
looks excellent looks winning it's
nerve-wracking
um well I'm sure he has something in
mind but that this doesn't look good at
some moment we have to look for a
bailout from Magnus where let's say
Bishop takes B4 uh Rook A2 just to put
some of these in the word A3 if you
could take on B4 give up your rope and
then take on yeah blockade A3 and if you
could make this work where you defend
the F2 Pawn white doesn't lose but
within the awkward placement of wise
pieces you can get in some trouble no
that's I was just about to say it's
exactly the type of thing we call that a
defensive sacrifice if if white could
take off everything on the queen side
even if at the cost of maybe even a
knight and a rook in some positions but
sorry that position actually if you keep
going just one step further there okay I
think we have a good example Rook A2 uh
wait black Bishop B4 okay Bishop B4 Rook
a two okay three takes on B4 take D1
Rook takes A3 Queen D2 this whole line
and if you play Knight D3 and E4 I think
Knight F4
here's wf2 but you can bring your knight
back to G2 and I don't really know this
should be a fortress yeah it looks like
a fortress but actually
um maybe this is an instructor move
instead of Queen to D2 but let's bring
up the analysis board here real quick
just to make sure that we don't lose
sight of the live position because Queen
D5 is on the board and we're we're
looking at this okay so not Bishop B4
what did they have in mind it was Bishop
before with such a natural move I'm like
I'm kind of puzzled y'all is trying to
keep this confusing for Magnus with
these moves but he might risk and blow
his you know white has a move here there
is E4 as a move
for white
that probably doesn't work out I was
trying to like trap the bishop okay
there are four moves to make though with
only 48 seconds that's good that's an
excellent move you're connecting your
Rooks which means the Knight can move
and you're covering the A2 Square so
even if things get bad perhaps you put
one Rook on E2 one Rook on A2 and say
you have an outside pass Pawn but you
actually can't make any progress but
block needs to be careful as well yeah I
was going to say this move prevents you
from taking B4
yeah so Queen B3 looks like the move for
black
um well why does threatening Rook A2 now
so black should play Queen B3 guys look
at John's time he also has four more
moves to make wow control they're both
super long this is again there is no
increment here which means what you see
is what you get
yeah this is this is pretty he can
actually play Knight C5 and Rook D7
maybe he's gonna go on the five at the
end
and oh wow 96 just King G6 yeah yeah he
goes Rook A2 see this is what we're
talking earlier that if we get the trade
or the um minor pieces then I don't
think white but white wide wins the pawn
directly right should be foreign
takes Knight Rook takes bishop and the a
pawn Falls white is the only one with
winning chances in that end game yeah
why there's only one winning chances but
I think that it's still a draw because
White's King will always come after
Perpetual if the Rooks get too active
Okay one minute for Yan to make three
more moves
two more moves from Carlson will be
required before time is added
we have 32 000 of you on YouTube 87 000
of you on Twitch for the hypest moment
we've had so far in the 2021 video World
Chess Championship What's So Scary is
Jan has to recognize that the two Rooks
against Queen scenario yeah with all
pawns the same so the boy that that's a
draw because in your head you may think
the Rooks will team up against the pawn
like we talked about earlier right and
I'll lose and so you might be afraid to
do that wait what just happened E4
Knight F4 oh nicey five no this is this
could be true John is blowing this
position here with no time now well like
Queen before 94 because if you take the
Knight you lose the bishop
yeah I was also thinking if Rook d2c2
that those pieces are all trapped they
can't move but maybe white can't make
problems we're at time control by the
way Magnus Carlson has reached time
control yon Napoli she has one more move
to make or he loses on time
oh my gosh and what's the move here like
it's not easy because Queen 64 Rook A3
is the worst version of all this that
might just lose in the spot because
white would bring the other Rook to A2
win A4 gun has made his move Queen B3
oh my gosh
Rook dc2 still seems like the right move
to play Knight to D2 but wait I want to
go back one moment since they've they've
reached time control
and neither of them has
blown the game away yeah I'm wondering
about this moment Rook D to C2 here
black cannot move
any piece besides his King in Pawns and
let's say black plays F5
white doesn't have an obvious move but
there's actually Knight takes A4 now
and the bishop is lost and this is a
very different version The Pawn on e4
actually takes away all of Black's
Perpetual check possibilities this one
might be really bad this could have been
winning for what this one might just be
winning because you gang up on F7 and
there's no way for black to create a
Perpetual check possibility or to create
F4 counter play Black spawns are fixed
you can even try to gang up on F5 that
might be the real part yeah because if
you win F5 you defend F2 in a lot of
sharp and then and then Black's done so
this one was really dangerous for black
I think Magnus might have missed what a
tough move to see in time pressure
obviously a subtle Rook Shuffle rather
than the forceful Knight capture I think
he's also Queen B1 I guess after uh
Queen to B1 but why can play Knight
takes a four
and yeah the pawn E4 is not where you
want it to be yeah we might yeah the
bishop is also like where does it go
because let's say Bishop to D6 the
Knight C3 comes and E4 is is hanging
right also could we've taken on e4 in
that position after Queen B1 then go
Knight takes E4 maybe yeah because now
Black's pieces are all over the place
and Knight C3 becomes a threat if you go
Bishop B4 there's Rook C to beat oh no
it's not Rook C to B2 because or maybe
90
but it's like it's like it's right there
it's very thin it's very a very thin
defense for black there might be
yeah it's difficult but for
Bishop before
Rook a to B2 Queen to D1 Knight to C3
maybe we we pick up that pawn slowly we
just Corral it with
with uh you know Rook A3 Rook A2 Etc
um and now black is losing on the king
side so so he might be in serious
trouble here that was losing right
because once you get that pawn you've
broken F4 which defends F2 while
attacking F6 that looks done well even
in the live position I think I think we
might still be I mean everything you
guys have been foreshadowing is
happening if if all Magnus has to do is
Corral the queen side come hell or high
water because this King side structure
is a nightmare for black but now that
pawn probably gets to A3 it's a very
concrete the bishop backs up and A3
comes in yeah let's say Rook D to C2 and
the move you said Bishop to f8
and white has no way of getting that
pawn the pawn remains on A3 although you
could argue Magnus is losing chances are
almost
zero here as well now that the E4 Pawn
is falling you could even give up the
Knight for the pawn in some lines and I
don't know that the queen and Bishop can
really beat the two Rooks over there I
think Magnus was super close to losing
this game so he's probably happy to
escape to a position where he isn't in
any real danger anymore for that moment
Queen to D5 by Yan I'm I'm still super
yeah this this was the moment where I I
don't understand what was screaming to
be played I mean it's a pawn
yeah it's a free Pawn
he I I think a move earlier we were we
were applauding his patients his ability
to maintain the tension not play the
obvious forcing move that you kind of
want to avoid when your opponents under
time pressure and I think he had the
same practical idea here he he didn't
want to take the beep on until he had to
is it possible he just missed the
response of Rook D2 because was Rook D2
an only move I I know but it's it's a
that's an easy move to miss right it's
also an easy move to make because you're
dealing with this pin for so long you
can't move your knight Rook D2 connects
everything and that's the place from the
Rooks that we wanted earlier when it
probably had great winning chances for
white so yeah it's honestly sort of
both players trying to win in certain
moments I've given you on a lot of
credit in this game for B5 G takes F6
some of these decisions were great even
this E5 move just trying to win and not
make Magnus life easy but we could tell
that once Magnus gave up his Queen for
those two Rooks he knew that he had good
chances to outlast Jan even though the
position initiative level it remains
level there's so many difficult
decisions for black and that moment with
Rook C5 back to C2 was missed and then
here yes Queen D5 I think was very
strange from Beyond probably trying to
like force a win somewhere or just
confuse Magnus but is objectively not
the move
yeah I think Jan was in this sort of
Blitz mode where he was thinking okay
Magnus has something in mind after
Bishop takes before rather than find out
what it is let's make a move that will
surprise him and make him burn time or
something wrong approach in general you
should be trying to make the best moves
not the most confusing moves
um
and and they're playing a world
championship match not
not a Blitz game you know they get more
time after move 40 so these moves are
super critical if one side ends up being
winning and I think they were both close
to winning at some point because I mean
because of this queen D5 Bishop takes
before I think Jan would have been close
to winning
later on Magnus was super close I think
to to being winning
so yeah this is a game that's I think
um
it had a lot of impressive ideas for
both players and also a lot of serious
mistakes which is understandable because
they were so low on time in such a
complicated position but this queen D5
move kind of strikes me as like what
what was the thought process behind it
besides just I want to confuse my
opponent one question for you is we keep
saying they play the board in front of
them every single game no matter the
previous results do you think they're
tired of making draws or do you think
they both saw a moment that could
totally change the match in their favor
well they both had Ambitions in this
game like we can see that they I think
they were going in their minds between
should I play for win and now I'm
worried should I try to like uh try to
save the get to safety
um but then
like yeah I thought Magnus was playing
for a win with this H4 King H2 I thought
it was very impressive these moves
practically speaking especially low on
time and extremely Brave to play in such
a way when he had
um safe options like Rook C5 we
mentioned yeah and uh Jan it looked like
was getting to some danger we mentioned
this work C2 and Knight F4 idea it's of
course understandable that Magnus missed
it uh Rook D1 was a serious mistake I
think he felt like
things were getting out of control maybe
he missed this bishop B2 Queen D6 and
then he started to panic in this
position and he thought I'm getting low
on time I can't start to burn time here
and potentially lose on the clock so he
just chose something turned out to not
be very good but he went with it
um fascinating because again if you were
missing our analysis in this moment
Robert and Fabi both really highlighting
what a what a brilliant potential
turnover we could have had here right
where where offense becomes defense and
vice versa this move Rook to C2 a
defensive retreating move if Bishop
takes A3 met by Knight F4
and you start to see that uh black is
actually maybe in very serious Danger
because not even because of the pawn but
because of things like this coming
and as Bobby said forget the pawn when
you've got a mating net this is exactly
what the doctor ordered for Carlson that
what a shocking finish that could have
been I think if he had played this way
and played it quickly he would have had
good chances to win the game yeah
I like we see that
the eval bar is not suggesting that what
is winning or anything
but it is possible that had the
computers underestimating what's attack
yeah that's one thing another thing is
maybe black has some miracle defense but
that's not relevant in a practical game
fascinating Rook C2 was a very tough
find of one that Magnus was unable to
come up with and after Bishop A3 Queen
D7
and equally equally just as good of a
chance for for Jan seemed to have
slipped away after the E5 Rook C2 Bishop
takes before I mean this is
if this bishop gets to f8 and this Pawn
gets to A3
we're probably talking about a black
victory
I think Jan will be kicking himself
over this this one move regardless of
whether it's a draw
I mean especially if he loses but it
even if it's a draw I think he will
really see this as a missed chance
Magnus had that chance but it was it was
a tough one it was a complicated one
here you're just you're just taking a
pawn you know like you know you're
making the move that uh that comes to
mind for everyone the first candidate
move Bishop takes before
Queen D5 was chosen and Ben oh man did
we have a Time scramble Queen B3 or K2
was there was there anything else
besides E4 as we see Magnus back at the
board now I think Bishop takes B4
was still we mentioned it this version
is probably I guess he wasn't sure about
it but it's probably a drop Bishop
before Rook D to B2 Queen takes D3 Rook
takes B4
the a pawn Falls
but since black has a flexible structure
not the E component E4 but upon E5 I
think he can just harass that F2 pawn
and white king and stop white from
getting active with the Rooks and one
critical point by the way is Bishop B4
uh Rook a to B2 may look pretty enticing
but the problem is as a to B2 you take
the Rook on D2 so you give up your queen
right back for the two Rooks you get
this pass on you win the game so yeah of
course Rook D to B2 is probably what I'm
saying you just get the bishop give up
the Knight and you win the a pawn so
yeah I mean Knight takes E4 is a hard
move to criticize Fabiano's Rook C2 just
keeping black stuck right you you can't
really move very easily for black that's
not that easy of a move to play even
though it's extremely understandable and
if you give Magnus one more minute on
the clock I think he could play Rook to
C2 but Knight takes E4 seems so strong
you're taking a Central Pawn you're
leaving black with all of these isolated
pawns on the board and if you take that
Knight on e4 you then lose the a pawn
and just lose the game on the spot so
that would just be a disaster and just
not everyone a simple idea like Rook D4
Rook F4 guard zip2 A4 balls and white
white wins this easily well I think that
we could
um we could pretty much figure out if
Rook dgc2 was actually winning move or
not because after Rook DTC 2 Flex
options are extremely Limited
he only has basically two moves one is
F5 one is Queen to B1
after F5 Knight takes A4
I think black will probably take Rook C3
let's move the queen somewhere probably
doesn't matter very much where or
something yeah Rook uh take with the
yeah C Rook black makes a way to move
Queen E1 for example Queen F1 Rook two
a five
King to G6 you have to defend that pawn
now let's say Rook to B2
so you teleport your Rook to F4 yeah I
don't know that you can win though well
which move do you make F6 okay but
you're gonna get into zuk's one
right Rook Rook B to A2 okay
you can't move your king because Rook
takes up five so you have to move your
queen so Queen D1 I guess yeah okay now
uh Queen to D1
as long as you're never threatening to
go here then I'm not in six month well
let's play Rook to A7 okay
okay now Rook to
I see that evil Barbie creeping but I
don't believe if you want to go full
Nigel I'm going forward I'm waiting for
you F4 king of 5K don't you turn your
back on the ocean or Nigel short I mean
those are two equally dangerous things
depending on the right setting
but that probably doesn't work actually
because a lot of these variations white
can take with the G Pawn so yeah but but
even if I don't go Nigel I'll let you
play this looks very difficult to crack
this might yeah might be a draw I was
thinking that with the Rook on the
seventh you can create zugs along again
but Rook to B7 King to H6 or Rook to B2
King to age six yeah because if you're
not on my f pawns I can Shuffle the king
yeah and if you are on the F pawns then
I can't but I can go here and the point
but here you can Shuffle the kingdom
what here you can Shuffle it oh and I
can go to G7 you're right but if the
part work is on A5 then the queen has to
move the closest you were was here
though this yeah it goes to D1
it has to go to D1 well it's white to
move first so yeah let's say rookie two
Queen to D1 and the point is that I feel
like I feel like Rook 82 is the wrong
one what if you go to C2 so that you
keep this open
so now now my queen oh that's yeah I
think oh but I can go to E1 now and you
still can't go up that's the difference
and if Rook to D5 then Queen to F1 yeah
and now wait let's try another one now
Rook to B2
you know so if I if I
um
if I go to E1 now you have King G2 yeah
The Rook guards D1 preventing and then
King G2 and it's over Rook goes to F5
yeah yeah if this happens King G2 Rook
to B5 takes up five and yes
and if F4 y just plays G takes F4 okay
but hold on so we I was I was helping
you out there to break down my own
blockchain I'm not going to help you
anymore Bobby
um
well and I have no chance of winning
this you have no chance against me your
move yeah I worked to D5
I think the D5 was a really key point
you're you have you can't go to D1
anymore
you have to go to E1 or C1 and then Rook
to B5 comes again everyone the queen
wants to stay hitting the F Pawn if the
queen is not hitting the F Pawn the
Rooks are doubled and this Pawn will be
captured defending if the king ever
moves off the F Pawn Falls so the only
way to maintain this is Queen here but
that allows the king to help himself big
fella
this is resigns and I'm frozen
just like Elsa
I always appreciate a good Frozen
reference I'm trying to figure out a way
for like if I even if I could pass the
move here yeah so that I understand
you're gonna Rook B5 then I'll play F4
and hope that I have some kind of I was
thinking about that you can mated
potential well
maybe not so quickly yeah you might have
Queen to E2 to G4 yeah a little
Perpetual but but I don't know what my
waiting move is here
okay so hold on so where are we back at
this is King G6
so King G6
Rook B2 I think this one is winning like
that's my that's my feeling so not Rook
H2 that your the Improvement is Rook to
D5 yeah which I like a lot maybe black
had to keep the queen on D1 in general
just to stop work to do Rook D5 can we
just just go for it really quickly here
if I play Queen C4
Rook B5 Rook B5 and then I try F4
oh yeah a gf4 queen E2 that's oh Robert
this is probably a draw very nice you
gain a Tempo note that the Rooks cannot
come back to help and the king not
helping himself do a victory at least
anymore because of the Perpetual check
well if you go too far just Queen I
change
and just you just go here oh there's two
right yeah this one and if the King goes
too far then F2 Falls yeah okay but
after Queen C4 I I just want to play
Rook to D1
we can play this one as slowly as we
want the queen can't get to F1 anymore
now Rook to D2 King G2 very slowly we
build up King G2 Rook G2 eventually one
of the Rooks comes back and the other
one joins the party they're not the same
thing
you have a four at the end even even so
at the end of all those lines you have
F4 but why can go for a Checkmate Rook
to D7 Rook B7 I don't want your I don't
want your iPhone
I wanted to play King G2 Rook to D7 Bob
Barker on this I want the whole thing I
want the whole thing Price is Right yep
anyway like if this is not losing it's
super super difficult to hold yeah
that's a really good point so Rook D1
black we'll just Shuffle this to show
when you when you're in when you're when
you're ready you go here or up to D6
forget the pawn maybe maybe the F6 Pawn
is the real Target
I mean so what we're establishing for
those wondering was whether or not
Magnus Carlson perhaps had a winning
opportunity with the brilliant
suggestion from our own Fabiano caruana
Rook to C2 sort of freezing black
and we were trying to figure out is this
is this end game winning for white with
F5 where you sacrifice the knife for the
pawn you regain the bishop
and it seems indeed
that they're just miserable there is a
way to coordinate it takes a little bit
of shuffling but eventually this idea
here is just that's just some
instructive stuff right there that's
that's brilliant flushing the queen out
so that you can then move the pieces on
your terms preventing the queen from
having any witch square that would have
a perpetual
oh well I think that Magnus saw the idea
of Rook dc2 but didn't realize he was he
was down to like 20 seconds so we can
understand uh he he didn't realize that
Knight takes A4 was a threat and so he
thought Rook dc2 F5 and and we wait
there's nothing to do but Knight takes
A4 if he had seen that I think he would
have played Rook dc2
for sure
well it looks like in the game even
though we didn't get that variation he
took an E4 he did bring a rook to C2 and
we were talking about Bishop f8 Pawn to
A3 and black better be in time for that
because otherwise Rooks can start going
to the seventh rank if you're not
careful and that could possible okay
it's on the board
Rook to C7
if A3
the nice thing about my queen is she
guards F7 yeah so you don't have time to
go good girl D7 yeah I don't think you
want to start abandoning that pawn so
quickly maybe after Bishop Buffet Knight
to C5
wait sorry what
maybe bishop Buffet Knight to C5
is his idea okay
if Queen to before there's Rook to D4
that wins a pawn
indeed it does
I don't understand why the eval bar is
not agreeing with is it like Bishop
what's what's oh Queen to B1 oh yeah
with a Tempo yeah black still has this
so okay
but yeah it feels like
we're entering
territory where black is no longer in
much danger white is not in danger
either
but I guess we'll see what Magnus has in
mind well it feels like Magnus might be
about to go in for a long post move 40
thing so we're gonna we're gonna give
ourselves a break I mean my adrenaline
was was up and down gonna need some uh
some post-traumatic I mean I'm gonna
need some therapy after that moment
right there but definitely uh we uh it
has been worth the wait for the
excitement that we just have with both
players scrambling and time pressure and
we still have a lot of action ahead so
don't go anywhere we have much more for
game six for the 2021 feed a World Chess
Championship we take a very quick break
when we return We dive in to all that
we'll be analyzing at the break because
that's what we do we we can't stop
talking about it don't go anywhere
chess.com's coverage brought to you by
coinbase will return
turn it down turn it down come on hey
yeah yeah let's go chess.com make you
know you gotta love this cause we
bringing all of y'all the best coverage
commentary that'll keep you into action
plus you get rest from yours truly the
matching uh so you better keep it locked
in no doubt make them know what you
watching I'm a king never no Pawn feed a
Chess Championship on chess.com peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is is this so here's what we're saying
yes
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship in one minute
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we got to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
chest.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in a free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
[Music]
and audio
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready yeah
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work soon
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in a free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
get
discuss it on
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
we are back here as game six it's been
quite the Thriller today's day in the
2021 vide World Chess Championship
continues
we have uh a little more action on the
board with the move Knight to D3 but let
me remind you first who is with you
Robert Hess Fabiano caruana Danny wrench
we're going to be here until this thing
comes to a close at some point in the
middle of December so if you haven't hit
that follow button before or that
subscribe button now's the time to do so
to make sure that you're a part of uh we
some are calling it The Greatest Show
in Hess
appreciate that Danny
but the game we have here it seems like
the players have calmed down after
reaching the time control no longer have
to worry about losing on the clock and
we saw Queen B5 you did not want to take
that Knight on C5 John figured that
would get him in trouble we keep talking
with two Rooks against Queen Dynamic
where the Rooks can team up on Pawn so
that's why the queen went back and
ideally black can get that pawn to A3
safely and for Magnus he wants to just
get that pollinate for if you could
somehow go after it it would be good
news for him well I thought you were
highly wants to get that part on H5
because you were talking about a dynamic
earlier where there's there's there's
there's a world where this Pawn is lost
I'm not sure who who Ventures far enough
to take it but I did the Knight of rook
and if this a pawn doesn't become
anything more than just something pretty
on A3
this is this is still a three result
game
yeah it is and I think Knight F4 must be
magnus's idea yeah but the word he used
is is very good venture because White's
Rook to take that pawn White's Rook has
to go on an adventure abandoning the a
pawn totally right you take the H5 Pawn
but that's not a game deciding Pawn it's
a big Pawn to win but not if it costs
you're working the process so let's say
I was thinking black might play Bishop
to B4 here
as an idea
asking why do you want to play rookie
two or do you want to play Rook D5 oh on
Rook D5 if you want Rook D5 then there's
Queen to A4
let's say you play Knight takes H5
and play King to age six
I don't know if Rook to C8 is suddenly
some sort of mating mating that
potentially but that has to be
calculated because white is promoting a
black sorry black is promoting a pawn
there and if white plays Rook to A2 well
that would be very bad because of Queen
to B3
so maybe white has Rook C8 there but
there's a huge amount to calculate it's
not at all
like why he's playing without risk let's
see Rook C8 if A2
then Rook to h8 King to G6 Knight to F4
King to G7 and Rook to d8 I think this
wins for white
okay I thought we had a mate that way
but yeah we made this one at five night
H5 and and made on G8
um
so yeah it's it's dangerous for both
black might uh end up with two queens
white might end up with uh which is
better which is better checkmate
one is rarer than the other what is
rarer than the other but okay a funny
idea too this isn't the aggressive
version of it but if that H5 Pawn Falls
there's a world where this Rook has to
give itself up for a pawn and the
position is still a draw
possibly but in that case black is the
one who is playing for when maybe white
has a fortress because well especially
if Knight and Bishop portrayed then then
it's just a draw The Rook on F4 is
cemented and black with the extra Queen
can't make any progress with Knight and
Bishop that's a kind of unusual end game
but not with Magnus wants for sure to to
try to draw in in a manner where he's
down a queen and he holds a fortress
potentially
well this is one of those positions
where the eval bar may be hovering
around 50 50 because the struggle is
real but that doesn't mean we're we're
lacking Fighting Chess this is this is
what the people pay for it's it's an
unbalanced Material Exchange two Rooks
for the queen and then a battle As Old
As Time Knight versus Bishop
and you know we were just talking about
a time trouble phase and time travel a
Time trouble phase oh yeah time travel
is for a different show but
it feels like just a few minutes ago
they were down to seconds yeah but you
can already see the time trouble looming
on the horizon it's amazing yeah it
happens very quickly it's a complicated
position and it's easy to think here for
half an hour on one position because
it's so complicated yeah and then
suddenly you're you're down to a few
minutes again
the time control on the other side does
have increment for the record so now
that they have reached move oh wait no
increment doesn't have to move six to
six okay I apologize that's right so the
players are still playing with that
sudden death uh Dynamic meaning 34
minutes is all that you have to reach
move 60 16 more moves still but but
nevertheless that's that's as as Bobby
said we're already back in a position
where Magnus has to at least be very
aware of his clock well yeah both of
them do because I can see yon taking a
significant amount of time at this
moment because Bishop B4 is a very
responsible decision you are inviting
white to directly attack your king with
attack on the queen check on the king
taking material in the process
so there's a lot to calculate here
um does he have other
more useful moves in Bishop to B4
I'm I'm not sure if there's another way
to deal with the threat of work today
there's no there's no way to stop it
anyway Robert and there's just some
lines I was thinking about let's say
Bishop B4 and I go Rook D4 if I just
stop a square short my poison Knight
takes H5 check is now a threat and if
you play Queen to A4 what I'm starting
to wonder here is after Queen A4 can I
play Rook C2 to C4
and you go A2 I take on B4 and you'll
take on if you take them before here you
get your next Queen but I win H5 and
there's no way black is ever winning
that position maybe white wins I think
white should yeah well I probably slowly
wins this one and that comes back to F4
the F2 Pawn will be defended by a king
most likely and why we'll just put the
Rook on D4 first king here to feel warm
and cozy put the pawn on H5 and then
I'll figure it out later and the reason
I bring this particular line up is
because if white can give up a rook for
the bishop and the pawn over there only
white can win that position and white
actually has quite good chances because
of the isolated double Pawns in the f
file the isolated H5 pawn and then the
rook and Knight can team up and that's
the thing is we know a queen is better
than a rook and Knight in terms of point
value but what a rook in the Knight can
do that a queen can't is team up on a
square so a queen can Attack One Pawn
then white defends the pawn you're not
bringing anything else Into The Party
The Rook in the night can pile up
pressure so my Rook D4 move was just
trying to get is amazing to an end but
that's just something that I'm keeping
in the back of my mind is is there a
time and a place where I can actually
get rid of the bishop in the pond and
try to win from there we have a move
that was not Bishop to B4 for the record
Queen A5
still inviting Rook D5 but I guess with
an idea of gaining a Tempo on Queen A4
there are no back rank the checkmates
that five and I was showing before you
can't quite reach because the bishop
will cut off the last rank so maybe
that's a game-saving Tempo in certain
positions so so we say Rook D5 Queen A4
maybe maybe you do your check thing I go
here and your point is it still looks
very dangerous because
can I play Rook C8 here I'm wondering
yeah again Rook A2 is met by Queen B3
but wait if you go Rook C8 I've eight A2
Rook takes a f8 yeah I'm not in time you
might have two queens but I'm attacking
you this is the weirdest material
balance I've ever seen But Rook h8
King G6 Knight F4
we saw this sort of mating pattern King
G7 Rook d8 before right isn't this still
Checkmate regardless of the two queens
or not so Queen takes F4 I know then you
lose of course then oh there's Queen A2
there maybe Queen A2 oh my goodness by a
miracle survive this one but maybe not
because that King could actually hide
like let's say H5 here
King to G7 Rook to d8 Queen takes up the
other Rook to d8
Queen takes F2 King to H3
if Queen to F1 King to H4 and queen H1
King to G4 I'm hiding from checks maybe
not forever but at least for now and H6
and F5 are threatened by the way that's
mate maybe black has F5 here but who
knows yeah if if you see that look from
yawn it was like a I'm glad I brought my
thinking cap that's what he's saying
there my handy dandy notebook and my man
bun well we we didn't see Rook D5
unfortunately that would have been fun
to see but we saw
the
um slightly less active Rook to A2
now Rook D5 is an obvious threat Jan is
playing so impressively quickly it's
actually amazing
um like it looks super complicated but
he's moving
each move takes a minute for him that's
kind of crazy
is he trying to push Bishop on B2
somehow and just trap The Rook that
would be that would be a really
interesting idea because that's not a
position that allows The Rook to give
itself up for a bishop I don't think you
can coordinate it though it's too slow
well like Bishop C3
just Rook C2 let's say I said passively
rather than going up the board like
Bishop C3 you're not really threatening
your Bishop B2 because I'll just take it
with my C2 rope but here maybe white is
happy to play Knight E2
and if Bishop to E5
he has a bishop B2 we might get the same
ending that we were talking about right
yeah you suck Bishop B2 Rook CB2 it
didn't have Knight takes H5 instead of
92. Oh that's oh the queen has to guard
the bishop you did have that that's um
that's bad news for black
the King has to move somewhere
and then Knight F4 and white basically
picked up a pawn with the same
or very similar position right because
the points Bishop B2 I'm always taking
it the one thing you need to be careful
is if the queen can get the B4 and then
you put a bishop on B2
yeah that would be problematic yeah but
how does black ever achieve that if the
queen comes to B4 and Bishop B2 there is
no sacrifice and the Rooks have been
excommunicated
from each other
okay wait so
Bishop E4 is on the board
Magnus is uh that's 30 minutes to make
another 15 moves
yeah the choices between
well there is Rook D to C2 there's Rook
D5 but there's also Rook D3 that move
does make sense
Rook D3 I will go Bishop C3 though
you will probably play Bishop to C3
there because then but it's still Knight
H5 here
and then let's say King moves somewhere
f8 but over here H6 Knight D Knight F4
sorry Bishop B2 and now we just got have
to get rid of that but how do we get rid
of that Bishop
we were relying on all those Rook C8
moves right Rook to B3
King to G2 now I'm threatening Rook B
takes A3
and if Queen C1 if Queen C2 there's Rook
um takes A3 either Rook I think I have
Queen C6 check okay yeah you'll check
but uh in the end you will have to take
the rook and we will end up with the
position we said okay good and there's
Queen to C1 maybe maybe this is a
problem
um
starts to get a bit chaotic
uh
yeah like Knight D3 is Queen B1
and then Rook right but then Rook takes
A3 all right but Knight D3 there's like
Queen two first of all there's start to
be checks but maybe Queen C4 I'm
wondering about
Queen C4 you can take on A3 again maybe
you maybe you actually end up in this
end game yeah that's what I mean four
which looks pretty sad for black to me
another
another position where
only white can win yeah because it from
here what White's gonna do and it might
take a bit of time is you want to put
that Rook on F4 like we talked about
earlier because then black has no
threads and then you try to maneuver
your knight around so maybe your knight
has to go like to H3 to stabilize with
your King on H2 then you'll bring the
Rook over to the four square and then
you can keep going white can play
Forever and black is struggling Magnus
played the move up to D3 it's on the
board
it's a really instructive little
exercise that Robert just did there for
the viewers quickly recognizing where
your pieces are ideally placed both to
limit risk like to work on F4 and also
to allow the most potential
um
I think it's what both sides are doing a
lot of right now is especially Magnus if
he's already fantasizing about
variations where he gives up The Rook
for a bishop and pawn he would love a
position like that with no risk one that
only he can win and probably decent
winning Chances with the rook and Knight
versus the queen I think when there's a
material imbalance players can struggle
with creating a new imbalance yeah and
for instance there are times where one
side's up in exchange and you're often
told to think about giving the exchange
back in exchanges when one side is
captured a rook the other size capture
Knight or Bishop but you're often taught
think about giving it back for some
other kind of advantage and here we see
that white is very restricted because of
this past A3 pawn and what the claim is
is that the black's pawns are so weak
that if we eliminate the biggest threat
on the board which is the least valuable
piece the pawn but it's a very powerful
past Pawn that if we can get rid of that
then the rook and the Knight can Team Up
coordinate and cause black some serious
issues so that's why I've been thinking
about it it's a play that's going to
cause yarn some really big trouble if he
allows it and then white can play freely
with zero risk whatsoever I think the
the main thing that's scary for Magnus
now is the clock
he has 29 minutes
for 14 moves until he gets that
much desired increment that he's he's
probably been waiting for for a long
time
and it's a complicated position things
can still go out of control although it
to me it feels like white is the one
pressing for an advantage here
you never know how how
things turn out
uh if things you know in time trouble
just like we saw in the first time
trouble phase
you know Magnus lost control and
suddenly he was on the brink of losing
that could potentially happen again it's
not like this is a one-sided position
but it still feels like the momentum has
if you're rooting for for a Magnus
victory has finally
gone the norwegian's favor here just I'm
having a harder time imagining
any way for white to lose this given how
many options there are to part ways with
the rook and with the bishop and Pawn on
the queen side for a rook I think that
Jan will avoid that at any cost let's
just make a move here Queen to F5 which
is a terrible move but just to
illustrate a point uh maybe it's not
even terrible move but let's say now I
want to take on A3
we the H tripod is alive but I don't
think that pawn is alive forever
uh White will unless black can can
somehow threaten Perpetual forever if
white gets Rook D3 Rook D5 that pawn is
is going to drop off maybe Queen C2 King
G2 Queen C6 still keeps that
uh
that sort of Dynamic Fortress you know
where wherever White's King moves black
attacks the F2 pawn and and so on and so
forth
so so maybe concretely hear why it
doesn't get it but if White's work was
on D3 here he would already have Rook D5
when that H5 Pawn long term and get in
an end game where
Beyond really doesn't want to go for it
even if it's somehow holding it's a tour
maybe here Magnus would throw for the
content maybe he'd throw for content
no no okay
no uh all right Rook D3 yeah Yawn is uh
gonna take a think here
we'll we'll open up the uh the the chat
for questions from our subscribers for
Fabiano
we played that game earlier today took
some questions only from subscribers
for Fabiano and Ivonne will do the same
for the next 10 minutes or so as we
continue to analyze this so if you are a
subscriber
get us an interesting question maybe
about the game we might go back to one
of the critical positions
um
maybe about the uh the psychology the
pressure the emotion of the moment
you know Danny I I said that this queen
of five is a terrible move my first
instinct
and now I'm thinking maybe it's the
right move
because if the Rook moves to D5 then
Queen to B1 comes that Queen gets an
express lane
to attack The Rook on A2 but all these
lines are just going to allow what we
were talking about yeah but here I don't
see a way for white to continue the game
after take Queen C2 because you can't
defend that F2 Pawn maybe you can play
Knight H3 here bring the Rook to F4 and
very slowly try to win that H5 Pawn
but it's a different story with the pawn
still alive it's not going to be easy to
win that pawn God it just feels so
painful for black I mean
it might be it might also be that you
can't really do anything I'm going to go
here
eventually if I do get here then I can
then I can rethink this whole situation
well let's have a look let's say black
plays F5
or maybe F5 will
all right you play Black I'll play White
let's go I'm just thinking does black go
for F5 let's just say black and white
for the moment okay so I'll just play
King to H6 okay if I beat you here what
do you give me
I'm not giving you anything Danny
okay
um Queen to D2
I'm gonna let your Rook get to um gonna
give me what I want What a Girl Wants
King G6 what a girl needs
I don't know if you want to play E4 oh
you know I do well E4 or I could still
play King to G7 so you're not winning
the pawn directly
um so it's your choice Danny
I say that in coup a lot you know yeah I
know what are you the Ambassador and the
captain would you call it on call out an
ambassador you play if you claimed
Ambassador right here I'd call you out I
see how it is
um
okay let me try this okay King to G7
hmm
yes it's a lot more frustrating Now
You're Gonna Go Queenie too I assume or
queen you won one of those moves The
Rook will draw back to F4 I mean black
is waiting G6
you know they know I'm gonna
yeah I got I gotta I got a tickle in
mine king G7
that's all right Queen E2 you know it's
like Queen E2 and id4
Queenie one yeah I got you I got you boo
ah you're getting 93 to D5 yep
I have a goal it's called the F6 Pawn
that that starts to look bad yep
that's that's looking pretty bad now
this looks winning
okay so this actually shows there is a
plan
yes as painful as that was the E4 Pawn
initially we thought it was intended to
guard The Rook on F5 to hit H5 but it's
actually intended to open up the E3
Square for the night and Bob's your
uncle with a very long journey I went on
a journey like that to Mordor once let's
just say it ended well
ended well for you for me
hey it's okay you know what all I did
was help you help you understand this
position a little better that's all
thanks
I'm kidding we know I took the good side
okay but yeah you're right this this is
very dangerous
um yeah it's hard to evaluate it fully
maybe F5 was actually the right approach
to stop your your initial idea maybe but
it's tough to decide on this because the
pawn will be targeted on F5 more
directly now we have a goal of D4 now
the goal changes right we get the Rook
to F4 and the Knight to D4 exactly the
Knight will go yeah Rook F4 Knight G1
King G2 Knight F3 maybe you should have
fought harder to let my Rook get on the
on the F5 Square I don't see how I'm
gonna stop that a queen can't stop a
rook from so it was here
what if you what if you just wasn't it
work D5 Rook D4 uh okay you're right
okay there's no way yeah there's no way
to get that Rook to not get to that well
now that we have a goal so this is the
the takeaway if the Rooks on F4 and
black has done nothing we can put the
pawn on e4 eventually relocate the
Knight the Long Way to the E3 and D5
square and F6 is the home maybe with the
Knight on F3 I could have played Queen
to D1
because I played Queen to E2 which was
which was pretty
a pretty lousy move
um here instead of Queen E2 Queen to D1
okay so the queen was only one yeah
sorry
uh
maybe black holds it this way it's tough
to decide because why can one can poke
and prod endlessly
but yeah it might be a draw that's
actually a really good point Rook D1 now
we're no Queen do you want now we're
back to Fabi being right teaching me
something about this position we see
King H6 on the board though
and they'll open the live position we
have action
booyah
um
Magnus is also reaching for a move
which move is a question Rook to D5 he
wants to play Queen to A4
he doesn't mind losing that pawn under
which he's giving up the Paul with check
I guess yeah The Rook is that misplaced
huh yeah the Knight check was better
than the Rook check because the Rook
really doesn't yeah let's actually show
that that's so analysis real quick this
is really instructive but what Jana's
baiting Magnus to do here everyone is is
to take with the Rook
because now and you see the eve elbow
reveals that the rook and Knight are not
as ideally placed to deal with black
threats and you're not you're not giving
up the Rook anymore for the rook and the
bishop you might be giving up the Rook
for the pawn yeah this is this is
actually a very very devious little
trick here from Beyond the Palm machine
so
it's not not an easy choice I mean John
is playing this very impressively and
quickly which is important yeah
um
I think that he's played
all his last moves they haven't been
obvious moves but they've been good
moves
I wonder if Magnus will
try for for Robert's idea to put the
Rook on D4
it feels like pressuring that Bishop a
bit is actually
although The Rook um
he didn't do that the previous movie so
a couple of interesting questions coming
to us from chat we appreciate it I'm
actually going to start with one that
says do you think at this point in the
game or at any moment since time control
you think Magnus knows that he blundered
Rook D1
paraphrasing a little bit but uh um I
don't know if he'll go back to that
moment I think he will go back to move
39. and he will be upset with himself
like he's definitely thought about Mr
brooksie too yeah I think he will have
noticed that in his head yeah the the
one before that it's like it was so long
ago it will bring up the analysis board
just to show everybody real quick
because it is instructive Favi is saying
that
this particular position I'll move 39
is probably eating at Magnus because he
probably has a better sense that he
missed this trap than he does that he
missed the question from twitch chat
which was
to play the move
Rook 5 to C2 rather than Rook D1 so I
agree with you I think that seems like
the more reasonable thing the move the
40th move will be more fresh in his mind
yeah and also he might not have even he
might not have spotted that idea of Rook
c294 he didn't spot it at the time so
why would he go back to that moment
while I'll move uh 40 his 40th move
yeah uh there is like this common
uh knowledge that the 40th move often
comes with a mistake and that's because
well it's the last move before time at
the highest levels of Chess I think
there's a thing that moves 36 to moves
40 are like the worst moves in chess
yeah at the highest level you guys you
guys don't make many mistakes but moves
36 to 40. we've run some accuracy
reports on chess.com like
those moves are where most mistakes are
made north of 2700. yeah I think it's
it's purely due to time trouble yep and
the pressure and stress of the moment
that's where you you get under the most
stress
uh in this case we can we can blame
their mistakes entirely on the fact that
they were down two seconds yep and
considering how long on time they were
they actually handled the complications
pretty reasonably apart from that one I
think I think Jan will really regret
that one mistake not taking the pawn
before yeah I was going to ask because
you were saying Magnus will be thinking
and you're sort of reminiscing about the
position what he could have done but do
you think he also takes an account that
his position was bad and think like wow
Yan also had chances or do you sort of
get singly focused on what you missed
and not what your opponent had yeah I
think uh chess players tend to remember
their the points in the game I think we
all know that emotionally if you know
you had a chance to win you don't care
because you you know the the karmic
Justice is irrelevant to you if you had
a chance to win that's what's
emotionally eating at you I think it's
also a timeline thing if you were
winning early on in the game but you
messed it up and then you were like dead
lost yeah before the time control and
then you save it yeah you feel better
you're feeling relief if it's the other
way around even though in both cases you
were winning and losing uh if it's other
way around you feel like
uh oh my God I missed a winning
opportunity you you forget entirely
about what happened earlier on in the
game yeah 100 agreed
uh Contra something on Twitch says if
Carlson does win this match do you think
only having one year between this match
and the next World Championship will
lower his chances of Defending again
first of all it'll be slightly more than
one year knowing what I know about when
the next v-day World Chess Championship
will occur
um it will it will likely not occur in
November of next year we'll just say
that but still interesting question
there will be less time likely I don't
see what it changes yeah okay
um like his opponent has
I guess less time too like
you know he's only going to know his
opponent after the candidates
uh is finished so he's going to have the
same amount of time regardless of when
it happens to the same amount of time he
had with you yeah the gap between the
candidates and the world championship
will be roughly the same yeah
Queen A4 has been played on the board
another question from twitch from a
username I won't read wants to know your
your opinion on magnus's beard Bobby
can we get a close-up on magnus's beard
real quick
oh yeah he's back at the board there it
is I could not even remotely care you
don't even remember
uh do you literally not care I I also
literally don't care
uh
well there you go Fabiano doesn't even
remotely care about Magnus Carlson's
facial hair so we love it Queen A4 Brook
A1 Robert
everything about White's setup suggests
one goal let me let me get rid of a rook
and a bishop let me get rid of a bishop
and a pawn for a rook but but where's
the next
where's the next Firepower coming from
hard to say you would want to get your
knight over to C2 perhaps but even once
you get there there are going to be some
tactics that make it difficult for like
let's just allow those go don't take my
Pawn H5 okay I'm just gonna make a move
sure let's go back and forth a little
bit you want to go to C2 with an item
I'll let you go to D4 so Bishop okay I'm
just gonna let you do it foreign
well I wanted my Bishop to be on B4 when
you do it oh okay sorry I was worried if
I let you take on A3 then I'm in trouble
okay and I was thinking after Knight C2
Bishop C3 yep because if you take on A3
you lose the 9 SC2 and black swing well
so you'd have to move your Rook away
it's maybe but you don't allow Bishop B2
either oh actually maybe you could allow
it yeah because you can SEC it depends
where the Rook goes right but we
it doesn't look like black is any danger
because let's say Bishop B2 here
Rook B2
a b Rook A4
B1 Queen isn't this a worse version or
or will it turn into the same story with
the Knight on D4 and white will try to
to win this slightly better position
yeah that's probably what we'll have the
same one we just had and also in theory
I was going to say okay this isn't as
great
right
this one looks bad okay okay yeah that's
actually really instructive but I don't
white doesn't lose this I think it's
still a draw if you play let's say Rook
C1 here
and Rook C4 I love that take on A3 Rook
C4 this is this is one of those oh my
queen is bouncing around there we go The
Rook goes to four
and over here
um yeah I think this is a draw it's just
a fortress black white can't do anything
but black has no way to make any inroads
because the Rook on F4 can't be attacked
by a pawn it's completely solidified on
F4 if black had an E Pawn yeah it would
be an entirely different story
all right
well we're going to take a very quick
break here as Hindu G1 has played we're
still
awaiting a little bit of
of information on
what either side can do to make progress
so don't go anywhere we still have a lot
ahead chest.com's coverage of the 2021
vide World Chess Championship returns
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER of a game game six in the 2021 video
World Chess Championship continues we're
happy to have you with us take a real
quick moment to remind more than 70 000
of you on Twitch we got 23 000 on
YouTube that the rest days of the world
championship are speed Chess
Championship days uh this is the the
highest stakes in chess and the highest
Stakes for speed chess is going down our
next event on Monday is actually a
double header we have dingley Ren the
number one in China versus levonne
aronian and then right after that we
have Hikaru Nakamura the favorite and
defending Champion against Anish Geary
should be quite should be quite the
match there I think a lot of people are
are looking for a niche to make a move
there
um we we uh expect nothing but exciting
chess just like we've had today guys
regardless of where the result goes we
should remind everybody too that when
the game ends our show is still running
on we will have special guests joining
us at the top of the show so make sure
that you stick around because when the
game ends we still have a lot more to
talk about every single day Robert you
were about to make a comment yeah this
queen E4 move yeah allows white to go
for Rook takes A3 and perhaps Jan has
figured out that this is just a draw
even though it looks a bit
troubling for black because Rook A3
forces Bishop takes A3 well uh there is
a move here I think what he wants is
maybe Queen takes H4 yeah that makes a
lot of sense because with Queen takes H4
the pawn is pinned so he's going he's
trying to solve his problems tactically
yeah so it is it's a very critical
audience what Magnus is calculating now
um
and you see he's really thinking he's
got that he's thinking that look so
let's say root takes a three Queen takes
H4 if King G2 I think Queen goes back to
E4 and black is doing I mean it's just a
draw because
um he's taking the next move and if F3
Queen G6 attacks G3 and he gets the Rook
back next yeah and H4 can now come so
it's not as simple as the H5 phone so so
I think King G1 after Queen H4 is a
critical move oh sorry Rook it takes A3
Queen H4 King G1
and now well the first thought is can
black plays Bishop takes G3 but I don't
think he can because White's King will
just run to his Center take take King F1
there's no perpetual and no way to
attack White's pieces
that means that the queen has to drop
back after King G1
or maybe drop forward with Queen H3 it's
it's hard Queen G4 looks like the most
natural Square
and then try to play H4 but it gets a
bit concrete it's slightly surprising
that eon
is allowing this because
he's giving Magnus some hope maybe not
much hope but some hope
and actually if we go back as well so
not only Rook takes a threes an option
in the start
Knight
B5 can we somehow get away with that I
think Bishop to E5 after Knight E5 is a
fine move
maybe Queen takes H4 is also
actually that looks also pretty good but
but Bishop E5 at the very least black
can play yeah this doesn't look like a
step in the right direction I mean Rook
takes A3 feels like the try at some
point you can of course move your king
so there's no pin on the G3 palm of Rook
A3 these lines we're looking at can be
quite forcing and white can never lose
these positions and I'm just wondering
if this
change a position benefits Magazine's
chances well we analyzed this a whole
bunch so just taking is
really exactly what Magnus wants uh
Bobby and I were breaking down all the
different ways white can make progress
in the same game earlier on the show you
should back up and check it out but
let's just quickly summarize that no
real way to stop the white Rook from
coming to the f-file and when that
happens F2 was guarded the Knight can
maneuver itself either to squares the
target H5 or F6 it seems like White's
winning chances are actually very real
in this end game
um yeah so he must want Queen takes H4
yeah only only idea maybe we should look
uh into the specifics of this after King
to G1
because black has a decision uh where
does the queen go if Queen to G4 I'm
wondering about Rook to A4
and if H4 there's Knight to B5
that's the reason why H4 doesn't work
out so well for black
if Bishop's B4 there's I'm not 100 sure
there's work to be one but black does
collect a bunch of Pawns but oh Bishop
to B4 in that line yeah H4 Knight B5
Bishop B4 Rook B1
hg3 wow Rook a takes B4 I think
well no black should definitely not take
black should play like Queen H3 Force
white to take
and then take and
we end up with a strange endgame if it
was just two Rooks against the queen
without well black wins the E3 Pawn if
black had no F pawns I think white wins
this end game
but with death Pawns
it's hard to say but Yan doesn't want
any part of this if we go back actually
to the start with after you Rook A4 H4
move maybe white can just play Knight C2
instead of Knight to B5 Knight B5 is
like the obvious move going for the
bishop but this just wins the H4 Pawn
directly this is even better that's much
better actually after y wins that H Pawn
I think white is winning yeah slowly
so it's okay for officially prevents H4
we've established that that makes blacks
next move a difficult one
well now that the E3 Pawn isn't
protected now we could consider
taking again
you could yeah
um take white would be obligated to take
King F1
Queen E3
Rook Rook A3 maybe yeah white slowly
coordinates and tries to win Black's
pick box pawns off which he very likely
will do this is a two result game and
it's I don't I don't think it's a small
chance that white might win this one by
the way we have liftoff
Rook takes A3
here we go this is
wow why did yarn allow you that's what
I'm wondering Queen E4
directly threatens H4 when H take on H4
doesn't solve all of Black's problems
it's a really curious moment there by
Yan and you could have made a neutral
move that's what I was thinking Bishop
f8 instead of instead of 24 anything
else holds on to the pawn well here I
I'd actually like to keep the bishop on
E5 right just because uh on D6 just
because I want the option to Bishop no
play like this yeah King yeah G7 G6 one
of those yeah this was the way to just
get a draw does he what is he doing
allowing this I mean only he can lose
this game
it's just a strange choice because it
might have the same evaluation
objectively
but at least I mean Magnus gets an easy
choice to play for it does I don't think
it even has the same evaluation
objectively like
this doesn't look easy shocking
and the fact that Jan is not thinking
after that move
it's not a good sign for him because I
think I just saw a small yeah small
Shake of like uh wait a second
maybe he missed King G1 he was looking
at Queen's four Kingdom or
it's possibly just rushed this this
decision
he played a bit too quickly
and the problem is those positions we
keep talking about with the Knight and
two Rooks against the queen in several
Pawns white is never in any danger of
losing and can play Forever like
um you know bring the Knight close to
the king bring the Rooks closer to the
enemy pawns and
there are very good chances for white to
crash through there because Black's
defensive task is very difficult so it
looks like he just took on H4 King G1
played
this is a scary moment yeah this is this
could we talked about moments earlier
that could have been the world
championship potentially for Magnus when
he was under pressure but that slightly
I I hate to use the word careless but it
feels a little bit careless to
underestimate Rook takes A3 when it's
White's only intention
so
I mean also just from a logical point of
view we Black's Queen will move and
white circle move in the next two moves
that means that we've traded an a pawn
for an H Pawn the a pawn was passed on
A3 defended by a bishop the H1 well it's
a good Pawn
but it's not that good it's not that
good yeah you traded H4 for A3 again the
reason my first instinct was okay there
must be some idea that he calculated
where you get H4 if you could get h4n
that's a different discussion yeah right
but as we're seeing where the queen
moves there's no H4 coming Rook A4
tactically holds everything yeah and for
example let's make Queen to H3 another
move that prepares H4
uh I think that white can even play Rook
to A4 here I was going to say there's
also Knight F3 but okay oh no 93 Bishop
G3 because my idea is after H4 if black
were to do that
then white has to move Knight to a
knight to F3 there's Bishop takes G3 so
maybe that's what I was looking at
earlier maybe this works out for black
wait what's Black's next move here
right like you maybe white has some move
because black Rook to F1
yeah Rook of one wow the point is if the
bishop moves everyone they're they're
they're talking about this H4 I I really
think Rook to F1 is a serious move here
yeah because it also threatens F takes
G3 yeah so if I move the king now F
takes G3 now you take it can get you one
and Knight H2 and you bake it
there's the move Queen D7 and then rip
D4 and then Bishop D6
well it's the only way it's like to
continue the game well and if the Rooks
double again then maybe Queen F like or
queen C C6 I don't know black is or even
trying to hang on with tactics Devin
actually
black is trying to hang in there with
tactics but maybe he manages no but here
even well there are multiple things go
back for a second Rook takes H4 check
King moves Rook takes D6
Queen F3 and Rook F4 like even something
like this will make the light very
different or Knight D4 instead of Rook
D6
you have a move Queen to E4 has been
played
yeah I was thinking here
sorry about that
I was thinking here maybe Knight to E2
wait but you're
The Rook saying oh sorry sorry no it
worked A4 in that case is uh
is ligatory
maybe not obligatory but the most
logical move is root A4
and if H for the Knight moves but black
still has Bishop to E5
doesn't look so easy for white to make
the next move here what what if we start
maybe it doesn't work I was gonna I was
thinking what if we bring our second
Rook to A4 so we like we activate with
like Rook A6 instead of Rook A4 but it
feels a little dicey or that just gave
me an idea maybe Rook to A7
maybe we're back yeah that's better for
sure we're back to the king being an
issue for black
if H4 Rook takes F7 and we might see
some still some sort of attack on the
king king G6 Rook to A7
and I can sacrifice my queen on H7 yeah
maybe it's still a draw that's kind of
key
this still looks like a draw
n gets up
gonna take a confident stroll only 12
minutes remain for Magnus Carlson to
make the next six moves
we are on move 54 remember the next the
next threshold if you will the next uh
Finish Line is move 60.
as that is when more time will yet again
be added onto the clock and increment if
somehow Magnus gets through this next
time scramble that's approaching and he
still has winning chances now the
increment will make a huge difference
yeah the increment helps Magnus and not
yawn yes big time because more time
allows white to find winning chances
whereas black needs to react to What
White's threatening and such a
difference now without the a pawn and H
Pawn yep look at The Rook on A4 active
the Rooks are connected with one another
not just staring into a black pawn but
staring over towards the king side and
if you're not careful that H5 Pawn can
always be targeted the Knight can
reroute to F4 at some point via E2 I
mean that was probably on a suggestion
of course we got the Rook out of the way
first
and The Rook can come to H4 like it
feels like Black's initiative against
White's King
not really amounting to much more than a
bunch of checks that you hope leads to a
draw and white on the other hand is
looking just pile up pressure against
black species this should be five I
think is the only move the more we look
at it yeah and I think white can make a
simple move like
well you have to keep your work on A4
protected so that after H4 your knight
can move
that's actually the difficulty because
if Rook C1 for example H4 comes right
and your knight can no longer move so
white black trades off these pawns which
is really necessary for him and H4 in
the initial position is not a threat
because after Bishop E5 sorry after
Bishop B5 I mean
I don't know how to pass but if I could
just pass and you play H4 then I move my
knight away and take on H4 with check in
some of these positions I mean maybe
white pieces all over the place so it
tactically black and get away with it
but it's not clear to me that H4
actually is available to Black if white
could just pass his turn but I should be
noted likewise that Bishop B5 is not
it's not really a threat because you
intend to take here in fact that would
be the last thing you want to do is
trade the bishop for the Knight and
allow the Rooks to coordinate to pick
off one weak Pawn after another the
bishop on E5 is really just an active
sort of you uh
whatever whatever he's doing here to the
white Camp is is sort of confusing the
situation you can't move the Rook off of
the pin without undefending this rook
and therefore opening up H4
possibilities
you can't move the Knight without the
Rook falling you can't move the Rook off
the second off the last rank without
opening up tactics here well maybe you
can play rookette too because after H4
there's Knight to C2 you don't allow a
check on them Ah that's really key
essential
uh but I can give a check on B1 first
and then play H4 but then maybe you can
just take it maybe you can take it and
put it around three but then there's
Queen G6 and that threats along those
the squares B1 and G6 look like a draw I
don't see black White's King hiding
anywhere
the Perpetual check so maybe after
Bishop to E5 the best move is Knight to
E2
it looks very awkward
but there's one thing that white needs
which is to stop H4 why can try to
slowly uh reorganize the pieces just
don't allow H4 and here like okay let's
say queen C2 is the most natural move
now Rook to A2
check somewhere
King to G2 or or even H2 because
you allow queen of one yeah but then the
Knight can can
actually organize itself in any way once
for example Knight G1 suggests itself
Knight to F3 you know slowly you try it
yeah this isn't
white will not organize quickly Bishop
B5 is on the board
for the record it just goes to your
Point you're making time to time again
Fabi that
the longer this game goes it feels like
the that increases White's winning
chances because if black is going to be
able to just immediately end the game
with some move that's the dream and you
want to play H4 not happening you want
to create some sort of pressure
somewhere not happening because white
can just slow play this Magnus is going
to play your nighty too he knows what's
at stake here he knows it he also knows
that he can't get too low on time
because he will need time to convert
this Advantage but I think he's feel
he's he's seeing he's seeing the road
now and he gets those 15 minutes and
move 60 plus the 30 second increment
which is so huge because without the 30
second increment
Good Luck winning this game yeah it's
Beyond difficult because you don't get
to rebuild your clock but you can
Shuffle when you get the increment for
players or for people watching who are
not used to tournaments you shuffle a
bit you repeat a position twice not
three three times so because that would
end the game in a draw and that way you
just build a minute on your clock here a
minute o'clock there and you have time
to think whereas for yawn he is going to
be defending for the next
50 moves
and one little slip of one reorganizing
of White's night that you probably were
just talking with Knight G1 to F3 that
really could put black in pressure that
you can't get out of Beyond Miss 92 you
can tell from his he probably thought
Bishop B5 white has no way to organize
to stop H4 in the short term
but now he realizes that
even though it looks a bit awkward for
white
uh there's no immediate way to equalize
this
and he's trying to keep playing quickly
but it's not going to be easy to find
moves now yeah this is exactly the type
of I think if you were writing the
script for how Magnus wins games against
yonda palmishi in in these world
championship match games this is the
game and I see Robert nodding and waving
his finger at me in agreement that this
is what was the script it was a game of
dynamic maneuvering and imbalances where
objectively equal but full of
opportunities for both sides to go wrong
and yawn consistently up on the clock
but playing a little too fast in the
critical moments where and that's
exactly where Magnus is going to look to
pounce it's just something's very small
that he underestimates something very
small that he takes for granted and if
we go back to the critical moment that
went with Rook takes E3 on move 53 to me
this is exactly the type of game that
team napomnishi will have nightmares
about because Jan has zero reasons zero
reasons to allow anything to change
about this position
he has no he has nothing he's playing
for here and and it's it's just like I
said I hate to use that word but it's
just it's careless to allow Magnus the
opportunity you did when any other move
that shuffles the game Bobby came back
from the break just so everyone knows we
were about to come back to the break and
Bobby said I think this game is going to
end very quickly to me and Robert and we
said why he said well Magnus played King
H2 and Jan's gonna play this and all
we're going to have is a shuffling sorry
Fabi I'm telling everybody what you said
no it's okay but I was dead I was
totally off on that well you but you
were right in the sense of that's what
should have happened but instead John
played the careless Queen E4 I actually
don't understand they were repeating
moves yeah right it makes no sense what
was Queen E4 I I actually don't get it
they were repeating moves weren't they
yeah
um King H7 had been played so they never
had actually repeated moves I was King
H2 King H7 King H2 well the king H2
doesn't have any sort of obviously yeah
what you were calling was all black has
to do is sit tight and white has nothing
better than to move the I mean find a
better move there are there are none
yeah what does King H2 do it doesn't
threaten anything it doesn't really
prepare anything so
this is this is not what you want to see
here with this with this move Queen E4
that allows exactly what happened in the
game but as I'm about to play it we have
a move in the live game so I'm gonna
jump back to it Queen C2
yeah so now I think I think uh White
should
there's some there's a trap here if Rook
Ford A2 big mistake
Queen to C4 that's a that's a nice
Square maybe not the only square but
you either
uh yeah you but you don't keep your you
have an id4 here
but then then probably like H4 or
something will yeah take Rook a fort
still what it looks like after black
gets H4 it's a draw so okay you don't
play Rook four day two you play Rook one
to A2
that's the correct move
the checks on D1 B1 those aren't so
relevant Magnus has already played your
move so we'll just stay right here
Magnus agrees with you Bobby
oh man this would be torture for any
player
playing this from the black side here
against any other player like we are
going to emphasize it's Magnus Carlson
you don't want this position against him
but this is a nightmare position no
matter if you're playing Magnus or any
other Grandmaster it's going to be
miserable because black has no chance to
win this game and black is going to be
required to kind of Shuffle and hope
that they're shuffling they're
maneuvering will counter whites
maneuvering but white is gonna try to
bring a rook over to H4 at some point
get that Knight on a more active square
and when that happens black has no ideas
there's no plan here for black it's all
your plan is this cross your fingers
hope and wait okay I I just have a crazy
looking move as a suggestion Bishop to
B2
and there is a reason for this move I
promise okay okay because if we give a
check white night white plays King H2
and then Knight to G1 F3 and that Knight
is perfectly placed there with the
visual B2 I'm threatening the Knight so
the Knight has to move
um Rook to B4 there's like Queen to D1
it doesn't look Queen B1 check oh sorry
to be one winning on the spot so that's
bad so the Knight has to move and if it
goes to F4 let's say I play H4
I'm very happy to get that in G takes H4
sacropon Queen to D1
King to H2
Bishop to E5 I'm very happy with this
outcome for black because suddenly the
Knight on F4 is pinned uh White
structure is broken up the king is is
vulnerable to a Perpetual check
so it feels like
here black will hold the draw
what a counter-intuitive move Bishop B2
I mean it makes a lot of sense now that
you've explained it but you're walking
into a pin you bring your Bishop which
looks beautifully placed in E5 to the
side of the board but the more I look at
it the more I think about it I like it
yeah it's I I think Knight F4 is not the
move here
the question is what does white do
instead maybe Knight D4 yeah Knight D4
now maybe we give a check on B1 okay
King G2 and H4
now we have to worry about tactics right
take it
take Queen B1
00 I'm sorry I I meant Queen G6
I don't know why it's a queen thinking
ahead by the way you could actually
maybe almost take here oh yeah this
should be a draw taken Queen E4 because
the Rook is
White's King becomes very open yeah so
just take take and shake and bake all
right that is uh where we find the
beauty and repetition as someone once
said
yeah should we find the beauty and
repetition let's find the beauty of
repetition
there is Beauty and rapidly
um
okay well
Jan is on the clock
after the move Rook one to A2 we are on
the edge of our seat potentially
potentially about to witness the first
decisive game in classical chess of a
World Chess Championship in more than
five years so if you were uh if you're
waiting for that moment you might not
want to go anywhere because today could
be the day of Magnus Carlson finds a way
to grind out this Victory Bishop B2 is
such a phenomenal that's a Fabiano move
I mean giving a check with your queen
and not walking into a pin seems like
the way you'd want to go but as we've
been highlighting for a while now as
white reorganizes the pieces Black's
trouble increases so Bishop B2 that was
such a good life okay
organizes the pieces he made a move but
I actually want to suggest something
kind of crazy after Bishop B2 okay
King to F1 okay Bishop B2 King F1
oh I see you during Queen D1 Queen D12
G2 Queen e two Rook B4
and we get that and then we we have our
winning chance I would have been winning
okay so in the live game he's played
Queen B3
Magnus uh so why not simply King H2 and
then Knight G1
looks like a good plan for white
yeah it's a great plan for white you
can't play H4 because I take a check
yeah he's trying to dominate the Rooks
like a bishop on B2 Queen on B3 he plays
King to G2 by the way makes sense good
enough I think his idea is anyway to go
Knight it's the same idea you're
bringing the Knight around oop Knights
don't move like that Dan
and they don't want to move like that
yeah they don't I learned from Magnus in
the press conference that Knights move
more like an L they move two squares and
over so that was super helpful great
question great question thank you so
much to whoever asked that brilliant
question in game five we know her name
um Queen B7 check is a question here
because
now it you know if you're King H2
then Knight G1 F3 becomes a little
harder to make work because the queen
covers the square
but I think we're happy just to have
Knight G1 so that we can play Rook to H4
and
Black's Queen will have to stay on that
diagonal to stop King G2 Knight F3 so y
will play even Rook H4 and the Knight H3
Knight F4 you might get at that pawn a
different way I think what's once
White's Rooks are free right now they're
a bit
stuck together the queen is holding them
in place because neither of them can
move to the side or lose other Rook once
they get free
we're already talking about white having
serious winning chances
question for you Fabi we see Jan
fiddling with that pawn
do you think that he believes this game
still for sure should be a draw with
proper play I think he thinks that it's
a draw but he's probably getting nervous
because
just because you think a position is a
draw doesn't mean that you know how it's
a draw right and I assume also this
position is a draw
but I don't know exactly how black
should play it
um it feels to me like black
if black sits and waits around
then he might lose which is already a
bad sign
because passive defense is the
you know is sort of the go-to here you
you suspect that black just Waits and
white can make progress
but if you have to start making weird
counter-intuitive moves to hold it all
together
that's a different story that's a much
harder
um
that's a much harder way to defend so
okay I think Magnus will play King H2
it's pretty much an only move at this
point
I mean King G1 is where he came from
king of one allows a
some weird checks and E4
I was wondering about obviously you
don't ever want to play that move until
it's necessary but I think at some point
it might if if you could get your knight
to F5 yeah exactly it doesn't it doesn't
eliminate White's winning chances but it
does cut off The Rook yeah yeah it kind
of cuts off and it allows black to play
H4 at some point there's a funny plan
here if white could somehow coordinate
it I'm looking at the open H file and
we're talking about the H4 Square I wish
any way I could get my Rooks to the H
file I'm probably winning you can't do
it because the bishop hits A1 but I was
imagining some position where the King
was on G1 and the Knight was on D4 and I
played Rook A1 well I think that it
doesn't matter which route you get today
following The Rook on A4 can go directly
to H4 yep not at the moment The Rook on
A2 will be hanging so white will play
King to H2
and I think first you defend F2
so you play Knight to G1
uh then you move one Rook let's say you
move one Rook to E2 one Rook to H4
then you move the other root back you
like you slowly kind of Shuffle around
until you get the setup you want which
is a work on H4 Knight on F4 and
um it's really good to say that because
I think it's instructive the setup you
want is The Rook on H4
the Knight on F4 because the bishop can
never the bishop trading is just a lost
ending two Rooks crush the queen when
you have a structure like this so Rook
on H4 Knight on F4 the other Rook really
just needs to be on any Square that's
tactically safe like frankly as long as
that Rook is not being lost if it's on
E1 even just out of the way the game is
going to be winning for white because I
mean I think that if people are
underestimating the drama of this moment
I I don't know that Jan is as confident
that this should be a draw anymore
because
I'm not that confident male just make it
personal because I don't see how
magnus's plan is stoppable what is Max
thinking about right now because King H2
comes naturally to us here and you know
moving F3 seems to loosen up the pawns
and the squares and so after he's
typically not a move you want to make if
your king is coming under some fire you
don't necessarily want to push the pawn
there
so what something is disturbing Magnus
well it's got to be some sort of nerve
surrounding this H4 idea it doesn't work
as long as the Rook can take with check
but the goal would be to Renegade that
pawn as soon as you can as as John to
kind of create some tactical problems I
mean there's something concretely
disturbing Magnus after King H2 he sees
some specific move which
which is giving him pause
but I I don't see it is there some Merit
to F3 King F2 that way you have
everything protected in the immediate
vicinity over here and then you can
reroute your Rooks I I F3 doesn't feel
like a move you really want to play but
at the same time I don't see how black
immediately takes advantage of it and so
perhaps white then can reorganize in the
way you were saying but it looks very
loose yeah I actually really like it I
mean
I it doesn't there's no obvious problem
with it
I just don't like it I agree no I we
were saying King Chu is so natural why
is Magnus thinking maybe there's some
deep idea
with F3 and then you can
bring the Rooks around but I'll explain
why I don't like it with the variation
let's say black plays Queen to D1 here
and now if King Tab 2 there's Queen H1
or Rook H4
um
yeah we're against four Bishop G3 I
didn't see this in advance but now now
it looks good Queen E1 King actually
Queen H1 is wrong
nice
and if Rook to H4 immediately the land
that I was I was thinking that Rook H4
was ID after Queen to D1 not King to F2
instead of King F2
and then I simply with black want to
play Queen to B1
you can't take that pawn and they've
Rook D2 you just get endlessly harassed
Queen to E1
Queen to be one yeah you can't get off
that second rank anymore because if your
Pawn was on F2 you would happily move
the work to A4 Knight to G1 Knight F3
now you can't do that the entire
Integrity of your king size is
compromise those types of variations
really illustrate the uh the potential
way that black draws it has to be
concrete it has to be based on
something really forcing it's almost all
the time a pawn chain is as strong as
the base Pawn if you have three you
don't have Pawn chains anymore the F2
Pawn protects E3 and G3 black is the one
with pawns that are in trouble because
they're double nice in the file and H5
pawns on a light square and white can
use his forces to team up on it so F3
was a move I never won to play I'm just
curious why Magnus is still thinking
here like what is he thinking about
I don't know but he's ready to make a
move now I mean he's forced to he has
four minutes he only needs to make two
more moves to get to the third time
control but still it's gonna be a long
game he wants to preserve his time so he
sort of obligated
to make a move quickly
I don't see more sensible move than King
H2 and I don't see a problem with King
H2
oh
but he played I was gonna say maybe he's
thinking Arby's
not the time Dan but
I am surprised by that move F3 I know I
was the one who was speculating that he
might be thinking about it but the lines
that Fabiano was just showing very
directly seem to take advantage of this
Pawn push where there are the G3 Pawn is
loose the second rank can be in some
Danger
so Queen D1 was the move that Fabiano
suggested and
I really am wondering how Magnus is
going to maybe Knight F4
okay we'll look at it Queen D1
Knight F4
aha but it's kind of annoying to deal
with that but take on F4 yeah work F4
how are you gonna line up your Rooks
against my pawns because you're the
second rank is open oh that's different
than before like a king G7 for example
yep it seems that you ever bring your
Rook up I check you forever
so you really would love that pawn to go
back to F2 I really don't know I I feel
like this F3 is a shocking move just
unless he was absolutely forced I
yeah it was so we were ill responsible
it wasn't the first king H2 was
maybe there's something after King H2 he
didn't like I don't see it but
um
I don't know but F3 is just so
responsible like
his King will be open for the rest of
the game and the main thing was that his
King was sort of safe it was sheltered
Behind These pawns which can only be
broken up by H4
so uh yeah surprising what if the king
moved yeah I thought that anyway you can
because now now I'm threatening H4
this is probably what he didn't like
because in this position The Rook is
actually double duties
guarding here
and the H Pawn so if you're not taking
with check H4 is an official let's say I
play Rook a to C2
now maybe
maybe Queen to D3 is the problem or I
was looking at both of these
both of these moves perhaps he didn't
see a way to to avoid the queen tickle
just similar to what we're struggling
with with F3 an active accurate and
concrete defense
yeah this is hard because yeah between
D3 for example yeah can't move your Rook
off the second rank because your
Knight's hanging if you bring your other
Rook into the defense even obvious on C4
you're never up to C4 H4 is not stopped
yep
so yeah you have Rook G4 here King f8
and this is why the queen is important
on D3 Rook G4 King f8 Rook C8 King E7
it's not just the Rook that was attacked
it's the queen on D3 like if it was on
B3 why could maybe play Rook H4 on D3 it
attacks tonight directly no so
so yeah maybe this was leading to a draw
and that's why he
played F3 out of um
because he didn't didn't see any sort of
winning chances after King H2 that makes
sense
wow wow wow wow
so now Jan
and queen D1 looks very natural
what other moves even come to mind here
I'm trying to
I think any King who was very natural
King to G7 for example were one move
away from time control again everyone
we're going to stick right here until
that moment is reached so that you don't
miss a moment of our commentary over the
action
but King G7 could have a bit of a flaw
so if you go King G7
what if I go Knight D4
okay we have action Queen to D1 has been
played this is this was your first
movement it feels like the most logical
thing to do I think Young easily
calculates A variation like King F2
Queen H1 Rook H4 Bishop G3 it's pretty
straightforward
um king of two is like the most natural
move so he he could easily
come to this uh variation you know in a
matter of
of seconds
it's a draw on the spot that's a draw on
the spot so King F2 feels like a draw
pretty much instantly
that's why maybe Knight F4 makes sense
but yeah Bishop F4 might just be a draw
yeah the difference now again every
other variation where the bishop trades
for the Knight white was safely playing
for a win but with the King Exposed on
the second rank it's a lot harder to
coordinate your Rooks no matter where
you put it
maybe white should play G4 at some point
what's funny is yeah I was going to say
there has to still be some winning
chances Here For What
it's just a lot harder
I mean if you if you put the Rook even
on a safe square and tried to coordinate
G4 in some weird position like if H4 is
played I I don't know if you have time
for that but you can put your Rook on H4
before playing G4 okay so you can force
The Exchange right so let's just let's
just play that out so something like
this
a little bit of tickle I don't know just
because I'm having fun
right
happened
yeah hg4 Rook G4 let's say King goes to
Center King F5
this is a scary mate
okay even better
okay
um
but actually I'm saying I think it was
just like let's just look at this for a
second after King H7 because I think it
was actually the slow approach which
ends black I think it might be king H3
is that possible Queen H1 oh I don't I
was trying to you know no I think maybe
no it's the Creator got too fancy maybe
what was wrong with oh Queen too maybe
Rook to G3
take your time
no what was the answer keep four maybe
E4 just keep your king Checkmate and
make sure you don't hang up E4 might be
that sir
nope we're struggling here
we're gonna find it
eventually we're all a little tired
where is it
where is the end of the scheme
oh
anybody
okay so the Rook F can go to another
Square
it can although it feels a bit wrong
why is King G3 bad by the way I don't
know
because like Queen G1 Rook G2 Queen E1
King F4
Queen B4 E4 and queen D6 yeah wait so
not that
not there then where can you go Queen E1
it's so frustrating
frustrating fobby
this is surprisingly difficult it feels
like there's just has to be maybe King
to H2
and I worked to G2 I worked to H for
super slow
yeah yeah because you can go Rook G3
like Rook G2 Rook G2 Rook H3 both work
actually that's what I was trying with
Rook G3 but then maybe the queen on E1
stops it yeah
okay so yeah it's here
whoa you see the movie just played
though oh F4 I was wondering about that
because there's no other way to win
based on what we've been seeing
wow that was move 60 by the way Magnus
Carlson has officially reached time
control
which is why
he now has 16 minutes on his clock for
those watching
he was given 15 minutes extra but most
importantly he was given the 30 second
increment so that he will no longer have
the heart racing moments of running out
of time
this this means when you reach room 60
everyone this means that the position on
the board is going to decide the result
in a different way it's not to say the
time pressure won't influence potential
blunders but
increment is is the great equalizer in
terms of the battle between the X's and
O's and the clock because you really can
never lose a position anymore on time in
theory
um so the 30-second increment that both
players now have is absolutely massive
yeah I don't like that The Rook can't
swing over to H4 anymore yeah of course
we're looking at these variations that
seem to you know end the game pretty
quickly with a draw so this keeps the
game alive it keeps chances alive and
white is not in any risk so it does make
perfect sense to go for this
but the question becomes well where are
you going to challenge black from here
on out and wise King is super open now
it's open to checks along the diagonal
checks along the second rank if the Rook
ever moves
um I think black can yeah Bishops
everything about this position was
better when that poem was not F2 that
pawn would love to move back then
we just talked about this the other day
it's it's still not possible I've been
trying for years we haven't fixed that
bug yet
I don't I don't know what white really
tries here it's everything's so loose
now and E3 is also a weakness so it
feels
very difficult to make significant
progress here
well with move 60 in the books we're
going to take a very quick break time
control has been reached the last time
control where there will be time added
back onto the clock so what you see is
what you get now 15 and a half minutes
roughly for Magnus Carlson 24 minutes
for yond to palmishi with a 30 second
increment throughout
how many how much more can Magnus create
here in terms of winning chances all I
know is we're going to be here to the
very end and let's remember that we have
guests joining at the top of the show so
no matter what if the show ends we are
still here so don't go anywhere today
special guests let's bring them up for
everybody we have an interview with
Colin Byrne the artist and Alchemist who
recently created the most valuable chess
set in the world worth more than four
million dollars it was in the studio
earlier it was an amazing thing to
behold we have an interview where we
catch up with him about his lover chess
and the process that went into making
that chess set Vladimir fedosiev the big
fish 1995 battled Magnus Carlson on
chess.com and a funny moment a little
bit ago we're going to talk about that
matches there's also some funny things
that have the chess Community buzzing
and then we're joined by Ludwig I don't
even Ludwig I mean the guy he is uh
maybe uh the most uh interesting person
right now in terms of the streaming
Community please don't inflate his ego
on twitching YouTube I can't anymore
anyway you're trying I'm going to try
and we can't wait to catch up with him
the first live interview he's given
since leaving twitch for YouTube is
happening on this show so you don't want
to miss that stick with us chess.com's
coverage of round six for the feed a
World Chess Championship which is
brought to you by coinbase returns in
just a few
minutes
to all the people who
tell me how you really
come down place your best man put your
things get in the crown keep it locked
here you ain't got no option come on
y'all you know what you're watching we
gonna keep carrying on feed a Chess
Championship or chess.com peace
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score see why moves are played
thanks to the coach's feedback and click
show line to see helpful engine
recommendations play a game start review
and try it today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
I think it plays its own role
uh it's you know it's I mean if I'm
trying to be serious it's hard to
evaluate because
um I think in modern shares you got to
be
very Universal player if you want to be
successful and so you can't rely on the
information alone
so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example a player a royal Chamberlain
would be the best intuition ever is
Mikhail child but
I guess he also had
to he had to calculate a lot here and
for example today if you if you try to
to stick to his playing his childhood
sometimes it will be very costly to to
your performance I think yeah the
intuition is always good but
I mean sometimes you basically can't
choose the move
because of your calculation or
evaluation and you need to for example
sometimes you are giving like two
similar opportunities you you you you
get to pick one and okay probably hear
the intuition comes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sleeping mood or something and then I'm
listening to some you know some hard
rock music or something so to to feel
the energy and feel the power but I mean
in general it's
I mean it really depends on the mood and
the mood can be different from from one
day to another
it's not some kind of a ritual line
trained
[Music]
welcome back everyone chess.com's
coverage of the feed a World Chess
Championship continues and your
opportunity to be a part of a private
group lesson with Fabiano caruana as we
debut our new feature classroom has been
running throughout the entire event
here's how it works all you have to do
is take one video Lesson on chess.com
from Fabiano's new video series which
you should be taking anyway because it's
amazing talks about his journey to his
battle versus Magnus Carlson goes over
the critical games versus Magnus Carlson
from the 2018 World Chess Championship
some of the finest content we've ever
had on chess.com if I don't say so
myself Fabiano and all you have to do is
take one of those video lessons take a
screenshot use the hashtag learn with
Bobby and you are automatically
registered to win 10 of you will be a
part of debuting our new feature
classroom a tool that brings coaches and
students together in real time with
awesome robust tools and Fabiano is
going to be displaying it with 10 of you
everybody will get at least one question
answered by Fabi in that in that lesson
if not more and it's going to be epic on
December 13th gives you it gives you
more content to look forward to so if
you're not doing it right now quickly
solve one lesson on chess.com take a
screenshot of it share it for us on
Instagram or Twitter and get registered
to win guys I know you're you're
registered for for an eight-hour game
today did you know you signed up for
that yeah I did okay the rest day
yesterday we thought that it would be a
battle and it remains so because the
position that we currently have is one
where white has been pressing for the
last what has been 30 moves or so maybe
maybe less than that maybe 20 but now
that we're here white is creating
problems for himself as well this isn't
just a one-sided fare anymore if white
tries too hard to win it can backfire
and then black can have some chances
take me through some of those problems
that he created for himself Bobby yeah I
actually like when Magnus has done
because although I think that the
valuation is basically equal and if
black plays correctly it's a draw he is
creating stuff which looks scary and
that's that's already a big thing when
you're when your opponent is in time
trouble
moves that look scary are are pretty
dangerous he wants to play rookies Rook
A8 and starting to tackle box King while
defending the E3 Pawn I don't think that
attack can really go through because
Black's King can escape via F5
but white is only one with chances to
win this
okay then I don't need two covers all
checks the E3 Pawn is for the moment
safely defended
I think black uh basically draws with
many moves because white doesn't have
many ideas here his pieces are in some
ways tied down in the night is a
defensive piece that we're hunting for
is defending the E3 pawn and it'll be
difficult for white to actually get
active and create threats that being
said when you have a safe Advantage
which you can press for a win that's
already a practical chance and Jan looks
a little bit uncomfortable he's
concentrated
um I think the reason he's uncomfortable
because he doesn't have like a very
concrete way of solving his problems
it's basically just as many moves which
roughly remain equal because white can't
do anything
um so significant
but it's difficult to make a move
without a concrete idea let's say to
play King G6 or queen D5
they're fine moves but they don't do
anything right they don't actually like
change the position anyway
Robert your thoughts yeah no of course
white is the one that continues to press
on and try to get a win here but because
this Pawn's an F4 and on F2 if white
goes all in there could be some problems
for the white king and the move King G7
played just to get closer to those F
pawns make sure that the white can't
suddenly attack them and Fabiano's point
of Rook E8 Rook A8 that can be an idea
that black needs to really look out for
because if you push that pawn from F6 to
F5 now you're putting Upon A light
Square because the bishop can never
defend it and perhaps white can team up
on that pawn and black does not want to
drop that one that said because E3 is
loose it's very difficult for white to
actually get that pawn on if it goes to
F5 because your Rook needs to stay on
the e-file well let's say a concrete
problem with F5 because F5 is an
important move in it's it's probably not
bad for black and it may happen at some
point so we should consider it let's say
immediately after rookie eight if black
were to play F5 I actually think this is
a bad moment because I can play Rook to
H1
and that H5 Pawn is actually a Target
the queen can no longer get it get there
to defend the pawn
and the King can't really go up because
of King G6 there's well maybe you can
play King G6 because again we're The
Rook on E8 is tied to E3 if Rook G8 King
F6 so maybe black still holds it like
this but it's it's a bit tenuous
we see Magnus has played your suggested
Rook to E8 which means Jan is on the
clock and for the first time in the
entire game
we may be in a position where John is
about to be down on the clock versus
Magnus they do have increment so of
course we're no longer fearing for our
life when we're under a couple minutes
but
but time pressure will have an influence
on this game Mark Mark our words Rook H1
now trying to go after that pawn there
could be some Queen D5 stuff happening
you don't want to put your Rooks in a
line like that as Queen D5 it does look
very scary and I guess white is able to
save the material but that's too close
for comfort
yeah you don't want to allow things like
that that's when you start to get in
trouble
the thing is yeah go ahead the good
thing for white is that even if white
were to like trade the A1 work for the B
B6 Bishop
um it's a draw okay he plays that five
he's he must be whether he's right or
wrong he must have visualized something
that he feels is a fortress something
that he can hold the blockade based on
the balance of a combination of pressure
on E3 and the inability for white to
pick up these pawns without without
basically releasing defense of said epon
this must be what he's going for see the
hesitation though he went to grab the
half Pawn to go F5 and he paused pause
stop and then made the move so I mean
it's a supercommittal move I'd be
nervous AF yeah it's Bobby Bobby
it's a very nerve-wracking moment
because he's trying and hasn't tried to
survive for a long while now and if
white can fully coordinate those Rooks
yeah that's when danger can happen but
because E3 that's really the key here is
that if the knight ever moves away from
E2 there's checks in the second rank if
the Knight doesn't move then the bishop
and queens are aiming at the E3 Pawn you
can't get both your Rooks into the
action in a way that allows white to
kind of try to get a win here I think
what we might see is Rook to H1 King to
G6 to defend that pawn and then Rook to
C1 you lured the king forward a bit and
then maybe Rook C6 becomes an idea this
is sort of a position of like let's say
we see Rook to eight which also makes
sense
it doesn't have a very obvious threat
but maybe he's hoping that Rook to G8
can F6 Rook to E8 sort of
traps that King on F6 is he switching
which Rook is defending
yeah and and just imagine that white has
another move here let's say black plays
uh Bishop C5 yeah Rook to G8 King F6
Rook to E8
and if white were to were able to play
Rook to E5
right now then black would suddenly be
in danger yeah because of Rook to G5 and
also because of tactics like Bishop D6
Rook takes up five things like that with
an id4 oh wow um Fork I'm gonna show
that just for the just for the Thrills I
don't actually know how to I think it's
difficult to make it to make it happen
yeah my Bishop B6 okay rookie five and
then Bishop C7 okay there we go and the
whole point is we have Rook takes F5
yeah with a fork Town Big Town the thing
is that even if White
it starts to get dangerous like this is
not a winning position but you start
with a small idea your opponent gets a
bit nervous that's that's the way you
win these positions it's just like it
starts to get a a bit of pressure a bit
lower on time for your opponent and then
eventually he makes a serious mistake
all these things start with a small idea
probably all Journeys start with a
single step
oh
um
Rook endings are drawn maybe not this
one
this is absolutely you out uh played me
on unnecessary
out of place pop culture references yeah
Robert I was gladly sitting inside I
thought it was better to ignore than
participate but yeah it's actually
beginning getting very tricky here for
black because these Rook G8 rookie ideas
when you say your King has no moves for
black you may see ghosts but there also
could be mating Nets and ideas that are
hard to meet so even coming up with the
move at this point for black isn't that
straightforward uh Queen D5 does come to
mind is one option trying to reroute the
queen over to H1 but that doesn't really
threaten the much the king can
eventually Escape anyway so yeah this is
a big moment for young has to be a
concrete defense something something
accurately calculated because as you
both have been pointing out just there
are different types of draws right and
sometimes there's the type of position
where you have to try not to change
anything just say pass right don't let
your opponent trick you into doing
something or changing something
this is the opposite black has to find
something concrete and and bring
pressure against the white king before
the Rooks coordinate and finally start
taking advantage of these weaknesses
yeah I think that black has a number of
deals that look there no it's just it's
a bit concerning but if I'm gonna I
think he's gonna say that buck has
options though right black has options I
don't think black is in any way forced
okay I don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing because sometimes a lot
of moves look the same but one of them
isn't and you end up making that move on
the other hand it should be a good thing
for your defense because you're never in
that situation where you have to find
that one uh path to to equality I like
to move Queen D5 that was suggested
um
it kind of eyes are organized the only
downside is it doesn't ie3 but Queen H1
does seem like an annoying idea maybe it
doesn't have an immediate threat but if
that Rook on A8 moves Queen to H1
followed by Queen to H2 Bishop to A5
check if white skin goes to E1 that King
could get flushed out what's still in
there again yeah I'm not sure but let's
just say y continues with idea Rook G8
King F6 Rook a to E8
King F6
work 88 and if Queen H1
then I think black has a threat of Queen
to H2 King U1 Bishop A5
um and this might just lead to a draw by
Perpetual yeah in rookie five now there
is Bishop C7 possible because there are
no Forks against this queen right the
queen on B3 uh Rudolph takes out five
with the fork on D4 which is what we
were talking about earlier but now the
Rook is forced to move and
yeah this should be a draw and also I
think that there's no Rook C6 so at
pretty much any moment black can start
giving that Queen H2 Queen H1 check as
well
so so Queen D5 is a nice looking move to
me
but not the only move
I think Jan should be moving quickly now
I understand it's nerve-wracking uh it's
been a very long intense game and
they're probably both exhausted by this
point
but you don't want to get super low on
time that's when serious mistakes start
to happen
only
nine plus minutes they do get the 30
second increment so you can build up
time but what you were saying has some
serious Merit here that black has a
bunch of different moves that all look
acceptable they look pretty good but
then you make a careless move at some
point because four moves look the same
and you make the inaccurate one and then
King gets in trouble your pawns may
start falling off maybe you walk into a
pin at some point that can be a trouble
so for example I'm trying to think how
to make this world let's say you go King
G6
just and go Rook a to B8
and you go Bishop takes E3 check
thinking okay your Rook is hanging there
right here King F3 almost works for
white but there's Bishop B6 checked back
right in order to save the bishop and
Save the Queen at the same time but
these are moments that it's easy to
overlook to move like Bishop back to B6
of course the players of this caliber
will find that but these sort of ideas
you just have limited time on the clock
and you don't see that possibility
that's when things can get out of hand
yeah Jan is is taking quite a while so
now it's clear that he even though the
position is objectively equal he's the
one under pressure
this is shown in the clock he was up on
time the entire game up until this
moment this is pretty much the first
time that Magnus is only slightly but it
is something slightly ahead on the clock
and
that eight minutes that yawn has he's
probably not going to be getting
getting much more time than that you
know he's he's now living pretty much
off the increment
um
and he might at some point make make
some quick moves and and Garner a bit of
time
Queen to B4 is
an unusual move but I don't think it
really
changes anything but it's a bit weird
looking anyway
Rook to G8 King to F6
so what's the idea if Rook 88 or is it
just his ideas you can't really improve
after that
I have
I'm trying to make even sometimes a rook
takes B6 like
A6 or something I'm just trying to
figure out a way if I can get in time
and it doesn't work here
but what I want to do is get my Rook to
G5 and if I have to take on B6 to put my
knight on D4 there are moments where
that can get kind of scary for yeah you
can start to pick up to the H5 and F5
partners and then Rook at night and two
pawns against the queen
is is a very scary end game in this case
it would be three pawns against one Pawn
but in any case it would be scary right
and we're asking for a lot but those are
the things that are sort of turning in
the back of my mind here like trying to
figure out is there a moment where I can
sacrifice my work that was one of the
initial plans A3 so just because he
wasn't captured once doesn't mean that
you can't go for the second time with
those pawns stuck where they are white
can team up on them
so I wonder if let's go back to the
current position and think about what
magnus's options are
uh there is also the move Rook to E5
it doesn't really threaten the pun
or maybe it does but in any case I put
some pressure on that problem
of course black can still you know play
Queen B3 Shuffle around
there's there's so many options and they
all look they all look the same
that's scary territory to be in
but maybe they all are the same and then
that's not so scary that's true but at
some point one of those moves is not
going to be the same
so now Magnus is thinking as well
they're both going to get low on time
that's I think a certainty at this point
Rook G8 feels right doesn't it give me
that check the king going to F6 it just
it's a vulnerable King Maybe not
immediately but
I'm wondering if you can play like Rook
a to C8 I want to really flush that King
out
I also have a it doesn't work but there
are some trip look at the tricks here if
we just go back A Moment Like instead of
Rook C8 if I go Rook G8 to B8 you need
to B8 I thought you said what and block
is I'm gonna go attack your E3 Pawn with
Queen B3
and I go Rook A6 you go Queen takes E3 I
go King E1 and the Knight is such a
wonderful Defender you only have one
check available to your queen and that's
the F2 square and then I'm gonna try to
run away with my king here
um maybe King D1 first yeah can you do
one first induce induce Queen F1 and
then King D2 no more checks I get your
Bishop so these are the kind of things
you can stumble into thinking the E3
Pawn is vulnerable right it is but if
your pin in all directions you may drop
a bishop for that pawn so you want your
move Rook a to C8 yeah actually it's
interesting so Robert and I had uh the
same coach when we were uh up and coming
players and I remember Miron Sharon I
remember one of the things that he told
me was the best defender around the king
is a knight right and what the line that
Robert just showed uh demonstrates that
perfectly the Knight even though it's a
far weaker piece on the queen
completely covered all the checks that
the queen had it defended the king
perfectly and allowed white to win that
Bishop this Rook here is also really
tricky because now you're you're trying
to create a
sort of a net here for the King by by
giving check now when the king comes up
I'm not saying that Rook C6 is
concretely winning in any way in fact I
don't think it is but it is that much
trickier for black to solve and this is
the thing that makes me super nervous if
I'm a yonda palm Mission fan here is
that if Magnus keeps this same scenario
then we just take let's say five minutes
off the clock for each player
and nothing has changed
who are you taking in that scenario a
drawer or a white wind yeah
I still you see what I'm saying I still
think we have to lean towards a draw
I don't know I mean to me but you guys
have made the point the longer this game
goes and the lower the clock gets the
harder this is to hold
I do really like Rook 88 before throwing
the check on G8 because you just ask
young more questions that's what I'm
saying no that's exactly why I went down
that thought process when it was played
is it's a non-forcing move it's the kind
of move that gives your opponent a lot
to think about you just want to create
opportunities for your opponent to go
wrong when they're under time pressure
and Magnus Carlson frankly has done that
better than than any of his peers for
the last decade plus and winning these
types of games is what he does
yeah I think that there there is
some chance that white wins this
due to the time situation and because
it's not easy for black to
to make decisions here yeah on the other
hand all the movies we've looked at and
we haven't been calculating very
you know we haven't been calculating to
the degree that the players are at the
border calculating obviously for
yourself but
we haven't made a move for black yet
that has changed the evaluation to White
having a winning position okay so it
feels like black has a lot of freedom
like unless unless it's a crude blunder
it doesn't feel like black is losing
this position that being said once in a
long time blunders do come into the
picture
yeah
Bishop A5 which is threatening oh that's
a funny move threatening checkmate
Queen E1 king of three Queen F1 is made
apparently Magnus was ready for that
quickly brings The Rook back to the
first rank says he could have brought
the king to the center Rook G8 king of
six Rook C6 King E7 and then gone back
to C1
but he decided not to do that I wonder
maybe black can even play King H7
white stress all the way over there
because Queenie wants it to strong yeah
you would be forcing to draw
will not so clearly Rook hate King
G7 Rook cg8 King F6
let me this is this is scary Tim this is
gets scary for white too yeah I would
actually like let's just say some rapid
fire so let's let's follow the live game
here rookie one Bishop B6 again and
after rookie five Carlson is I mean
optically he's improved his chances
you know what could be
something that blocking to be very
careful I was like Rook D1 Knight D4 at
some point because Rook D1 also tries to
get the Rook to D5 and it depends where
the black king is as well because if the
king ever goes to F6 then once the Rook
gets to D5 or three take on F5 with
check yep so there are some serious
concern about that and if I can play
Rook d194 I'm not even saying that's
necessarily winning but that gets very
scary if you have to take that Knight on
D4 well I can take with the pawn on
right and now you have a pass Pawn
you're Rook from E5 can come back to E2
to Shield your king and then you're just
gonna push that pawn on the board and
that actually might be losing for black
we'll show some line like this just so
it's clear what the guys are talking
about here if if something like this
occurs and obviously not ideal but oh
sorry The Rook on D1 so it's my Bishop
A7 instead of uh Queen B3 yep
this just shows that black can't just
sit tight yeah here white has also Rook
D5 stuff so black has to be extra
careful yeah yeah 94 like I think if
black takes medially then ed4 black is
in trouble
yep most likely but there's the
immediate Queen B2
and then if King to F3 now I can take on
D4 and ed4 there's Queen B3 so things
like that might come into the picture
it's a good call
yeah okay we have a move now Queen to B3
from yawn looks very sensible defending
the F5 Pawn
it feels like we've seen a position
pretty much like this at some point what
it feels like we've seen a position
pretty much like this at some point
Magnus with nine minutes young with five
and a half so two different options I'm
seeing here one is to go Rook H1
to just try to go after the H5 Pawn but
after King G6 I think it's a dead end
yeah you're not getting anywhere and the
other is to start with like Rook C3 and
try to get your Rook to the fifth rank
because you're protecting E3 which means
that the Rook on E5 can take F5 next if
you leave it hanging so Queen B1 though
that defends at five Bishop A5 later if
that Rook you know goes back to E8
things like that it feels like black is
hanging on by just sort of circling the
position certainly the white king in
particular yeah black black is still
hanging in there barely
yeah it's it's difficult to know what to
suggest for what I would think
you might want to play Rook C8 again but
then we've kind of seen that same idea
from Magnus he already tried to put his
Rooks on the eighth rank to try to maybe
create some checks against Black's King
and that didn't seem to lead anywhere
but again if you just play tickle long
enough we'll be under time pressure
before you know it boys and girls don't
go anywhere
a decisive result for the first time in
five years as it comes to classical
chess and the world championship could
be in store here today this has been a
fascinating game regardless of the
result and you can tell by the way Jan
is staring at this board he is putting
every last bit of energy that he has and
he must be exhausted they've been
playing at this point for over six hours
or about six hours that is
so tiring because he's been considering
all these options he had five seconds
left when he made his 40th move right so
he barely got to the time control and
when you have those kind of nerves that
stress that compounds and now he's in a
moment where he probably knows he's
holding he probably feels pretty
definitive about it but you can never
not for a single moment let go you just
have to keep paying attention keep being
sharp keep being skeptical of your ideas
to make sure that you are accurately
calculating and it does seem like he has
things under control right now
never let go young never let go
actually if we go back he made that Rook
C1 move
but we were discussing this variation
before Rook C1 if he gave Rook G8 check
King H7 Rook h8 King G7 Rook G8 King F6
Rook oh sorry this game was played
we'll go back to that one because it was
it was interesting instead of Rook C1
yeah uh yeah here move 67 instead of
Rook C1 yep
black doesn't have to play King H7 but
let's say he does
Rook G8 King F6 Rook H6 King he said it
looks like white hit a brick road but
here Knight to D4
and if Queen to E1 King to G2 the king
actually hides look at all those forks
for a second
the king hides here and queen D2 King H3
it's probably still a draw
I mean not here anymore but uh you know
there's some risk for black because the
king is weirdly enough even though it's
being checked seems to escape
what in the world would be the move here
if not Chuck this is like exactly the
type of blind Magnus should have gone
for because tell me a human move here
maybe I don't know what the computer
says maybe King to D7 is holding on King
to D7 that is just you know what
no it doesn't it doesn't hold up I don't
know what it is this is just this is not
a holdable position by any human
standard this is a lost position for
black it looks really bad yeah you just
made Titanic references You're darn
right I was because I'll never let go
Jack
it's it's tough here it's that that line
could be a line that Magnus pursues
because he could probably rearrange his
Rooks back to the eighth Rank and
I guess the queen come into H1 if you go
for it right now things have changed a
bit
I think the more you maneuver although
it
it helps get your opponent lower on time
it also helps him understand which
defenses yeah that's true that's a
really good really good point actually
Beyond is playing more confident and
looking more confident now he probably
probably realizes that the queen on D5
can jump into H1 and and restricts
White's Rook activity so if it goes to
C8 Queen H1 happens
we love those
this could just be what Magnus wants
maybe is Queen H1 to play Rook G8 and if
King F6 Rook C1 back hold on let me yeah
I was thinking about that where the
queen gets to H1 and it looks Queen H1
Rook GA check yeah King F6 and then Rook
C1 because the queen looks threatening
on H2 but once you bring the king up to
Africa if you make this check you might
regret it yeah because Rook C6 check
will threaten to win a piece and that
Queen is stuck over there but here after
Queen to E4 I was gonna say or queen D5
like yeah maybe Queen D5 no Queen D5
should be fine but I thought Queen E4 is
more forcing it forces Rook to C3 and
then you can go back I feel like that
that confident glance we saw yawn shoot
across the board to Magnus right
but we see is there Knight G1 here
Queen H2 King F1
and I don't know if it leads anywhere
but you can't take G3 because of rook
ghx and at least I'm asking you some
questions of what next I might have
Knight F3 no it's it's an idea it's kind
of funny looking
but it's an idea of lines with H4 now
and check GA King F6 check C6 King E7
you win the bishop HD3 what's going on
there I have no idea like it's just like
I think the problem might be that it
allows H4 what are you taking it even
GTX okay yeah simple stuff
and actually no oh the my line doesn't
work but I think black can play for
example Queen to B2
uh pretty safely
just go back
but white can play around like this
white can play 92 or night uh I don't
know if Knight F3 leaves a king too open
but Knight E2 leads to a position
well it actually leads to repetition
Queen B1 king of two queen is one
and so on a knight did you want find the
beauty yep
maybe that's his idea although it's a
funny
it's a bit awkward to put your knight on
G1 on your key on F1 it's funny this is
now the one under under five minutes the
one under time pressure
I'm trying every last attempt Knight G1
is just
prove your draw it looks easily provable
as we're discussing with the queen just
going back over Queen's two check we
back to B2 but one question what about
Rook to E5 here
okay
um so if Queen H2 maybe I'll put like
King in the center King one Queen H1
King D2 and queen B1 that doesn't look
very promising it looks like the king is
going
to a bad place they were to the bad
place to the sunken Place turns out the
good place is the bad place oh sorry
twist ending spoiler hey you know what
Ted Danson you are a legend what I said
dance would be so disappointing you Ted
Danson
loves Jess by the way true shout out to
Ted if you're watching this show
all right so yeah
we see the queen just maneuvering around
Rook to B1 is interesting asking a
question of where to put that Bishop if
Bishop C5 maybe Rook E5 is maybe it's
not a big deal but it's a bit awkward
looking
and if Bishop to A7 then you might get
hit with some seventh rank attack seven
yep yeah the ambitious five rookie Vibe
yeah
of course the bishop where it doesn't
want to be on a square like this so that
you can gain a Tempo and maybe this is
okay Queen to D3
did we actually gain anything well this
if Rook C5 Knight D4 it's not here but
at some point you know you can consider
going for this and it's clear that black
should have a bunch of checks and be
able to survive isn't that clear
well Queen to B2
King's F3 Queen to B7
I feel like we're we're in the territory
of a draw here right but the thing is
you lose sight of that idea at some
point Yeah by surprise I'm with you I'm
liking it I'm loving it you want some
more of it I want some more of it
that's what I want
so what is Jan going to do here this is
not the easiest choice but I guess the
bishop is going to end up on C5
you can drop your queen back to just
defend the bishop but that seems
because if Queen C6 maybe there's like
rookie five or B5 coming
yeah Queen C6 rookie five
I don't know how bad it is because black
like F5 is a bit difficult to take
without hey getting hit with Queen E4
also detectives on E3 rear their ugly
head as soon as you for sure take the
Rook off the e-file well you still have
to make a move there which is not the
easiest thing right don't tell me what I
have to do
all right fine Queen C6 rookie five
because my next one was B1 to B5 most
likely yeah that's that's uh
I mean I and I can't go here anymore
here Rook C1 wins you all right we have
a bishop A7 so this is what we
anticipated now Rook E7 Bishop C5 Rook
E5 it actually didn't do anything
apparently we learned well you can also
I wonder if you can start with rookie
five
because after Queen D3 there could be
like Rook B7
yeah this this is about us about a
squares squares you're in trouble you
have Queen A3 but that's uh
a bit suspicious looking
yeah this doesn't look great even if
it's somehow okay it's not really
reflected yeah King I don't know a7's
also hanging yeah Bishop C5 Rook F7
I'ma not be happy not happy Bob looks
like you're surviving
so maybe yeah maybe rookie five
immediately look at that there's also
rookie five Queen D7
25 Queens but then I go Rook to B5
probably
yeah wait one what do you if Queen D3
would be 77
this one actually looks very different I
think we're about to see rookie five on
the board oh rookie seven okay uh rookie
five felt like a better chance
but maybe it's
so we just looked at this with Bishop C5
Rook E5 to follow with Tempe
the queen takes the which Square I mean
the main one we looked at was D3 taking
advantage of the fact that you can't
play Rook B5 the the bishop cuts off
communication this is sort of but you
can play Rook B7 here
but then I was I thought it should be
six it might be Rook D7 you have to be
like super careful about these weird
pins and yeah this is this is suddenly
getting sharp and not easy for black
anymore
especially with under four minutes yep
but he should play Bishop C5 right what
other moves I mean there's nothing else
but then Rook to e B7 yeah B7 and take
F7 okay
touche and
yeah he plays Bishop C5 we should
consider the the possibility of let's
say queen A2 Rook B7 Bishop C5 broke up
seven and a trade on F7
because that's not an immediately
obvious end game
it seems like white should be winning
though we'll come back to that magnus's
all White's pawns are on dark squares on
the other hand white can I mean black
spawns are super weak as well F5 let's
say a knight on D4 attacks F5 that could
become relevant at some point
Carlson looks poised to score his first
win in classical chess since 2016.
of the World Chess Championship
wow so
rookie five feels sort of mandatory at
this point is there another move that
well any if Rook C7 you get hit with
Bishop E3
and uh
I think you need to take the
the fat head out in case that happens
here he goes rookie five of course yeah
here he goes
and I'm wondering if what Magnus was
doing right there is trying to think of
his follow-up because when you're in
time trouble I think a very
good thing to do often yeah have your
moves in pairs so that way you keep your
opponent on the clock because Black's
decisions are much more difficult here
than whites yep
so Rook B7 how are we meeting Rook B7
you can't see Fabiano Bishop Bishop D6
is the most
um obvious move but then Rook D7 right
Queen A3 loses to Rook takes up five
what okay I have an idea Rook B7
what's your next move if I oh wait if I
move off you have Knight D4
uh the king escapes I think maybe Knight
D4 is a movie Up
Queen D2 King F3 Queen D1 King G2 the
Knight on G4 covers E2 that's important
that's why the king could escape to H3
Queen D2 King here maybe it's still the
king is a bit too abandoned so that even
if you win at five you still get into
Perpetual check but I think in a
player's head you see this in your head
you're visualizing like I might just
lose this and a few moves is black it's
scary you could get mated yeah but wait
let's see if white has something better
after Rook B7 Bishop A3
because
um white also has like Rook d a five I
just want to get to the seventh rank
somehow is there problem with B5 and
just going after the F5 Pawn because you
can't attack E3 anymore no I don't think
there's a b to B5 and then a lawnmower
across the fifth rank
again we have to consider King G6
but there I I'm thinking that looks
pretty bad yeah
those are those kind of six seven dollar
blunders right you know can happen
usually not over the board but as a
player is calculating they think they
have some resource they get to the
position and they're like oh
that's no good
so wait John's
what's going on in the game right here
he's thinking
after Queen D3 yeah almost almost under
two minutes now
is Carlson yeah it's it's a time that he
needs to
it's a critical moment it's
understandable he's thinking here yep
but he doesn't want to get down to
seconds for the rest of the game
he does get that increment right both
players 30 second increments so every
move they make you see what time they
have left as it was made again 30
seconds added to their clock that's
extremely important at this stage of the
game both players likely exhausted mag
is looking for a chance here a chance
there Yan trying to keep Magnus at Bay
but I think this move rooked to B7 it
just puts that onus on yon here and we
keep talking about various moves they're
really not easy to play because you
might think F5 is falling you have to
calculate what Fabiano keeps talking
about if we get the two Rooks uh for the
queen of the pawn white will be able to
pawn and end game good chances to win
maybe not winning but that's not really
an ideal scenario for Jana Paul machine
I don't see better moves than Rook wait
there's Rook to H1
wait that actually wins the H1 Bishop D6
oh yeah we Rook away
Rook Rook H1 Bishop D6 Rook to EA it's
H5 and the point is that the C5 Bishop
is still under attack Magnus is under a
minute so wait if Rook H1 Bishop D6
hitting the Rook where do you go if Rook
C8 there's Queen to B5 maybe yeah so I
think I think Rook B7 is the idea the
original idea but the Rook H1 is super
critical I think this is one of the
lines on magnuses and he goes rupee
seven it looks like it looks like it
there it is seven is on the board and he
has roughly a minute on the clock now
after the 30 seconds added back
but even though Magnus is the one
dipping below a minute the position some
of course much more difficult to play
for young don't be surprised if yon
spends several minutes here trying to
figure out can I play Bishop A3 which
looks like such a ridiculous move in a
sense do I play Bishop f8 to be closer
to my king but just because you're
closer King doesn't mean that's a good
thing and Knight D4 is still on the
table there as you mentioned but these
the point is that there are several
options there for white to try to take
advantage of the position and Bishop D6
Rook D7 I'm struggling to see a move in
response to that but maybe
white can't really make progress there
either well I was thinking about Bishop
D6 Rook D7 King F6 but there's e to E7
yeah that is super nasty C2 oh my
goodness that not a move that we saw
coming now Rook C7 doesn't work because
of Bishop what about Rook to B5 Rook to
B5 Rook to B5
is looks like that might even be on the
board
oh my gosh Rook to E5 it does win that
F5
it's Rook to B5 where does the bishop go
without losing the F5 Pawn all right
well anywhere goes you're losing that
pawn the question is do you have some
tricks after that Bishop to A7 Rook F5
Queen E4 that's the only thing I can
think of Bishop Bishop to A7 Rook to F5
Queen to E4 hits the E3 Pawn that's
actually that's really key I don't know
because he finds it Bishop A7 Jan is
defending this position but there's Rook
G5 checking Rook B3 at the very least
that holds everything together yeah okay
Rook A5 played with the tempo I like
that Against Time repeating we talked
about this right yep you see the beauty
and repetition but his clock the beauty
and gaining time on the clock exactly
his clock gains time and he can just go
back there's nothing that Jan can do
here this is a really smart decision by
Magnus Carlson and there was that one
line I think if we can quickly show it
the five minute we're discussing in our
heads if the bishop had gone to D6 uh
when The Rook went to B7 just right here
Bishop D6 we're saying Rook D7 and if
King F6 there's Rook e to E7 which is a
really nasty looking move because it
pins everywhere so I mean there's a lot
to figure out but we can just go back to
the game yeah I I'm wondering so Rook
takes F5 Queen to E4 Rook to G5 what
does black do we're about to find out
Queen E4 location F5 Queen to E4
so Rook to G5 can't go anywhere
oh because King F6 is Rook F5 I think F6
Rook F5 trades Rook F5 and you and you
have to take everything because if you
move to the e-file rookie five wins but
I probably unless I'm 100 sure that's a
win which I'm not I would play have a
king of six or B5 to B3 I can play this
game forever and we talked about how the
more time the players have that's
actually a really good the better it
will be for Magnus he is now I mean he's
in the driver's side either way he's
winning in that line Giannis played
Queen to D3 rather than Queen E4 this is
super revealing that Jan knows this is
this is magnus's game to win and break
the five-year classical non-decisive
game streak he has to give a check now
because if Rook F to E5 as Bishop takes
E3 overloading that Rook no matter which
Rook goes which well if we're
E7 the result other Rook to E5 there was
also F6 potentially but showing the idea
for everyone
the E3 plus so he's gonna give a check
he has to on G5 yeah it's the only move
earlier oh my gosh we lost sight of it
but that was an idea we talked about
earlier when now all of a sudden white
gets a rook a knight and two pawns the
white king is very safe and maybe this
is not winning but Magnus clearly has
zero risk and he can try to play this
forever but also what was wrong with
Rook to G5 because I understand this is
this is probably a very interesting way
to play but
what did what did John want after Rook
G5
it's a great question
f8 I think oh sorry you have king of
Fate oh yeah yeah yes and then if rookie
father's F6 okay yeah that makes perfect
sense okay no this is
this is the only way for white to keep
the winning chances alive it seems and I
think he'll have plenty of them no
matter where the King goes you win the
bishop
and the point is that White's position
is a virtual Fortress against the
Queen's checking chances
and it's just a matter of coordinating
before you can slowly Advance it's it's
going to be hard to be clear it's going
to be hard to advance the pawns without
opening up your king to potential
Perpetual checks but
when I said we were in for an eight plus
hour game ladies and gentlemen I was not
kidding because sometimes that's what it
takes to get the job done in classical
chess it takes that much chess in order
to beat a tough opponent look at John's
face that's he's tired and he's
certainly not happy to defend this
because while the bar off the side of
the screen says something yep he
probably feels like he can make a draw
but it's extremely difficult at this
point because that rook in A7 has so
many different places to lend E5 G5 yep
Magnus will pick and choose and the King
can eventually run like you can end up
moving your knight to D4 your king
starts running actually this is how
white might coordinate very easily here
Knight to D4 and if queen queen H1
Knight to F3 that knife forms both a
defensive and an attacking function
close off checks and you threaten things
like 95 like Knight H4 the moment the
black king starts getting pushed back
and white can advance it this becomes
what we call an you act actively defend
against Perpetual what that means is as
the black queen is going to check this
white king Magnus is going to
essentially activate the king and use
the pieces like the knights and the
pawns to block the checks against the
queen it's easier said than done but
that's how this game will eventually be
won if it is to be or maybe just put the
Rook on E5 now because Queen H2 check
doesn't mean anything right rookie five
rookie seven sorry so rookie sorry
rookie seven Queen to H1 Rook to E5
and uh blackened trade the h g pawns
with H4 but I don't know if that helps
him make a draw because let's just say
white takes takes King G2 they made a
move but takes takes King G2 and ig3 I
think that this is this is a very tough
ending to defend yeah this is the kind
of position you start kicking the queen
you start advancing these yeah the
slowly really tough
slowly it's amazing that this Ebel bar
makes it look like oh this is close
compared to the positions this is like
this is just a win for what
um check it's not necessarily a win for
white but it's super tough to defend
especially in Practical game I wonder
why he gave this check
I mean it's probably a fine move but
um
why does it help white to to put the
Rook on the sixth rank it looks like
it's more it should be supported uh by
upon that four rookie five Rook G5
rather than is it is it possible he just
invited the king in am I blundering
something
it looks it looks more than shaky yeah I
don't know though because after King F5
uh yeah it's
we're gonna find out is he going no wait
wait wait king of five E4 check oh my
gosh for Queen E4 and G4 check oh my
gosh what a puzzle King G4 okay oh King
G4 I forgot you can take with your king
I was like so happy to Fork you
everywhere Knight C3 and if Queen takes
Robert's idea no but actually yeah I
just can't actually if you want to take
a 93 that's one of those you have a you
have a an end game puzzle and puzzle
rush and you're at your record 35 and
they give you an Indian puzzle I think
King F5 was shut off the phone and throw
it I think King F5 was was uh Jan's
chance to
his best chance to not suffer for a long
time to try to get because that King on
G4 it starts to really pose problems for
white it can even go to H3 you know but
but in that position right if the you
know King F5 just uh back here Knight D4
check
like your king is getting all right Rook
G6 check but maybe king T maybe it can
goes to D3 as well right but even here
like I was looking at this I was like
this Rook Chief I mean Rook G5 Queen A2
don't go to F3 oh my gosh it's made down
there nice
yeah that's a problem but you have like
Knight E2 and that's still Knight E2
it's suspicious it doesn't doesn't end
very maybe the king is better on e4 and
D3 but yeah it's understandable young
the youngest
going back and forth but Magnus has
improved the knights position The Rook
guards any checks on the second rank
what's what's the plan though for white
it's a very slow plan but it probably
involves getting the Rook to the fifth
rank maybe Rook to B1 it's not possible
here but trying to get that Rook to like
B5 and to G5 because that
yeah okay so Jana's trying to disturb
that work a bit but there's Rook A5 here
actually right so he can
but then maybe Queen B2 king of three
Queen B7
E4 it's hard to say
it starts to get sharp but Rook A5 looks
like a very interesting move but that
looks that looks tough for black too so
if we just go what five I'm saying Rook
A5 Queen B2 check uh King F3 Queen B7
check now Eve after E4 Rook G5 check is
up like a pretty big threat with Knight
F5 to follow yeah and there's no B3 and
let's say like Queen to B4 for example
or something to disturb the pieces then
Rook to G5 King to F6 wait which
position Queen be here Queen B4 let's
say
Rook G5 king of six E5 King F7 you know
the King on e4 will maybe doesn't go
here immediately but it feels feels so
good but there's going to be one
and a lot of these positions you end up
starting to play moves like this like
you want to block with the chat you want
to keep the Knight close to the king to
avoid Perpetual by the question which is
why you can even keep your Pawn on e4
just to Shield all sorts of checks
around uh but it's a position like 905
first right it gets very concrete if you
check like 93 and now five is loose and
you see the eval bar going up you make
one check that looks normal and all of a
sudden you might drop your Pawn so Rook
A2 and queen H1 are on the board okay
Knight F3 seems likely
okay to check first
but then the night will go back to F3
right
King F7 or G7 is met by Knight of three
guarding the checks yeah he's playing
this slowly he wants to gain time on the
clock he's going to play King somewhere
Knight F3 Queen will go somewhere like
B1 then The Rook will drop from D6 to D2
yeah I was gonna say you put the Rook
here then the rook and Knight are
coordinated for defense you can push the
E Pawn safely
this is a very very slow he might
actually try to push that e-pawn by
playing The Rook on E2 and E4 yeah I was
gonna say if the Rooks on E2 and the
King's on G2 and the Knights on F3 you
push the E Pawn
very difficult to stop you can even put
the Rook on E1 defended by the Knight
yeah then you then you'll get checks
from a second so probably work on E2 is
is going to be necessary at some uh
award on the second will be necessary at
some point slow jamming slow jamming it
is it time to predict the result Joshua
Chamberlain does he live
I think this is 50 50 still
yeah it's still very unclear to me if
white is actually
uh
has an objectively you know large
advantage or if it's just practically
super tough for black but this is
aside from
some of the moments where he was waiting
for one move like there was that
um roots of C2 and Knight F4 that we
pointed out this is the best chance he's
had all game yeah all match all match
all match yeah yeah all matches maybe in
years
I don't know if I'd go that far but uh
well I guess in years yes it was the
first time in this match then the last
time he played a match was years ago so
you're right you're right but here the
point is that black has shuffling to do
you don't have H4 for black and we're
just discussing that might not even be
helpful but you don't have it available
to you and bobiano said Rook D6 Rook D2
here we're seeing all this because as
long as White's King is shielded then E4
becomes a possibility you could see even
now
um once there was the D6 E4 becomes
possible because the queen can't take on
e4 Knight G5 check they're all sorts of
night Forks that black has to be on the
lookout for and that's no fun we usually
say this in speed chess and bullet in
particular Knights are great pieces he's
watching for Forks we're getting into
Blitz chest they don't have much time
and every move is critical at this
juncture for yawn to Palmer Street with
the black pieces
well said and of course we're joking
that it's been years I guess but
it has been five years since a decisive
game in the classical portion of the
World Chess Championship so if you're
tuning in one of the more than 100 000
on Twitch more than 35 000 on YouTube
and thousands scattered through the
other platforms we're streaming to
thanks for being with us and you might
be about to witness history
The Rook D5 is a funny move because
anyway after Queen A2 he has to go back
to D2 yeah so we we pretty much get the
same position black can't do anything
black has no con active idea so he just
Waits and asks white what do you do
well there is something a bit funny here
in these positions because after Queen
you know the queen will come to A2 and
we see Magnus laser focus here about to
rokitu right is what we've been talking
about right so the river comes to E2 and
now let's say you play Queen E4 to try
to stop white from playing Pawnee for
that's what you're afraid of but Queen
E4 just to show this like if you move
your knight to D2 and you're like oh
I'll go Queen H1 and try to check you
then the Knight goes back to F3 you
don't have checks anymore and then I can
push my we've seen this dog and pony
show before
you can't you can't stop that pawn from
going up to E4 to E5 and potentially the
E6 the question is after E6 black will
blockade it with the King he'll play
King to f8 to E8 or to E7 and how does
white make progress there and the
downside of moving your e-pawn forward
is that at the moment black has no way
to check the white king then black has
Queen B6 or C5 King G2 Queen to C6 black
can start to harass the white king
either with checks or with pins right
and then I guess my thinking is the
white king will go over to H2 to limit
some of your checks maybe I'll put my
knight on H4 and then go after H5 Pawn
so I may be willing to give up my e-pawn
to get your H Pawn and then my my
remaining two pawns are unopposed the
other idea I was going to answer that
question with is depending on where the
queen is if she's being sufficiently
sort of suppressed by the Knight you
also have the F Pawn depending on how
concrete those lines are
if you can get E5 and F5 that starts to
look super dangerous yeah the question
is can can you actually get it because
black will after E5 maybe play Queen to
B1 to cover that at five square black
doesn't want to see both those pawns
rolling for sure because if white gets
pawns on like E5 F6 then we're already
talking about pawns that are might be
rolling on their own right they barely
even need neither rook's help and then
Knight to G5 coming E6 suddenly we're
talking about promoting pawns
um so okay Jan is just trying to bother
Magnus a bit by playing Queen B6 white
can play King to G2 black will play like
Queen B5 and just try to annoy white
with
pushing that pawn forward which is not
so easy
and this is move 92 Queen B6 was played
here where nearing the century mark and
queen B6 is quite annoying because E4
not possible the pawn is pinned if you
start going King to G2 maybe the queen
will start going after the Rook with
Queen A6 or queen B5 that's why I was
saying rookie one
I mean the Rooks only won the night
guards at yeah but then after Queen B2
you don't want to put your King on the
first rank you can do that
maybe maybe you will eventually get E4
if you play like that but it's really
not how you want to play this position
what does this move Rook C2 besides just
happening he's preparing Knight D4 and
Rook to C6 to try to cut off that King
and prepare some Knight of five stuff
but he's just shuffling around he's
gaining time with every move you see he
he was down to under a minute yep now
Magnus is at four minutes 17 seconds
he can continue to gain time because
black can't do anything and black can
only claim a draw after 50 moves without
a pawn being pushed or a trade plenty of
time then yep yeah it looks like Queen
B1 was played and then Knight to D4 yep
so the black queen probes the Knight
goes to D4 to protect the Rook there are
some Knight F5 ideas as well
that
need to be considered so we see the
queen going to H1
so I I have a question I don't know the
answer to this what is the longest game
ever played in a world championship
match shout out to our daily trivia
question
I don't know the answer to that and I
don't know that we had that question but
for those of you who played along all
you had to do was quote your answer to
today's question
um I don't even know what the question
was or the answer it's been a very long
day and it will be worth it if we get a
decisive result if we don't
Robert's walking home that's fine for me
but the position that we're getting here
the
Queen is on H1 yep
and the King went to up to F6 so we see
that Black's King goes forward which
isn't that big of a deal right now but
if you could like play E3 to E5 that's
when things get tricky because as
Fabiano said pawns on E5 and F5 going
together though you might roll
themselves to the other side and become
a queen so E4 not possible right now
because a queen takes E4 but that's the
dream is pushing upon E5 in this
position yeah once nepo sees those pawns
rolling
[Music]
it's over
it's it's very dangerous for sure
well maybe he's got the right defense
going on he's preventing E4 leaving
Queen H2 check if you bring the Knight
back to F3 then the queen can just go
back over to B1 should go back to B1
because let's say Knight F3 if black
were to play Queen to D1 for example I
think white would happily take the
chance to play E4 in that situation yeah
because now there's no check here now
there's no chair at all and uh moves
forward are we
about is there like a three-time
repetition somewhere here I don't think
I don't think so because the king's on
F6 but I'm just trying to keep track
they're gonna have to watch out for that
for sure tonight wasn't on D4 previously
right obviously if the Knight goes back
to F3 we've had positions with the queen
on H1 the 9f3 but the King on F6 and The
Rook on C6 look a bit different very
easy to lose track of that but Magnus
will be very careful because he wants to
play this until the very end until the
50 move rule if he gets that or sorry he
starts pushing his Pawn to restart the
50 move rule for people who are watching
who may not be so familiar that if there
are 50 moves made without a pawn push or
a capture the game concludes as a draw
so that's something to keep in mind as
well that at some point Magnus may have
to make the move E4 or F5 to start the
move counter over again
there he is Magnus Carlson his legacy is
at stake
he wants to defend his title for the
fourth time
but Jan is defending this end game as
long as defending his incredibly well I
I think that this is frankly if John
holds this it might be as telling in
regards to what we'll be talking about
in the world championship as anything
else because this is the test we know
Magnus is going to get opportunities
like this and will Yan have the
discipline
and the perseverance to hold and it's a
cool moment because E4 is possible now
because even if you could check and take
the Rook as a knight Fork on E5 if you
take the pawn E4 there's Knight G5 check
so neither The Rook which can't be
attacked with check or the pawn E4 which
can be captured immediately they're
immune because of the night Force now
we've been talking about if you play E4
you King get Success With all sorts of
other checks yep but it feels like at
some point or another he'll have to play
a pawn push yeah we should show it if E4
takes just so everyone's aware that's
not a good idea yeah in this case black
will start to give checks and White's
King will be forced to the first rank
which it's not so clear if that's bad
but you probably don't want to go there
I don't even know what to do I think you
have to escape to the king side King to
G1 or something like that we have we
have uh
okay what do we have here we have Knight
G5 check that has been played so what
does Magnus want now because the Knight
on G5 doesn't attack anything there
except for the King give us a check he
could be preparing E4 and then trying to
run his King
through the middle of the board to to
create an attack using the king
but I don't see that really working out
so probably John will play King E7
I don't know if King G7 is also
also fine but King E7 looks a bit more
natural okay King G7 also looks
like a perfectly good move
and the one benefit I'm looking on G7 is
no Rook H6 where not certain that The
Rook wanted to go there just yet but
we've been talking about this Dynamic if
we trade epon for H Pawn that means that
white has a little bit more freedom to
try to push those pawns off the board
but here are the kings on G7
where is it it feels like white should
be relatively close to be inching
forward I'm not even sure I see a move
right now yeah I'm wondering about E4
and then I just want to run my king down
E3 D4 E5 and try to create a meeting at
let's just see
how that oh wow you're just gonna ditch
I'm ditching the G3 Pawn I like it I
know that's a very committal but what's
your line E4
let's say queen to B2 King de3
Queen to B3 King to D4
and if Queen G3 King to E5 I like it
going all the way trying to create a
mating net using all the pieces you
threatening things like King F5 in some
positions they're really close to C7 and
here you go
maybe even the previous episode yeah
maybe the previous group was nag here
maybe Rook to C7 first because of King
to G6 there's F5 that wins yes it does
winning the queen and then promoting
first
so okay so stuff like this could be
possible but it's tough he gives a check
which is smart just to gain time it
looks like he's going back to D4 now
because after King F7
he's probably getting I mean I don't
think he wants to play Knight G5 again
he might but
it looks like he's just trying to play
E4
because you can never take this Rook on
C6 we talk about night Force there's a
fork on d8 this time and you can't take
on e4 because of the four gun G5 so this
Knight is such a tricky piece he does go
back to D4 which is uh sensible it seems
like he doesn't want to push until he's
either forced to or he feels absolutely
ready but you can see yon's chair
shaking
I wonder if he wants to play F5 now that
looks a really like a really weird move
but let's say queen H1 F5 this actually
allows the king to March up in case of
checks Queen H2 King F3 Queen's one king
of four Once the king gets active we're
talking about a mating attack so it
looks strange to try you try to move
pawns together right E4
F5 slowly but moving one Pawn up is a
bit unusual it makes a lot of sense to
me
well Queen H1 has been played and as
Robert observed Jan's chair was shaking
that's the first time I think we've seen
either players chair Shake in the entire
match and you know that I mean they're
very nervous at this stage a yawn more
so than Magnus Magus can't lose this
position unless he blunders yeah right
but here it's a position where after
Queen H1 The Rook came back to F6 we
have seen this position before he's
going to give another check now once
there's no advantage to having the King
on F6 besides to give second game which
means we've seen that position twice at
least Magnus will have to think about
yeah you have to you're possible three
folds by the way it's quite possible
when we mentioned history not only have
we not had a decisive game in classical
chess in five years the longest game in
world championship history was cord Show
versus karpov in 1974 and it was 124
moves for those of you following along
at chess.com events one of our
moderators can share a direct link to it
you can see we are on move 101 we'll
keep you updated on the moved number but
again encourage everybody to go over to
chess.com you can still watch our show
from the direct link so if our staff can
share some links people can join us and
watch over at chess.com events I think
unless we see a three-fold repetition in
this may very well break that record of
the longest world championship game yeah
if Magnus wins this game we are breaking
that record for sure yes
Queen which is not going to happen yeah
I mean but there are some mating Nets
around this King and I just want to show
one sample line here if you go E4 right
now you blunder Queen B6 check so that's
that's clear but it don't do that I'm
just trying to make a point if Queen
takes E4 like let's say you get E4 and
you take on e4 like Rook F7 check can
catch you really off guard and now
you're in trouble because King and this
line but if you also went King G6
there's F5 check and if King H6 there's
Rook H7 check and Knight G5 of course
there's Queen B6 in the initial position
to win that Rook but these kind of
positions the King on F6 in particular
the king is running out of squares and
can be very vulnerable to that Rook
Knight in those Pawns
so he's keeping track of how many times
each position has been played
yeah he's looking at it well it's
difficult to keep things I was gonna say
he's keeping track of something but it's
very difficult to keep track of the
repetition of of a position because
remember the rule is
you don't have to repeat the same
position three moves in a row as long as
the same position occurs it could be a
hundred moves separating them in theory
not likely but in theory
but at least he he knows that that is a
possibility so he's yeah he's looking at
it right now trying to keep track of it
uh at some point he's going out to make
a decision yep
Yawn is
not
not so sure okay so we're going to try
to shake things up
he can play an id2 but
looks a bit
although it makes sense because then you
kind of push E4
okay but he plays Rook D2
we've seen this position before but was
the queen on B2 right that that's the
question where of the where's the queen
been if it might have been on A2 right
right but is Queen B1 is that the third
time in in this position after Rook D2
Queen B1
I'm not sure what
that's why they have an Arbiter on site
keeping track of this stuff well we can
see actually a move 91
if you go there for a second D2
.1 no but the queen went to B1 yeah but
the king but the King was on oh and I
think he's an F6 yeah yeah has to be the
exact same position so
Magnus might be checking little details
like that if they haven't already gotten
them a second score sheet I'm sure that
they will soon I think he's more
frustrated that he can't find an idea to
make progress yep
Rook to E2 would be nice but Queen to B6
I don't see we saw that position right I
don't see how he's pushing that pawn
ahead
maybe that E4 or that crazy stuff that I
mentioned was was some sort of chance
but it's really tough to play like that
right it's just jettison the G3 Pawn run
your king up yeah but it did feel like
you know why can't ever really lose
these positions no why why wasn't going
to lose that one
well you're still worried that you you
know blunder a fork of uh rook and king
to the queen and you know at this stage
of the game when they've been playing
for so long and such a difficult game
like this was not a game where Magnus
has been trying to nurse an advantage
the whole time he's been close to losing
he's been objectively winning
uh they're they're exhausted
Knight G1 he Retreats the night back oh
he wants to play rookie two E4 King on
G2 he actually forces through E4 in that
case
that's actually really interesting
midnight on G1 this is the guard the E2
Rook with the King on G2 you can finally
push the pawn yeah or you can put the
King on H2 John gave us a look there
saying okay I see but what if after
white goes rookie too black brings the
queen right back to E4
um that's actually really irritating yep
yeah that actually
that stops everything the the point yeah
yeah if the Knight is on F3 then the
queen is not sitting on e4 because of
what the Knight has been doing but then
with the queen on e4 work on E2 yes your
queen can't move again so I go back to
F3 before I talked about earlier I
kicked the queen away with something
some knight move and then you bring your
knight back to after so yeah let's let's
have a look at that it's a very direct
so Queen E4 Queen E4 here rookie two
rookie two King somewhere somewhere well
that is a risk yourself King F6 Knight
G5 Queen goes H1 and we go Knight F3
back so actually I mentioned finally got
yourself in a spot where you can play
and we're not claiming this is winning
and we see the evaluation bar isn't
going crazy but the point is that you
need to play E4 at something you have to
one so that it's not a draw by 50 moves
or threefold repetition and Knight G1
means we will not get a three-fold
repetition because the Knight has never
been on G1
um and Magnus wants to play E4 that's
the two things it shows the question is
after he gets E4 can you make progress
after that
it is objective
did he play Rook to D1 he did play Rook
D1 after Queen to B4 so
well there he is surprising us again
yeah
I I wonder
why he didn't go rookie too maybe he
doesn't want to play E4 maybe he thinks
that's just a drawn position
well he he's gonna get M5 at some point
I mean otherwise he has to do what he's
going with this
so you have a check Queen B3 through in
a check maybe he wants E4 but only when
the black king is in a certain spot
maybe here King G7 E4 he wants
too
hmm
yeah if you keep shuffling of course at
some point the position will repeat
three times
where is he going with this
yeah I liked your plan earlier though
the E4 and the King running in that felt
like
yeah quite chance it was an idea I mean
it's almost certainly a draw there but
Magnus looks like
he no longer has so much hope that it's
that he has serious winning chances here
but he's concentrating he's locked in
he's hoping that Jan puts his King on a
square that could be vulnerable to a
night fork or just allow E4 to be
punched through with stronger effect but
Jan is doing well on the clock that's
really important here and he has more
time you get 30 seconds added to their
clock with every move they make so they
can build up their clock and Yan is
doing very well to stay ahead he does
not want to be down under a minute and
then there's E4 happens and he has to
make a critical Choice with not enough
time remaining so here he he's smart
that you know qg7 yep right just to hide
the king away not be in the path of a
night Fork once the Knight comes back to
F3 there's no Knight five Knight G5
things like that but I just don't know
where can Magnus may play Rook D4 Knight
E2 Pawn E4 in that manner
um because that blocks checks in the
diagonal yeah that makes sense The Rook
on d4902 makes perfect sense well maybe
that's what he's going for
well did he
um okay so here we go we understand his
idea
92 and E4 will
it's an interesting one the reason I
like it is because then I don't need two
not only guards The Rook it guards G3
and F4 making any sort of crazy tactics
to blow this thing open less effective
yeah I think this is a great idea
because Also let's say if white plays
Queen B1 92 Queen H1 after E4 Queen H2
not only is G3 Pawn defended yeah after
King E3 we saw that night in previous
variations it defends the king against
any checks so there's no queens you won
there's no Queen C1 there's no checks
and then white will happily push F5 the
question becomes after H4 let's say that
we see a trait of H and G pawns okay
well White
have serious winning chances there or
will the King still be a bit vulnerable
I think in that position you'd want your
Pawn back on E3 which is kind of that's
funny and it's one of the reasons Magnus
has been so patient here once you commit
there's no going back right so he really
wants to be sure that his Knight his
Rook his King are all in their ideal
setups for the
for The Rush
um but there is also something to note
that if like 92 happens and white can
play F5 and put the Rook on F4
that's very dangerous because you're
going to push the pawn as far as you can
yeah and if the king tries to blockade
the pawn if your knight can free up for
some checks that's also a worry of
course if your knight starts going in
for checks your king is susceptible to
checks against the Black by The Black
Queen so it's not that clear-cut but
that's one of the ideas that Magnus can
keep in his back good point we'll
analyze that real quick like if let's
just show if like the king went to G6
and the Knight went to E2 and the King
went back
there's as long as there's no check on
C2 hitting the king and picking up the
pawn F5 is an idea yeah e4f F5 we're
gonna swing The Rook here
and suddenly F6 is coming there's no H4
the problem is your knight can't get in
the game so easily because what once the
king sits on F6 you need your knight to
get to E4 something like that yeah as
soon as your knight leaves there are a
bunch of checks I think that we we have
Queen B2 check 92 and queen to B1 all on
the board
yeah maybe Jan is showing his intention
to play E4 Queen H1 and to trade those g
h pawns yeah
the problem also with the Knight on E2
even though we like it for all the
defensive reasons of the pawns Robert is
the Knight on F3 is the best one to
defend the king from Czechs right now
now the threat of Queen to H1 from Yawn
is renewed well with the King on E3
though it is completely covered from
checks okay that's very so let's say E4
Queen to H1 I think white would love to
get Rook D5 and King E3 as one move here
yeah but it's not it it's not possible
maybe maybe
after queen bee when we start with Rook
D5
aren't we going back to the previous
stuff I'm gonna go quickly to H1 and how
are you pushing E4 now yeah yeah you can
move Rook E5 no but I like I like this
idea of
E4 and then King E3 I like H4
take maybe black gives a check on H3
first king D2 Queen H4 but this is this
is here we go
yeah we're you know there's no going
back now right last game of the year Dan
don't hold anything back it's the same
scenario where the Knight needs to help
out so you can push the pawns yeah but
as soon as the Knight leaves there's a
bunch of checks the queen will get
this is and he goes E4 oh okay we have
action the pawn has released the Kraken
release the Kraken and that restarts the
50 move counter yep so they don't have
to worry about three-time repetition
they don't have to worry about 15 moves
that are captured or on push and that
means we almost certainly are going to
break the world championship record for
longest ever game that was move 110 for
those who just tuned in the longest game
in World Chess Championship history was
Scorch Noy karpov 1974 at 124 moves I'm
gonna call it
we will we will be breaking 1978 I
apologies correction I apologies
has it been a long day or what it's been
a long day shout out to all those who
woke up with us at 2 A.M on the west
coast huh
all three of them all five of the
viewers all three of the people wait
wake up maybe a strong word for people
who are up at 2AM yeah they may have
just had a long night
all right well E4 played and
did did John move because it looks like
Magnus is
thinking here waiting oh okay so E4 was
played sorry Queen H1 and Rook he's
getting seven checks makes sense the
King has to make a choice does it go if
it goes forward suddenly there's checks
I don't think he wants to go forward so
maybe it just goes to the back rank
let's say it's G8 because if King F6 E5
I'm starting to get a bit worried about
that King right
if it goes to G6 F5 same story
and I really wish that Knight could go
to F5 and the King could just run into
the
the middle right your plan from earlier
with an E2 that's it's a great defensive
piece right but not a great attacking
price Knights are I struggle to turn
from a Defender it's an offensive piece
but Jan he's goes back to G8
which makes sense considering what you
were saying no Pawn pushes the check but
now we can start thinking about some
Pawn pushes the E5 and I'm a bit
concerned E5 H4 that work on D7 is
hanging
oh because the Rook is yeah is loose
there for example if King G8 E5 H4 if
White
let's try the movie five or you know
let's run back to defamer so he's just
so he's repeating
black and play H4 immediately or repeat
the position with King to G7
you should probably play tickle here no
reason to play H4
unless yeah he feels that H4 immediately
secures him in the half point that he
feels that he has enough play against
the pawns and pieces but Magnus can keep
playing this why not question was a bit
funny because the king's better on E3
yeah you actually forced the king where
he wants to go probably shoot on his
plate H4 55 now becomes a pretty serious
idea
I think at some point here we have to
CH4 and look at
actually this line might not work I was
going to say if King G7 here
like Rook D5
and of H4
sometimes you play Rook H5
but the thing is H3 might turn this
around where you are dilute now you lose
now who's better yeah not white anymore
well then we have the weird question of
Knight and three pawns against Queen
Knight in three pawns versus queen is a
question
no I'm actually asking I've never seen
that game before
I guess the queen wins but yeah I don't
know probably probably but okay we're
not 100 sure they're not on F5
and the King on E3 it's it's difficult
to break down H4 has been played
H4 has been played along with that we
look at this exact line King D2 will
will come we saw with the King on G7
it's a slightly worse version for black
here but essentially shouldn't change
very much right with the King on G8
why might play E5 here that looks very
sensible
and you know after E5 white might
already be threatening F5 because the
root goes behind the F Pawn and then as
Robert said that those bonds start to
end moving
uh that could be dangerous and he goes I
like that move Rook D3 oh I also like
that movie that's a great move you just
say your turn yep I'm not committing and
The Rook can go behind E3 maybe goes to
F3 can also go to G3 I mean white can
choose
we are in
possibly table based territory yeah I
was going to say we might seven pieces
we might actually
have an answer we do
wow that this is a draw
yeah well that's that's not too too
surprising
uh only moves which blunder the queen
immediately loses yeah I was saying I
see you know options that lose right but
they're all Queen G4 walking into a pan
for getting up for those watching all
all moderators please share a link to
the uh to the direct the direct game on
chess.com and if you click the table
base tab in the upper right
you can actually see the answer to the
position we can't actually show it in
front of you because it would cover
magnus's beautiful face and our show
we're not going to do that but if you
click the table base tab in the upper
right you can actually see the forced
and if somebody is to make a mistake and
blow it you'll be able to see it in real
time
um that it is no longer a draw but
according to the table base black should
be able to draw this ending
but a table based drawer doesn't mean
not at all not at all table based straw
you heard the doubt when someone's when
you said we should check the table base
I was I was actually shocked that it was
a draw oh I know I thought this should
be a draw but at the same time 500 made
this point a long long time ago in a
a land far away where you can make a
move just with your hand rather than
with your brain you move your queen
across the board you know the difference
between B6 and A6 looks nothing and then
one move loses and the other holds so
Magnus is going to continue pressing his
look at his pieces the Knight The Rook
the pawns the king they're all nice and
compact here so if he can
limit the checks that the black queen
can give maybe then he can push his
pawns and we see you know Magnus is
giving this his all both players are and
they're coming out the rest day I think
they might need another rest day
tomorrow they're not getting one but
they probably need one
they probably need it let's keep going
we're gonna we're gonna stay right in
here the live view
and it looks like Eon brought his Queen
back to its starting square with check
and he does get a bunch of checks that's
the good news for young if the king
tries to come back towards the center
and it looks like Max is doing that the
queen can go diagonally to B6 square and
give another check so but white can
cover that check very comfortably with
Knight to D4
and White's goal is Knight D4 E5 King E4
you want to move that King up with the
protection of pieces around it pieces
and pawns and if you eventually get your
king to F5
then when black gives a check you can
play White six and white can give up
exactly can cover with a counter check
so
that's the goal for white it's of course
a very long and slow process if white
wants to try for a win
there's no immediate sort of threats why
I can make well I guess 94 isn't a
immediate threat to the fork but uh in
general black will move around why we'll
move around and try to push the Pawns
you know I think in so many of these
variations it can be scary for black
right you just get in your own head more
than anything yawns are doing a
fantastic job bring his Queen back and
forth all across the board but then you
see Knight D4 E5 King E4 these moves
that you've been talking about and you
can just worry yourself unnecessarily
and he goes Queen A5 if Knight D4 that's
a huge blunder because Queen C3 check
will actually win the Knight yep on D4
immediately so that's out of the
equation and if you push the pawn to E5
your King's not going to be able to go
up to E4 because after Queen A3 check
King E4 Queen A8 check and your King's
not going up because you would lose your
Rooks the King has to go back once more
so maybe he wants to play F5 to give the
king another Square to go forward
the king can go to F4 Square
[Music]
very true
and just to show examples where it can
go wrong if you're giving careless
checks in these positions you're just
helping your opponent advance
yeah and sometimes it's a good check
like here after Queen C4 yeah draws
comfortably yeah after here you have to
go back so that would be but an example
of a careless check let's go continue
with that line okay uh E5 Queen C4 King
E3 Queen C5 King E4
and now I think Queen C6 is a drop if
you play Queen C4 Knight D4
I'm not sure what kind of territory
we're in anymore because suddenly
there's no checks and white is super
advanced
um it could be that there's only like
one or two moves at all yeah now we
already saw that position only three
moves were drawing for black and
everything else was losing so
black has to be careful
and look at this he's Magnus has
switched which Pawn is rookies behind
and at any moment he could just push E5
right he doesn't have to push the F Pawn
he could use the E1 and he gets to
dictate the action here but this is
going to be so hard for John to hold
because this is he's just gonna keep
pushing this
forever
yeah and any time again there is no 50
move draw or three move repetition here
the position will slowly advance and at
some point the critical moment will come
and the queen will have to find all the
accurate checks to hold oh I think that
at some point we will see a position
where black has only one or two moves to
make a drop exactly at some point we
will have his moments in the game where
black has to play Super accurately right
now he can probably make any move and
it's still objectively a draw
but that's not gonna last forever yeah
and that's why the table bases although
useful it is a little bit misleading on
the complexity of this position
I would lose this position with both
sides that's definitely not true white
has no risk of losing unless you blunder
everything have you ever seen me play
chess
um I'm not going to answer that question
but here
then I went to G3 so it's clear he wants
to start pushing his pawns Jan says
Queen D2 check if you go King F3 there's
Queen D1 and then the Rook can come back
to E2 the Knight is perfectly placed on
G3 so Fabi so I look at this we talk
about careless checks I mean Rook E2 to
block the check
okay sorry king of three in the live
position here rookie two and if you give
a careless check like Queen D3 and King
G4
the king's escaping your queen D7 I go
F5 right I can push this is what I was
talking about in terms of careless
checks you know and if you keep careless
checking you might careless check
yourself off the board
yeah we're probably still in draw
territory but white is starting to
advance so after King F3 rookie two
Queen B3 I suspect he'll play King G2
the king cannot be checked there and
then he can try to push his Pawns in
relative peace at least for the moment
at some point the checks will Begin
Again
but for the moment after King G2 black
doesn't have a checking Square which
doesn't lose the queen right and then
white will play F5 next
and then E5 and then the checks will
begin again and we'll have to start
calculating stuff
so
Jan is still playing quickly there they
both have a healthy amount of time
and we're about to break the world
record for longest world championship
game we are nearing history here will it
be a decisive game today uh it's I have
no idea how to answer that question but
I know that either way we have broken
history here in the 2021 World Chess
Championship because the move Rook to D2
officially makes this game the longest
game in World Chess Championship history
these two guys made it happen maybe he
doesn't want F5 maybe he wants Rook to
D5 and then the king sneaks around King
history G4 and the rook and Knight cover
checks from pretty much everywhere do
you think either of these guys or ask it
this way do you think Magnus knows that
this is objectively probably a draw I
would guess yes that makes no difference
to him but I would guess he's probably
aware that with best play this should
hold
I I don't think they're a hundred
percent know that right okay but I think
they assume because this sort of end
game is known with well let's say not
with enf but with other configurations
of Pawns yep they assume that's a draw
they they both don't look like either of
them is thinking this game is going one
way or the other right now but that's
that's still different from you know
knowing how to draw it or how to win it
right Magnus has one with a lot less
right he's at positions where you've
seen even material and he just squeezes
inches forward finds a little hole in
his opponent's position and is able to
take advantage but one of the critical
things here is e-force protected and
even if the move Queen takes F4 were
possible if we're legal then Rook F2 so
the black king well it probably needs to
establish itself in front of the pawns
rather than off on the side of the board
because then the pawns just start going
it makes it harder for black to really
attack the pawns even when they're
hanging sometimes you shouldn't take it
because there could be a pin and so I
like the way that Max is doing this he's
not rushing and he's leaving yon with
more decisions to make and we see him
bring the queen to B3 he's playing
active defense here but what Fabiano
said at some point the king would like
to run through H3 to G4 and in the event
of Rook D5 right now
you still won't be able to take on F4
even if you can attack it because Rook
F5 checks so if we show this for a
second like Rook D5 Queen E3
King H3 like you're not threatening the
opponent F4 because it's Rook F5 check
so white can try his best to run the
King around this way it's not gonna be
easy because black can take away the
squares with his Queen but that's
something that
is in the cards potentially maybe he can
also give a check first on d8 Rook to d8
King let's say some some Square
and the King might be a bit more
vulnerable to checks like let's say now
here Rook to D5
now Queen E3 is no longer a move right
Knight to F5 wins the queen directly
and it really doesn't change so much but
yeah let's say queen Z2 and now white
plays King to F3 or H3 tries to get that
King slowly up the board without
allowing too many checks or Perpetual
check
right and we'll and well we see that
Magnus grabs a piece as we know chess
players love to do they're a little
nervous they fiddle with pieces here and
the Queen on B3 it just it feels like if
the king tries to escape the H3 maybe
that Queen comes to F3 and just make
sure that while the Knight on G2 is a
great defender it's not going to be able
to get active because it's pinned and
the King has no Escape for white so
and these push upon
I think he might have no no okay it
feels like a very good Rook on D5 yes
very actively placed it blocks off a lot
of the Queen's influence
so there's no
like the queen can't get to E6 or to G8
right
and yeah I mean when we look at this uh
position here so where where do you
think this queen should go like what's
the ideal I was thinking black can try
to give checks Queen to B2
yeah let's say queen B2 King H3
yep
Queen to h8 King to G4 so you're trying
to check from the front yeah I'm trying
to check anywhere I can
okay so you're saying it's not careless
right it's a queen B2 check well it
might be codes but it might lead to the
same sort of position because I don't
know if black can
can really stop white from advancing the
king now right between the G7 is there
Rook G5 Rook to G5 Queen to D7 yep
so The Rook can come to F5 would check
the Knight can block on F5 the pawn can
block on F5 I don't like the Knight
blocking because then the queen comes to
D1 and I don't think you can stop those
tracks it's a very good point that the
the Knight blocking all of a sudden
there's checks and yeah you're not
stopping them but after Rook to F5 black
has to make a tough choice where to put
that King anywhere it goes it's either
vulnerable to a check or a fork by the
Knight right potentially right and it
also gets in the way of Black's Queen
checks for example of King to E7 maybe
white plays King to G5
and then Rook to E5 Knight to five you
see how we're slowly creeping up the
board right and that's the idea you
mentioned before and black had an H Pawn
in some of these types of positions so
this could be really scary we'll hop uh
back to the live position seeing some
moves were in fact played uh rooked The
Rook on D5 and King to E7 Rook to E5 was
played yes right so we're King to F7 so
to check on E5 King to F7 and
yeah I don't think much has changed
white will probably try to run the king
down the board now maybe with King to H3
or sorry run the king up the board
rather uh Kings of H3 makes a lot of
sense maybe then the queen goes on F3
and that's sort of annoying
for white
uh so okay Magnus continues giving
checks because well he has time right
he has 50 moves between every every Pawn
movie he can make
he actually if we think about how many
Palm moves are left we're looking at 50
moves times a lot which is more math
than I am qualified to do I think
there's something really important
though about The Rook being on F5 okay
that when the King goes to H3 and the
black queen comes to F3
just uh to show this why can play King
H4 if the Rook went on F5 H F4 would be
hanging with check but the king H4 now
we're renewing all sorts of different
options that black needs to consider and
it's really difficult at this moment
well now we see Rook F5 King E8 has been
played
on the board and is it time it is time
time nope wait no we're pushing E5 he
pushed E5
okay now the Rook might go to F6 that F6
square is a beautiful one for the king
to slowly go up because look at how much
space white is taking away from Black's
Queen checks suddenly where do you let's
say the king is on H3 and working on F6
yep where did you check that King from
yep C8 it doesn't look like a great
Square to check from and the King will
anyway move up if the Rook is on F6 and
King on H4 black has only one square to
check from which is H2 I guess
potentially H7 as well but it is
interesting I think an instructor for
the viewers to say how we keep saying
this should be a draw yet white is
making progress so what is it about the
position that will eventually be a draw
it's that white will eventually have to
expand far enough that the board opens
up fully for the queen to Chase the king
right and it's easier said than done but
or or is you you guys are the great what
what is I was assuming that's the reason
but what is the reason this may be bold
but I think that's more likely that
white wins a position like this than
black for us I'm starting to feel that
too especially with the Rook coming to
F6 yeah
it it's a draw objectively but it might
come down to only moves at some point
right it might be that white spawns
Advanced all the way and at that point
you have only checks here and there
I don't think that that's realistic
uh for black to find
right it's much easier for white because
he has no there's no risk he can just he
also doesn't have any any responsibility
with time he has all the Time in the
World to to advance his his pawns and
pieces right here for example The Rook
is pinned you can play King G4 to defend
that rook and let's say black passes
then you can win Knight E4 maybe Knight
G5 and then the king can we go King H5
King to G6 that's asking for a lot I'm
aware of that but those are the type of
things where if that King gets all the
way in there you're gonna not have
enough checks because you're King on E8
actually Limits The Black Queen yeah
continuing to check the king as the
white king marches up the board if white
gets Knight G5 and King G6 I think it's
over I think that's just winning because
you can't you can no longer check that
King anymore
I mean white we'll play like Rook F7 E6
F5 and and the opponents push themselves
at that point yeah so we're already in
that and that's what we've been saying
from the beginning regardless of the
table base that this is a this is it's a
winning end game for white black has to
find the only moves can we check the
table base now white wins no
that's what it says oh wow according to
the table base white is officially
winning which means what was the move
it was right here Queen E6 which is
apparently Queen E6 was the losing move
and the only two moves that Drew were
both moves that maintained the long
diagonal and it is instructive still
even though again it's not not to
reiterate the point I made but the point
is you have to have your queen in a
position where she's reaching the whole
board you can't put your queen in a
position where her options are limited
right and this is still the the queen
had to defend from g2h to those squares
yeah and for some reason why can't it to
the point now if the king comes up white
has moves like Queen G2 or sorry black
hazards like Queen and obviously I would
lose this game as I already
self-deprecated okay I would lose this
to anybody I think most of us would lose
this yeah look at the bar look at the
bar like it is officially just winning
territory yep and everybody can see it
and I think that Jan might know it
because if your queen is on H6 you got
nothing going on for you here yep the
white king is marching off the board
already at age four maybe we'll keep
going and those pawns what are you gonna
do about those Pawns yep I'm not going
to do nothing about the pawns they're
not my pawns Robert and let's say queen
to G6
or queen to H7
uh he played Queen H7 so and it's going
to be similar okay I want to try Queen
H7 Rook to G5 because I want to get that
Rook to G7 to fully auto out and then
you're putting that check is a threat
too broke to G8 is all media threat but
let's say the queen goes back to B1
okay
Rook to G7
maybe it's it's not good to cut that
King off yeah actually this puts us back
in a weird drawing territory because the
queen is in a more it feels like open
board right yeah I already messed it up
and and possible this is just so hard
but it's
so obviously we're gonna we're gonna be
diving into all of this just to remind
everybody
to G5 now it's not on the board yet
though right but can't but wait where's
yourself Queen GA checking or King to H6
yeah exactly and then fully invade with
with Rook F6 F5 E6 the King on H6 can we
check from h8 King G6 no then Queen G8
Knight G7
King to E7 E6 a rook F7 and this is this
is just yeah and there's no checks
you've blocked blocked them all so Queen
H7 played
King G5 so yeah you don't want to let
the queen go back to be when we were
talking about that earlier at the moment
when not only had those move two moves
that Drew so
wait the queen xl5 is not a threat by
the way white can maybe play E6 that's
exactly what I was thinking Queen F5 is
not a threat because of Knight G7 the
Knight G7 check so E6 was because of
Rook F7 the third Rook of seven and you
can't ever take this Pawn E6 anyway with
Queen E7 check like you're not taking
this Pawn that can't be captured right
also Queen Seven Rook F6 yep and you're
Frozen but King G4 might also be very
good
Kings of G4 because that pawn is immune
as Robert mentioned but I like King G5
most that to me that feels like that
looked like an E6 he played yeah that
looks like an E6 okay he's played E6
the queen cannot capture The Rook
because of the fork on G7
the moves available to Black are
becoming less and less the moment that
Queen came to the short side of the
board if you will she cut off her
opportunities and put black in a
technically losing game no judgments
this was almost impossible to hold
regardless which is why we've seen Carl
one tactic I want to say if black plays
Queen G6 here for example a passing move
I like to move Rook to F7
now that is threatening Knight F6 E7 and
if black takes on E6 Knight G7 King F7
Knight E6 King E6 with the G5 King F7
King F5
this is I know your king component
endings kids
it's a winning Pro it's a winning end
game for what wow I mean it was an
immensely difficult task for young we've
been sort of
saying that for a long time now where it
seemed like mag was pushing pushing
waiting finding his moments and this is
a lost position for Jana and what you're
saying Danny is so important that when
the queen is close to a knight what yeah
my coach and five minutes coach taught
us at a young age is Knights are amazing
Defenders because let's see the queen
was on age six like even if the Rook
weren't over there you don't have a
single check yep because the Knight
cover is F6 it covers F4 and is blocking
the H file yep so Knights are amazing at
restricting the queen and that's why the
queen needed to be on B1 on C2 all the
way on the side of the board to give
checks so the Knight couldn't block but
now it's way too late for that the king
is coming up the pawn The Rook
everything is working harmoniously and
Jana palmchi he knows he's lost right
yeah it's one of those really
instructive just the geometry lesson
that is a chessboard when you see a
knight dominate a queen in close
proximity because the queen as powerful
as she is has no access to these long
diagonals the things that she normally
does to flex muscles on both sides of
the board oh Queen G6 Rook F7 is winning
on the spot now Rook F7 threatens Knight
F6 and again six is losing did you
mention that the king of Pawn inning
we've already talked about if Queen
takes 26 you Fork
we just saw the bar go Wilder maybe Rook
F7 Queen to H6 is Possible Oh no
so why is this I don't know I think the
evil bar just I think it was just taking
a second to evaluate no this is still
winning what sometimes happens is it
sees you know lines right but doesn't go
deep enough right and so it may think
that king of Pawn game doesn't see an
issue that's winning of course it is The
Rook F7 we use our human intuition here
and take a breath boys and girls you're
about to start you're about to see the
first decisive result in more than five
years in classical chess of the World
Chess Championship I expect yonda Palm
Desi
to throw in the towel in this position
I really do yeah and I think we will uh
we will have
we will have blood from Dubai as they
say we will have our first victory
yeah no no bowling pins no bowling
alleys Paul Daniel you'll be okay yeah
but this is this is a problem because
this is going to be the end of the game
we said very early on that Yampa G takes
F6 he played B5 it just feels like a
lifetime ago he was playing very well
but he lost the thread and they became a
very Magnus carlson-esque position yep
and here we are we're about to see the
first classical chess victory for Magnus
Carlson in a world championship since
2016.
we're wrong he doesn't resign he makes
one more one more I think F5 is easy
enough yes
F5 and the Knight goes to F6
or white might just push that pawn
forward by force I think probably white
is already in territory where
most moves which don't blunder
material win
black screen will go to G1
Magnus has chosen F5 white can play Rook
to D7 to start with
or
I think probably Knight F6 also does the
trick yeah Knight F6 threatens E7 and
there's no way to deal with it well
there's a lot of checks so it gets a big
concerns the king can hide which I think
there's a path because there's Queen H6
in the end there but
um
what's what's the most clinical way to
do it here I feel like actually Rook to
G7 is a very good way of doing it
because that threatens E7 just as much
because the Rook gets out of the way
oh that's that's the that's even nicer
he's the highest the same idea is the
Knight on F6 and that it threatens z7
everyone but this actually keeps the
much easier Escape Route for the king so
the king's actually go to G8 yeah okay
because it goes to F6 so it checks in
the diagonal but you're gonna go exactly
like that and then that's it I think
this is resign the moment to resign
wow
and I mean for John de palmistry
this is a brutal moment because in the
first five games of the match he was the
one with more chances yep and in this
game he also had his fair share of
chances he was the one who kept the
Queens on tried to play and then the
imbalance that he created and yet here
we are The Rook the Knight the two pawns
that's the end of the story here one of
them the e-pawn is going to promote you
have to sacrifice your queen for it that
of course is losing and Magnus Carlson
he's going to shush the doubters he's
put his finger to his lips too early in
certain events and there it is there's
the handshake and that is Magnus Carlson
taking the three and a half two and a
half lead the first decisive game in
more than five years of classical chess
for the World Chess Championship
yeah no but in general yeah
okay I mean in
[Music]
the Blitz Games
yeah
foreign
and as we said you just witnessed
history the longest game in World Chess
Championship history the first decisive
game in more than five years in the
classical portion of the World Chess
Championship and Magnus Carlson takes
a very very crucial game and takes the
lead in Dubai
wow yeah that was quite again that could
have gone anyway
we saw Magnus in trouble at some point
we saw him winning at some point we were
sure it would be a draw
then we saw this Queenie formu suddenly
we saw some hope for Magnus I'm sure he
saw it too we thought it was a draw
again Yan was defending well
and finally he pulled through in the end
well amazing game
let's remind everybody again there's a
lot to come regardless of how tired we
are we have a post show to do we have
Recaps to deliver we have guests to
welcome we have so many things to break
down the world will be buzzing about
what just was game six from the 2021
vide World Chess Championship but don't
go anywhere remember we also have the
live post game press conference live
from Dubai so there is so much ahead
that you're going to want to tune into
and keep watching for because you just
witnessed history in more ways than one
we're going to take a very short break
when we come back Chestnut comps
coverage presented by coinbase continues
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes we will discuss it on
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship in one minute
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always feel like you could could do
more but I guess we are doing some
insane amount of work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes we will discuss it on
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
foreign
lighting and audio
[Music]
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in a free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
numeral lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS gave us an incredible fight and we
had the first Victory photographers you
know to stay out of the way of the
cameras and also for the journalists as
a reminder when you ask your questions
please keep your mask on and do not
touch the microphones at the side of the
room uh first question for you Magnus
this
were you aware of the fact that this
isn't the longest world championship
game in history and how do you feel at
this moment breaking through winning
this game after not having won uh a game
in over five years
um
yeah I think I had the previous record
as well probably against Anand
um although that wasn't nearly as many
hours and
actually it was Court snowy car parts uh
it was still uh yeah the um the one
where he tried to win with the bishop
and wrong Pawn is that correct uh yeah
uh okay anyway
um
that's um yeah somebody told me after
after the game obviously I'm elated to
um to get with this
um
result
um was never easy
um nor I mean frankly should it be
um
and uh there was
a lot of the same emotions as
um as the the game that I that I won
against karyakin where was just um
a marathon there as well so
uh but um yeah it's obviously um it was
huge
were you surprised in the opening it
seemed like he played this move B5 and
you you froze for some time yeah I did I
couldn't remember the lines properly
there so
um
from there on I had to kind of invent
things over the world
um any case I think after that
um
it was fair Fairly balanced
um most most of the time
yeah
yeah and uh congratulations on a tough
fight I know this is not the result you
wanted of course but can you
contextualize the struggle that the game
was and your feelings about it
oh yeah well basically I thought like I
should try to play for more than a draw
after the opening because I felt like
okay these two Bishops is nice but uh
are nice but I mean somehow I uh
it's not like maybe 594 instead of 94
would be interesting but it would be
like very very unclear so I mean in
general it was pretty equal game yeah
but uh during the
first time travel I guess uh
uh you know it started to go a little
bit wrong for me and then of course uh
you know this uh Queen E4 was
unnecessary just like playing music's
King H7 and this is like uh very likely
a draw but I mean
um anyway I would say that Magnus
managed to capitalize on very few
chances he got he he got this game so
that's like
uh very nice of him but uh in general uh
I believe even this queen against uh 19
19 rook and two pawns should be a draw
but yeah once you play it basically
Blitz uh it's you know if you don't know
the correct setup as black and uh if you
uh maybe misplace your queen a little
bit it becomes tricky already
can you speak to the level of fatigue
that you feel at the moment after such a
long game
well uh obviously it wasn't the most
Pleasant game but I mean anyway life
goes on so it's not a big deal
Magnus you're you're famously fit but
this definitely tests your endurance
um sure
um
but um I think that's
that's the way it is as I said it
shouldn't be easy in a world
championship match
um you um
you you have to
um to try for every uh every chance no
matter how how small it is
um
and part of it it was uh by Design at
some point that I thought I should
um
I thought I should make the game as long
as possible so that we would both
be as start as possible when the
critical moment moment came and
yeah that turned out to be a good
strategy
I don't want to ask about too many moves
but there was a moment in the game you
played Rook D1 when you could have
played Rook C to C2 which look after you
play Bishop B2 did you see this move uh
as a possible winning chance for you or
you did you think about the moon
sorry was that so I thought Rook D1 you
played Rook C5 he's like Queen D6 you
would work D1 you had worked C2
attacking his bishop and and uh you had
the chance after
play for uh Knight F4 and Rook D7 Etc
was a was a strong attack
not not a four if you take some B4
uh the Queen's on D6 so his Queen's
under attack after Knight F4 yeah so and
then Rook D7
yeah okay uh Rook D7
yeah it could be uh that was not on my
my radar I was trying to play
um no I mean
as a matter of fact when when I uh when
I went for for this uh uh Rook D1 I just
missed Queen D7 uh and then takes I
thought I would be in time to go Rook B4
and and eliminate those pawns so
um that was more an oversight than
anything
anything else
um maybe if I'd seen that that didn't
work I would have
to come for the uh for the other option
but
yeah it was
far far from obvious just to to give up
your whole Queen side like that but yeah
maybe it went I don't know
all right we will go to the questions by
the journalists
please
hello Rakesh from chess.com India your
firstly congratulations from Agnes
you're the first player in recent
history to win a world championship game
over two two days because the game
started yesterday and my question is
this was your 51st game at World
Championship like in a match so how much
of that experience helps in these long
games and wins
um I I feel like
today was more about experience from
from playing long games in general but
uh
yeah I would say um
the game today yeah it had little to do
with um world championship experience or
or pressure I I don't don't particularly
think so
only from chess 24 congratulations to
Magnus who won game six today also
against Vichy uh two times you won game
six and historically in World
Championship matches game six has seen a
high unusually high number of decisive
results is there something about getting
to this point in the match that pushes
these decisive results you think well
that's uh news to me so
um
yeah I think it's pretty random since a
lot of matches have been
have been a lot longer as well and so
it's not about it being a midpoint of
the match
um maybe it's
uh yeah I don't know I think it's pretty
random okay thank you
my climate chess.com my question is
primarily for Magnus but yawn you can
step in if you'd like this game was
almost like its own mini series and the
first episode was that first time
control where you didn't have an
increment what was the mood like inside
the room could you feel a little bit of
extra tension you being in this
situation for the first time Magnus
oh for sure
um but I think that's the way it's
supposed to be
um there should be that other added
element of intrigue with um with the
clock so obviously it's not
it's not entirely pleasant but um yeah I
think it's um
I think it's appropriate
um yeah
Nicholas from afternoon in Norway
um
this was a very long game does it give
you extra pleasure minus two two wins
and after such a long time yes
thank you
short answers I can understand that yeah
um
there was a time Magnus where you were
both like really low on the clock and it
seemed the position still required a lot
of precision
how much were you able to calculate and
how much where you uh did you need to
rely on intuition in a position like
that no
yeah I would say the last few moves
before the time control I was
mainly guessing
um I I mean I I had three minutes left
and then I was hit with a
with a bit of a nasty surprise and that
I hadn't hands in so there was not much
time
how my question is for both the players
one of the most critical moments of the
game was when Yan played Rook C8 and
Magnus took on C8 there was also
possibility to play B4 at that point and
why did you decide to play Rook C8 there
uh and did you think the position that
was a good decision and Max what is your
opinion on that
well Rook C8 was uh I believe a little
bit unnecessary but uh I guess uh black
has a very nice play there so it uh at
some point it became quite chaotic but
uh I guess rookie said it's a nice way
to I don't know to complicate things a
little bit because I don't think black
is taking any serious risk uh yeah but
uh once it came to the time trouble uh
yeah I mean I believe it was in many
ways to improve so clearly European C8
is not uh is not a problem
in this game
um
yeah I was happy to see roxiet in
general as you said before was move
under probably probably others as well I
didn't particularly feel that I was that
I was better
um and Rook C8 gave me at least a Target
I
I felt like we were both risking a bit
um but I thought maybe black was risking
a bit more
and it meant that we would would get a
serious struggle which I was happy with
and in the final position when you had
Rook Knight and two pawns if the table
bases show it's a draw but did you feel
like you would win that Indian
no I thought it was more likely to be a
be a a draw
um
but once I got the Knight to G3 and The
Rook to D5 F5 I got very optimistic
um probably it was still it was still a
draw
um but yeah generally it's it's it's a
draw but uh it's easy to um sort of
beloved into a false sense of security
there as you saw in the game things can
can easily go awry
chess.com again this question for both
players we can start with you on please
uh how much will you review this game
tonight there's so many moves that are
worthy of attention or will you review
it at all
I guess uh me you know it wouldn't take
long
so obviously uh I think uh from both
sides you know play was really far from
Excellence from Excellency but uh yeah
what to do
there will be uh there will be a time
and a place for for that and I don't
think it's today
just two more questions please
wait for Leeches first of all
congratulations on such a grueling win
and thank you both for taking the time
to to be here
um I have a question about uh how how
late this game has ended and in
particular whether you both have a kind
of daily schedule that this late
lateness of game will have impacted such
as you know we will be going to sleep
later today essentially
uh putting you out of a routine
could I please pass you know the first
time or the first answer to Magnus
um yeah uh I think
such a long game
um sort of
messes up everybody's schedule
um but it's um it's why we're here so
it's fine
sure thank you
this question is to Magnus uh I'm Amrita
from chess with India very similar on
his lines that how uh I was very hungry
when your game was going on so how do
you manage this food thing you know for
seven hours you can't have dinner can
you elaborate
yeah I was running on films at the end
so
it's not easy
in lieu of a question from Twitter I'll
ask if there's one last question John
is it just one game or
and how do you bounce back
uh hopefully in style
uh yeah but well uh I mean sometimes you
make mistakes and uh sometimes it's you
know
that's pretty human look here you know
that's a pretty human thing so I don't
think uh you can aim for uh playing
let's say four consecutive games without
winning or losing it's like a part of
the game so let's see
and final question to you Magnus your
experience how significant is a win like
this
um I I mean the match has been
deadlocked so far so any any win that I
can
that I can get is great um but it's it's
far from over
well we are over now and thank the
players and thank you all for your
patience next game game seven will be
tomorrow at 16 30. thank you all and
have a good night
[Applause]
chess.com is here with Grandmaster Yan
nepalmanushi first of all uh you should
be commended as a sportsman for coming
out here and facing the media I do want
to let you know that was the longest
world championship game in history sure
that was no small consolation uh let me
ask you uh what was the moment where you
knew you were going to have to defend
that for many hours we all know Magnus
plays this way but what was the moment
where you knew I have to try to grind
this out
well I think uh
change it a little bit after the first
time control because I mean okay clearly
I was pressing there but yeah somehow
wide I think it's in time to uh get
everything together and uh to secure a
drill but you know into the you know
into this like 39 or 40 it was like this
c5v4 which was probably wrong I think
it's anyway a draw but then uh well I
ended up like playing this
G6 would be an easy draw and like in
many different moments
still you know it would be the same
result but somehow yep I mean what to do
so I guess uh the Final End Game right
like rookie Knight against Queen is
probably also a draw but you would be
very precise but here you basically play
breeds and it's it's difficult to defend
I'm not sure if you know it was move 130
Queen E6 but anyway at hour four or five
I was going to ask you is this your
toughest game ever against Magnus but
now I have to ask you is it your
toughest game of all time that you just
played well not really but what do you
mean 144 Queen E6 after which one after
each one the table bases were okay with
your position until Queen E6
but uh which was like uh what was the
setup uh well you the table bases
preferred Queen B1 but uh there was a
rook on F5 I think you had pinned the
root by playing Queen E6 uh yeah okay so
angelis it was all right yeah no I mean
okay it's very difficult so why to
improve so okay maybe it's still a draw
but you know it's uh it's hard to
understand humanly thanks so much
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be larger oh
[Music]
magic magic
with music with architecture weird
colors magic with celebration with your
safety From Here There and Everywhere
for six homos day and night join the
making of a new world starting October
1st
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes we would discuss it on
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
foreign
lighting and audio
[Music]
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some
insane amount of work so
I hope we we got to be you know
ready enough
thank you
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
we have made history here the longest
game in World Chess Championship history
the first decisive game the first
victory in more than five years and on
that note I should start right at the
top and say the chess kit is free party
all around the world if you are a kid
who's been looking for a website unlock
premium today for the next 24 hours uh
if you're an adult who has any any child
they're looking over niece nephew
children grandchildren check out
chefskid.com and get unlimited access
today all right with that out of the way
it's time for us to do what we normally
do right at the top of the show guys
when the game ends which is the coinbase
rapid recap because today's game was
particularly particularly long and uh
and special we went right to the post
game press conference but we appreciate
all those who've stuck around you're in
for a treat because this is the coinbase
rapid recap here we go
D4 will just give a moment of silence
for the fact that Danny was right about
that you were right not only about that
but about the general opening which was
the Catalan the general opening though I
I don't know that I was uh can fully
take credit for that I anticipated C4
which of course for those following the
match close they could have transposed
us directly into the position we had in
game two but alas that was not meant to
be B3 was played a flexible approach
designed to kind of get things get
things messy a little bit in the move
order and I want to not pause until we
get to this first moment here where C4
was met by the move Queen to C2 which
Robert called for kind of a really
important little little maneuver but an
important idea Robert right the pawn is
pinned to the bishop and that way white
doesn't have to take with the pawn on C4
and compromise the queen Side Pawn
surgery two isolated pawns so and the
follow-up was brilliant after this right
where he says you know you can have my
Pawn I'm playing Knight D2 if you take
on B3 I take with Knight the whole board
opens up and white is ahead in
development yeah and to see all the
variations we got into with Bishop B6
Knight f2d4 you should re-watch the live
broadcast because we did have a lot of
fun and it was instructive in real time
but we will summarize this position as
saying
Beyond was not interested in this played
Knight to C6 but most importantly
followed Knight C6 Bobby with what
Robert called one of the best moves he's
played yet in the world championship
yeah I think that Jan handled the
opening surprise and we can I think
safely say Knight B to D2 was a big
surprise for him yep it's pretty much an
unknown idea it's something that Magnus
and his team team cooked up
but Jan decided not to go for the sharp
lines where he's under pressure he has
material but he's under pressure and he
played an excellent move B5 this eases
Black's development very significantly
because he's developing with gain of
tempo yep the Knight has to move from
the square and there are no there are no
crushing tactics in order here and so
after the Knight C moves to E5 we had
Knight to B4 Queen B2 Bishop B7 and then
we also spent a lot of time debating
between the two Retreats for this night
here and ultimately applauded yawn for
his decision Robert to go for the
slightly more challenging even though it
seems a slightly more Awkward Retreat
right because it creates tension between
the pieces and if the Knight had gone to
D5 instead that's a more advanced square
but it's not threatening anything and
can potentially be kicked out of there
so I like to move Knight to C6 it was a
great choice by Yan and as we saw over
the next series of moves it felt like
black was doing just fine yeah we catch
up again to the live position here and
after Knight C6 Knight D3 keeping the
pieces on the board Bishop B6 Bishop G5
rook d8 and now after Bishop takes F6 we
all we all talked about this moment with
with much anticipation because there
were two choices for Yan he could have
taken with the queen and we should give
credit to the Challenger regardless of
the result of this game that even though
this was probably a safer approach for
him to head toward an endgame that he's
in good shape to hold he played G takes
F6 the more challenging move keeping the
Queens on the board despite what that
did to his kingside Pawn structure yeah
g takes up six was a brave decision I
think in hindsight if we had seen Queen
takes F6 we might have seen a different
result yeah it was a safer option but to
his credit and Jan mentioned this in the
post game press conference yeah that he
felt like he was the one who had chances
to play for an advantage and that's why
he played G takes F6 because clearly
this is an ambitious move yeah keeping
the Queens on basically to say
yeah my king size is a bit weakened but
your queen on B2 is for the moment
extremely misplaced yep and I can try to
play aggressively in the center right
and after Rook to C1 he did play
aggressively instead of with Knight to
D4 although as we commented on there is
a debate that despite G takes F6 being
the more aggressive Dynamic try maybe he
could have kept some pieces on the board
with something like E5 but obviously
very double-edged and risky to go for
something that has positional weaknesses
to it so what kind of what kind of let
that pass and go for the the next
critical position just just to mention
that Jan did say E5 might have been a
better option okay yeah in the president
he did mention this move so maybe that
was one of the moments not a big moment
but one of the moments when he could
have tried to press for more yeah okay
he did not he played Knight to D4
the trade occurred on D4
and after Queen to A2 Bishop takes G2 we
we were still well while we were kind of
sensing Robert that if we got an end
game this night might be the better
minor piece than the bishop this was
still a position that black was in
control over yeah it's something that I
highlighted earlier that the light
Square Knight on D3 protected by a pawn
the bishop can't kick it out the bishop
can't really threaten anything that said
with the Queens on the board the Knight
doesn't have access forward right and
white needs to care about the king so I
think the activity that black has in the
position it's definitely fine for black
but the way Magnus played it it begged
questions out of beyond that resulted in
the material imbalance yeah you start to
see that right away because after the
move Queen to C2 which opens up the
possibilities as you said if the Queens
come off the board you already start to
like white a little bit more and then
after A5 Rook to D1 you're really
preparing to get the Queens off the
board with magnus's next move Rook to D2
this defends the queen it defends the
the E2 Pawn really opens the idea for
this Knight to move ideas like Queen to
C6 for example example that Bishop B6
has played we might have seen a move
like this we spent some time analyzing
that
and and did that Force John's hand was
this not something he wanted to go for
we saw both players asked about it and
Jan said he thought Rook to C8 was okay
Magnus said he thought it was okay but
that it was more okay for white
I I think that this was the first huge
decision and Jan to his credit took a
very brave one yeah he imbalanced the
position before this move it is very
roughly balanced and black I think has a
number of moves which Keep It In Balance
I think I heard mention of the move B4
in the press conference and maybe this
was a very a concrete way of trying to
simplify everything because it was a
bishop gets to C3 black is doing very
well and if white takes on B4 Queen
takes C2 Rook takes C2
or maybe you should have to check right
oh Bishop takes up two check in fact
this is the first idea and black takes
on B4 and then you take and equalizes
completely maybe even more than
equalizes so this is probably one of the
only lines we actually didn't look at in
live fashion this maybe is what black
should have done
so Jan decided maybe against this or
maybe he didn't spot it but Rook CA was
a brave decision perhaps one which in
hindsight he may regret slightly
yeah and Rook to Seattle was mentioned
by ifan of course Hobie Fawn joins us
daily if you're not tuning in for that
that's a you problem uh but it doesn't
mean that it wasn't without great risk
we we now had the imbalance that is
going to set the tone for the rest of
this coinbase rapid recap because it was
very instructive and dynamic to see how
the two Rooks and queen battled it out
but again in hindsight maybe maybe now
we agree with Magnus that white was the
one with better chances and I agree with
that from the beginning as soon as we
got to this position and we just see the
next one Queen D5 and b4a4 now we have a
set Pawn structure on the queen side the
pawn and A3 is vulnerable because that's
a dark Square Bishop at some point
Bishop B2 also the queen come into B3
but what I was advocating for was Rook
C8 back to C2 and we know that later in
the game that was even more powerful for
white but the point that I was making is
that black actually can't threaten
anything and if white gets several turns
to protect A3 maybe bring that Knight
forward into C5 in many of these
positions two Rooks are better than a
queen because two Rooks can team up on a
square and a queen is a lone piece it's
very valuable but it doesn't have the
benefit of joining forces with another
because not enough material remaining
for black and another idea you
highlighted and Fabi of course was right
there with you is and we're going to see
lots of variations uh uh that display
that Black's long-term weaknesses on the
king's side even if they're not an issue
in five moves and 10 moves and 15 moves
they will be an issue at some point it's
only a matter of time for white to
coordinate and defend the threats as you
said on the queen side and that's kind
of what we saw here E3 was played Bishop
E5 and then H4 H5 was a quick response
and after King H2
a slightly curious Bishop B2 really
forced us into variations where Magnus
he actually missed his first opportunity
to maybe put the game away and uh that
was actually with the move Rook to C5
followed by Rook five to C2 Bishop B2
was uh a very serious mistake but not
one which was obvious and I don't think
that well we we heard from Magnus that
he didn't see this idea after Bishop to
B2 yeah I think maybe John spotted it
only after he played Bishop to B2 but we
we mentioned during the game that Queen
to B3 would probably lead to a draw but
it's a difficult decision for black as
well because he allows the invasion of
the Rooks Knight takes E5 F takes E5
Rook C7 oh yeah
Queen takes A3
Rook 2 to D7 Queen takes B4 Rook F7 it's
very very close to being a mating attack
but after King to G6 Rook to G7 King to
H6 we could not find any way for white
to continue the attack besides to go for
a Perpetual but it's very understandable
that Jan didn't want to go for this
where white has a safety net of a draw
and it's also difficult to be completely
sure that white doesn't have more and on
top of that the sort of winning strategy
that white had was like eight moves down
the line and included some sacrifices so
uh if we go to The Rook C5 Rook C2
moment that was actually playing the
game yeah that was here not played yeah
right Rook C2 is what we're looking at
there are all these variations which we
did analyze a bishop takes A3 we talked
about Knights F4 Queen takes B4 and here
after Rook D7 E5 we actually were
struggling to figure it out but after
Knight H5 check King G6 I believe to
move Rook C6 you're giving up your
knight on H5 and you're creating a
mating net which doesn't look immediate
but the king is in trouble and look at
Black's pieces the queen on B4 the
bishop 183 not helping to save that King
and that's really hard to spot from so
many moves away so the criticism when
you have the engine evaluation with you
I know we were talking about Rook C2 we
didn't see it all the way through but we
like the dynamic chances but look at how
difficult that variation was in magnus's
immense time trouble yeah that would say
that even if you spot this if you even
if you calculate all the way through and
Magnus only at three minutes to do so it
still doesn't seem clear because let's
say you win
the queen for one of White's Rooks black
still has two connected past pawns on
the queen side even there you're not 100
sure that you can stop those pawns or
Advance your Pawns in time so this was
immensely difficult
but it was a big chance anyway for
Magnus
yeah well said and uh This Moment
instead of the move Rook to C2
was was met with Rook to D1 which as you
can see again ignoring the evil bar
knowing how difficult this was
especially given the time pressure the
players had set us down a new a new time
scramble where suddenly we were talking
about maybe this was going to be a game
for the Challenger he captured the a
pawn
and is now going to win the bee Pawn by
force or so we thought after the move E5
Rook C2 this was in hindsight maybe the
last the last real opportunity that
Janda Palmer she had yeah Bishop takes
B4 we're screaming for that move and
it's begging to be played
um in this position because the Knight
is pinned to the rook and now black can
safely Retreat the bishop try to put the
pawn in A3 and it's a much better
version of the game because instead of
taking on B4 what ended up happening is
that Jan lost his e-pawn and that left
him with such a horrible Pawn structure
in the resulting position that even
though the evaluation its remain level
his task is so much harder because all
of these different end games even if
white gives away some material the
contracts are so bad that a rook in the
Knight can dominate against the queen
foreshadowing you are for those who
might be watching this coinbase rapid
recap on our YouTube channel in terms of
what's ahead all right uh again Napoleon
she did not capture on B4 he played the
surprising Queen D5 and after Rook dd2
which credit to Magnus he found this
move in no time and a very difficult and
subtle book coming forward but as you
said in hindsight kind of the only move
and suddenly you realize this bishop is
trapped unless you're going to get rid
of the Knight but getting rid of the
Knight requires you making a weakness
with the E4 Pawn advance and suddenly
everything is changing I think we should
mention E4 was probably a very big
mistake okay it was understandable that
Jan didn't want to go for Bishop takes
before Rook D to B2 Queen takes D3 Rook
text B4 where white wins the A4 pawn and
can only play for two results it's
difficult to foresee if white can
actually make progress here but I don't
believe white can and if he were to go
for this I don't think his defensive
task would be too difficult because once
you get here black
really has doesn't have too many more
difficult moves left black simply has to
keep an eye on the F2 part so that
White's Rooks can't get too active
if he had done this I think that we
would likely have seen a defense by by
on
and it was moved I believe 38. I was
just about to say he was also in
retirement he was and you're entering a
point of no return because once you get
here and we sell those trades then it's
either you're holding which doesn't
initially look like it because your Pawn
structure is bad yeah the Rooks can team
up but it does in fact appear that you
end up holding right so with the
analysis was in calculation he didn't
have enough time to calculate all the
weight there's an E4 was an
understandable mistake from Yan but it
put him in some tremendous pressure and
that resulted through the rest of the
game yep E4 Knight to C5 Queen takes B4
and we spent a lot of time analyzing
another maybe fun opportunity Magnus had
which was the surprising Rook d2c2 where
despite what it looks like At first
blacks pieces are actually Frozen in in
place and with without any any ability
to to move out we're going to get
variations where let's say the pawn is
protected with F5 white is able to rid
the queen side completely
of Pawns and we spend a lot of time
analyzing that this end game unlike what
the pawns on E5 and F6 which do prevent
the Rooks from being ideally coordinated
is probably winning for white again a
very very difficult end game um but
back up and watch the show in real time
to see Fabiano's full full breakdown uh
okay Fabiano's full breakdown that
sounds like a hopefully not a full
breakdown a little bit of a full
breakdown uh Magnus didn't play Rook dc2
he took on e4 uh and after Queen to B3
Rook a to C2 we start to get into this
struggle here where okay we were
definitely considering the fact that
it's now a two result position for white
but skeptical of how that was going to
happen until
one later critical moment go ahead
Robert yeah I actually had mentioned
this because I was looking at the weak
Pawn structure yeah and thinking that
white could give up a rook for the
bishop and a pawn something I mentioned
during the commentary and something you
need to keep in mind that just because
you a rook is more valuable you want to
keep a rook compared to fisherman Pawn
the resulting position leaves black no
active play so by eliminating that pawn
and it was a big mistake on Jan's part
coming up he allowed that pawn to be
eliminated and then he was really in
trouble yeah and we you could already
foreshadow if you just imagine the
bishop and Pawn off the board for either
of these Rooks you realize just how
perfect and solid white structure is and
how difficult it will be for black to
defend so uh the the Maneuvers that
continued were were kind of logical and
clear until we reached one critical
moment which really in the end may have
been the critical moment because it
surprised all of us in the in that Jan
I used the word at the time during the
live show careless maybe that was harsh
it just felt a little bit uh
short-sighted in the potential that
white had here with the mistake that was
made I think this is certainly a
careless mistake and by with magnus's
last move King to G1 King G1 to H2
he showed that predicting a draw almost
I was already predicting a quick draw
because it seemed like they were both
shuffling their Kings King G1 to H2
doesn't prepare anything in fact the
only idea of it is to provoke Queen E4
because suddenly the king is in the line
of that Bishop there's a pit on a G3
Pawn so he's in a way asking why don't
you give Queen E4 a shot
King King H2 the king can't go anywhere
so if black were to play King G6 here
King G7 a move like that I don't believe
white has anything better than to keep
shuffling
uh I I'm curious to see well we will
never see but I'm I would have been
curious to see what Magnus would have
done if Jan kept shuffling maybe we
would have seen a draw maybe Magnus had
some idea in mind but it's not very
clear what that is well as you said King
H2 provokes the idea that the G Pawn is
pinned and apparently that was all that
was all the provoking that John needed
because he played Queen E4 and magnus's
trap had been laid he now takes on A3
allowing the queen to take H4 and then
with the great follow-up King G1 and you
suddenly realized the pawn can't really
be taken by the bishop because white
will capture back and eventually get out
of checks and that changes everything
we're suddenly in a dynamic where the a
pawn is gone and you didn't even have to
lose your Rook because of it we get a
we're going to get a lot more moves now
where essentially white spends the next
15 or so moves coordinating the two
Brooks in the night to be in their best
possible position to eventually make way
over here against the weak King side
structure a 92 the pieces maneuver
Queen E4 check F3 definitely turned a
little bit of our heads right Robert
well I was wondering why he was thinking
so I figured he was going to play the
move F3 and I guess he thought that he
couldn't win without making that move
because there's so many times where
black tries to move the pawn to H4 if
the king's ever on H2 you you need to
leave the H file with your king before
playing H4 as black but that was the
problem that he foresaw so he ends up
playing F3 and that gave him more time
to maneuver around and eventually it led
him into a very promising position F3
was followed by F4 and we suddenly saw
another reason why F3 was playable
because surprisingly you don't even have
to keep the pawn there once you dislodge
the bishop these pawns can't be
protected which means the Fortress is uh
is starting to show show some holes
again White's pieces coordinate
incredibly well over the over the coming
series of moves we we should highlight
that F5 was a move we were talking about
as an eventual requirement as risky as
it was to put pawns on these weak
squares because you have to prevent
white from making progress here
yeah all of these moves that Magnus made
yeah they don't differ so much from
other moves in terms of evaluation but
the thing that he did which was amazing
was that he kept the position tense and
full of life
he didn't allow it to simplify for a
long time until they were both low on
time right and he he realized that
although the evaluation or the the
objective evaluation is probably close
to equal or simply equal it with perfect
play Black is the one who has to make
the more difficult decisions here right
and already here we were starting to see
even even two moves before so we were
starting to see that black was getting
in trouble with this F5 Pawn which is
which is very difficult to defend long
term because the bishop can't ever
defend it and it can be attacked by two
Rooks but only defended by one Queen
but and as soon as white had the
opportunity the pawns it did start to
fall now John his credit was tenacious
and and would not go away Queen to D3
now forces an even more more forcing
idea which if you I would love to say if
you wanted to pause the video and see
the the transition Magnus made it's it's
certainly an educational one not to
mirror yourself for the type of
Advantage you have but just mirror
yourself to the idea of winning and
Robert he sacrificed an F7 a tactic you
saw coming and and uh with this you win
a a bishop and pawn for The Rook but
really put white in a position where
there was there was no longer doubt that
white was the only one who could win and
that it would be very difficult for
black to hold yeah there's a practical
problem earlier with the pawn E3 yeah
bishop and the queen were lined up at
that point the white Rooks could not
actually defend because the looseness of
the other Rook so here he goes for this
he says I have a rook a knight in two
pawns and I can play this game out I'll
make a pawn move when I have to but he
was in no rush and Magnus showed great
technique in rerouting his pieces keep
asking Yan questions like where's your
queen going to go what's the best Square
can you stop my paw from going to E4 is
that devastating Jan actually was
playing very well here and there's only
much later in the game after tons and
tons of shuffling that Jan eventually
made an error but that's because he was
exhausted it was near midnight in Dubai
and Magnus was relentless in the
pressure he put on yeah one of the
educational things uh speaking of a
Relentless approach by Magnus is how the
night maneuvered consistently putting
itself in a spot both of you highlighted
a couple times that your your former
childhood coach talks about the knights
being Knight being such a key Defender
to the king how a knight can dominate a
queen in close proximity that's a theme
that not only paid dividends here but
ultimately helped him convert on the
advantage at the end of the game we see
keeping the Knight close to the king
allows you to have security and allows
you to maneuver and eventually allowed
Magnus to push his Advantage as soon as
he could with these pawns getting
rolling up the board this was move 110
and as soon as he played it we knew that
we weren't going to have a repetition a
threefold repetition we wouldn't have a
15 move draw and that we would more than
likely be making history today with the
longest ever World Chess Championship
game in history uh which of course was
the previous record of 124 moves between
Cortino and karpov in 1978 but this game
was on Pace to break that and uh break
that it did I think that this whole end
game was Magnus Magnus at his best yep
even though it looked like he was moving
in circles for a long time
he always kept control of a position
and he always slowly made progress he
knew that he had time black has no
counter play so he played with absolute
patience and with every move we felt
white is making progress even though the
objective evaluation in this position
and in most of these positions was a
draw it felt harder and harder for Yan
to to keep defending it until at some
point it was just too difficult to uh to
handle we're going to get to that point
here in just a second because as Fabiano
uh and Hester was saying you just was a
difficult battle and in fact it was
right here this was the moment and I'll
let you take it away Robin and explain
why the table base says black should
draw this but why that is a completely
unfair standard to hold any human to
yeah it's pretty hard to hold them Queen
E6 against Yan because you're putting
the rook in a pin and you're bringing
the queen to a place where he can
deliver some more checks the problem is
Knights are amazing at defending Kings
against Queens because they cover so
many of the important squares while
blocking the file that the queen is on
so Queen C2 or Queen B1 those are
necessary choices for Giannis but the
only two moves that objectively hold the
game because the Knight needs to remain
protecting The Rook of course it also
leaves many checks open so if the king
tries to run up the board too quickly
there are more checks um to go you can
pin the Knight of course like this and
so white isn't able to just run forward
and in the game after Queen E6 we saw a
very quick conclusion here because up
goes the white king you get one more
check on H6 and look at the Knight on H5
even if you're a rook or not an F5 the
Knight covers F4 it covers F6 and it
blocks to check on the file that it's on
which means that the queen is just
buried by that one Knight and then we
saw a really beautiful move next where
Magnus was able to push his e-pawn
because the Rook on F5 not attacked
Knight G7 check is a winning fork and
after E6 was played the rest as they say
was history yep young played a couple
more moves with Queen G6 and then Rook
F7 again showing the line that Queen E6
does not work because this end game
although it makes black feel a little
better maybe but we don't they don't
they don't play for almost ease and
feeling good this is still a lost end
game if you know your kingdom Pawn
endings white goes on to win easily and
so with that not being an option for the
Russian he well he he ran the king away
or tried to but after F5
Queen G1 and Knight G7 we did indeed
finally have a resignation with again
just a brilliant display there of how
pieces can outplay the queen together
how perseverance and and pushing hard
especially the Practical nature of using
the clock as a weapon objectively this
game was a draw for many many moves yet
it feels in hindsight that the result
for Magnus was never in doubt
yeah this was a game that was marred at
the start by some serious errors
to be to be fair very understandable
errors because it was such a complicated
position and they were low on time but
uh the end of the game or the end of the
game was quite long the last
50 moves or so was just absolutely
brilliant technique for Magnus uh very
tenacious defense as well but Magnus
didn't
never let up on the pressure and when
you never let up on the pressure at some
point your opponent cracks and that's
exactly what happened
those are going to be our final thoughts
right there and that is How the West Was
Won as they say Magnus Carlson takes
home the cake today not his birthday but
I'm sure he'll he'll take the dub just a
few days late we gave him a w in his
birthday basket here on our show just a
couple days ago but uh you know better
late than never and again
congratulations to the world champion
for taking taking a lead will it prove
to be a commanding lead and critical
time will tell obviously the Challenger
gets the white pieces in tomorrow's game
but we're gonna we're gonna continue our
show here don't go anywhere of course we
have more guests joining us right now
we'll remind you that we're about to be
joined uh by Vladimir ferrosev the big
fish 1995 is our next guest uh we'll
talk to him quickly about what happened
today and maybe have some fun with him
about the times he's thrown down against
Magnus Carlson we also have young
Lubbock Hammer cannot wait to hear what
Hammer has to say about the buzz in
Norway after today's incredible game uh
we will actually not be joined by Ludwig
anymore because he's at Universal
Studios right now having a good time
apparently there's some copyright strike
or something I don't know but he'll
he'll be he'll be joining us tomorrow we
think uh but anyway don't go anywhere
just.com's post game coverage of game
six this historical historical day
continues when we return
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
lighting and audio
[Music]
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
foreign
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
we are now joined by a special guest
from a special location uh Vladimir
where are you at right now
thank you
uh I'm an emotional Center we have a
late dinner uh here and Justin cake and
the cheer this game was incredibly
longer I was just it was just hard to
to think where to go for me uh during
this game I expected to finish
uh really early on but it doesn't happen
and now I am still in the Moscow Center
and it's possible there to enjoy cake
and tea
um thanks for joining us to remind
everybody our our guests are brought To
Us by grip six we'll remind you about
that in a second but let me uh just ask
you Vlad
obviously maybe today's result not the
one that uh fans and Friends of yonda
Palm machine and Russia were rooting for
but uh what are your thoughts on on what
this what this game means for his
overall chances as the Challenger in the
match
foreign
but uh
but I can say that this game was so hard
it's just really hard to evaluate all
the time and he misses some chances
zeros to play for events
maybe it's a count and as a
two points for Magnus because he can
simply lose this game somewhere
at least I feel like this
he had three minutes against 19 in the
first Islands on move chochiban and it's
so hard to manage such positions
and make nine moves more and he could
simply be in flagging today so it was a
good chance for Jan to score and then
it's
after move
forward it's evaluated invites fire and
then
it was play play play play play and play
and uh
in the church in the church side months
uh Magnus finally was able to score him
in position which
I believe according to luminos of
databases just a draw
uh these positions yeah it's seven
pieces songs about so it's I'm currently
person's insurance in luminous of
database and they can simply check this
position
yeah yeah but but it's so hard to play
this black it's so depressed and good
word I say really tough yeah it's
depression feel the top defense well
you know I know it's late it's late for
you it's a long day for everyone I don't
I don't have a lot more questions I I
would say you know what it's like to
play Magnus he's a very tough cookie you
played him in the defide World Cup uh in
the uh I think it was the quarterfinals
maybe the sweet 16 but
um
what what are your uh what What's your
advice for uh for for team young going
forward
I think we might have lost him
did we lose Vlad
no
I have no idea what's going on
um
go me bye bye okay
um we're gonna take a quick break and we
come back we'll continue our post show
don't go anywhere everybody
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chest.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
um
when we prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
shout out to everyone with us and shout
out to our next guest who is brought to
you by grip six remember you can go to
grip6.com using the promo code chess you
can get 25 off
that that's a pretty decent that's a
pretty decent discount and we're joined
daily by a pretty decent guest all the
way from Norway it's late for you Hammer
but I'll tuck you into bed after the
interview I promise let us know your
thoughts on uh on this historic
absolutely historic day in the feed day
World Chess Championship
well what a game it's we don't have
enough time to talk about all of it I
will note this that when Magnus was
really low on time around move 30 after
Yan had given away two of his Rooks in
exchange for magnus's Queen We were
quiet nervous we were looking for ways
for Magnus to equalize the game and to
salvage the draw we were not expecting
him to go for the win being low on time
and facing some quite serious threats to
the queen side pawns but boy did he
prove us wrong and he went for it time
to scramble or not and he almost could
have won it then and there he almost
could have lost it then and there but it
was one of the most uh yeah dramatic
games
just to see what it looks like to watch
a 136 a record-setting world
championship move play in the background
of Hammer's interview so I'll let Robert
ask the next question but yeah uh you
you described the the tense moments well
yeah it was a very topsy-turvy game
especially at that point so hammer I
guess the question views how seriously
did you and the rest of Norway think
that Magnus might lose that game because
it was very dangerous around the time
Patrol when he was living on his final
few minutes
I think it's impossible not to be
nervous but at the same time you know we
have the computer engines helping us
they were saying you know it's not great
but there's not a clear win for uh for
black either and two people I mean this
game lasted almost eight hours and that
moment when we were nervous lasted for
what 10 minutes so in in the grand
scheme of things we were way more
optimistic about magnus's chances than
we were pessimistic it was like limited
to a very short time spent where to be
fair in that time span we had no idea
what was going on but we we didn't have
to worry as soon as he had the
opportunity he went back to his room I'm
sure he relaxed for a few minutes after
the post game press conference Magnus
Carlson the world champion tweeted in
all capital letters yes and and as if he
doesn't need to say anything else now
that the monkey he is off his back now
that he has won a game in the world
championship classical portion for the
first time in five years just say a
little bit about what you think this
means to him to show uh that uh that he
is he is capable of getting it done in
the classical portion and not needing a
rapid tiebreaker
let me give you this stock the last time
Magnus had the lead in a world
championship match was in 2014. uh and
in that match he did not need the full
12 games to decide the title the one the
time before that when he had the lead
was in 2013 and that time as well he did
not need the full length of the match to
decide it in his favor uh I think when
Magnus already makes his breakthrough
um he's just the the momentum and also
like the the responsibility and pressure
it puts on his opponent to actually take
quite a few risks which Magnus is just a
master at exploiting
um I don't think nepalnya she's coming
back from this and I don't think he's
going to be able to make the match last
14 games I I think Magnus has a track
record of when he gets the lead uh it
just it the psychology of the match
changes and
um and he he knows how to explain it for
sure and one of the things that I think
will be a story about heading into Mars
both players must be absolutely
exhausted Beyond exhausted they played
past midnight in Dubai and you know
historically would say if any player can
rebound it's Magnus Carlson he keeps in
pretty Peak Physical shape but what do
you think this leaves him tomorrow
because yes the onus is on yonda palmchi
who gets the white pieces and we have
seen Jan secure advantages with the
white side against the Marshall in the
Royal Lopez so what do you see for
tomorrow's game and how do you settle
the nerves if you're both Magnus and Yon
well I I think Jan has been going into
this with a strategy uh that he's happy
to get these kind of slow grinds uh in
the real Lopez that he's been going for
personally I I came on this show and
told you guys I thought it wasn't direct
enough I I I said I I thought it was the
wrong strategy but I changed my mind I
think the previous game uh when when Jan
had the white pieces he was very close
to generating something and he's so well
prepared he's putting pressure on Magnus
in positions that look like it's nothing
and then he comes in and and like he has
slightly better placed pieces and and
he's very close to uh to getting some
some very solid advantages through that
play which is a surprise because that's
a very magnus-esque player uh way of
playing where whereas napometri has been
primarily known for his well a pretty
blunt attacking uh play uh so um I I
think he has a strategy of playing slow
I think it's been working for him and I
think he should not change it because if
he starts getting desperate just because
he lost the game then did he really
believe in his match strategy to begin
with do you go into a world championship
match against Magnus and think well
there's no way I'm gonna lose the first
game right no you don't think that but
you you choose the strategy that gives
you the best hope of of winning games
and uh Jan has been putting pressure on
Magnus I think Magnus has defended
brilliantly with the black pieces but I
I think
how brilliantly Magnus has been
defending with black has kind of
disguised how much pressure Jan has
actually put
uh and and so I'm expecting more of the
same uh and and just for yawn it's just
try to to act like it's business as
usual and don't let the the game losing
one game affect your your match strategy
at this point because um if you win one
then it's all tied and then you have to
say everyone has a strategy everyone has
a plan until they get hit right so I I I
heed your words and hear them well and I
agree with you although I am very
curious to see uh what happens in the
coming games with the will this will
this be a rebound yeah go ahead yeah no
I I
yeah I I if you I I I think this is
getting the lead is what Magnus needs to
to win the match uh but I would have
said the same thing against Fabiano
right Magnus was very close to winning
the very first game of the match against
Fabiano and if he had succeeded in
converting that position I think it
could have been to blow uh a blowout
um so Magnus taking the lead in matches
is just such a terrifying thought uh
that uh uh he hasn't managed to do that
against kayaking and against Fabiano
it's been seven years since Magnus had
the lead uh in a world championship
match but seven years ago and eight
years ago uh that the lead was was
enough what is that what does that do
some serious damage I mean for us the
last time Magnus Carlson had a lead in
the World Chess Championship Obama was
President
Tick Tock was not a thing what are some
other fun things
it's been a while that's the point and
uh
Danny was still uh the best chess
commentator I'm gonna I'm gonna take
that in stride if that was if that was
ever the case I'll take it as a
compliment but uh I will I will bow down
to you Hess and many others at this
point thanks for everything that you're
doing Hammer I I don't have any other
questions besides uh
you know are you going right to bed
after this or are you celebrating as a
Norwegian watching your boy get it done
wow there's a new game tomorrow Danny
it's uh it's a tough life being a chess
commentator
we are first though we are also ready
for some dinner and maybe uh maybe some
rest because there is another game
tomorrow as they say all right Hammer
thank you so much man we appreciate it
as always bringing it and we'll we will
see you manana
bye bye all right there there he is yeah
the uh
the heat from Hammer he held nothing
back he held nothing back he just said
this match is over yeah he didn't mince
words yeah he said now that Magnus
Carlsen has the lead it's done and I
think a lot of people have felt that way
in previous matches as well and Hammer
said the same but yonda Palm Nashi what
Hammer did say is that he likes the
style that Jana's playing right now but
at some point he needs to win yep
because Magnus will be happy to draw the
rest of the games and that means when
Jan has the white pieces he needs to
find something to cause Magnus some real
problems in game five we saw that happen
if you played C4 Magnus expresses
discomfort
but will he go back to this style that
made him yawn to Palm Tree to begin with
yeah will he be the type of player who
loves those topsy-turvy battles where he
may find a sacrifice at any moment and
is one of the best calculators in the
world right so I'm not sure when that
moment is it's still relatively early in
the match but I do think that
janapamnashi he might need to take up a
more aggressive approach yeah we we yeah
we dog with this while I don't totally
agree with hammer and would say the
match is over we do all agree that
Magnus Carlson leading a match that's
not no one wants to be trailing against
Magnus Carlson and certainly there's a
lot of questions that uh that we will
find out starting tomorrow once again
thank you to grip six for bringing us
our guests every day again you get 25
off all you got to do is use a promo
code that's pretty cool wearing their
belt right now so to speak uh I I don't
have their socks on today but I do have
many many pairs at home so shout out to
grip six all right we're going to take a
quick break coming up is the answer to
the trivia question if you're playing
along with us one of you has already won
a diamond a one year Diamond membership
today all you had to do was quote tweet
the answer uh after that we have an
interview with Colin Byrne who is an
artist Alchemist who uh created the most
valuable chess set ever uh and uh much
more ahead don't go anywhere chess.com's
continued post game coverage of game six
of the 2021 v-day World Chess
Championship return in a moment
[Music]
hi Jonathan corable here from Expo 2020
in Dubai with another trivia question
about World Chess championships
during his match with capablanca
Alexander Al yankin switched his
citizenship to France now despite having
a rich history in chess
there has only been one world
championship that took place on French
soil name that match
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes we would discuss it on
[Music]
the first game of the 2021 video World
Championship in one minute
foreign
lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
foreign
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
back again with the answer to our trivia
question what was the only match for the
World Chess Championship that took place
on French soil well Kasparov karpov 1990
and that took place in Lyon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first game of
we are back here chess.com's coverage of
the 2021 video World Chess Championship
rolls on and we are now joined by The
Jewelry Artist Colin Byrne Colin you are
also referred to as an alchemist so I
have to start right at the top what
defines modern day Alchemy and what
exactly is an alchemist
well let's feel the chemistry of
combining Metals really
um for me I use a lot of in my eye to
use a lot of work
electrochemistry and and the combining
of metals using that particular craft so
it's a little different to the
traditional casting but I do do casting
as well okay wow well it's in art form I
know little about but maybe by the end
of this interview I'll know uh more
about it I I will point out the obvious
to uh the fans if you've been watching
from the beginning of today's show you
already saw Fabiano caruana and Robert
Hess make moves on the chessboard as we
predicted the first move of Magnus
Carlsen today and and this chess set
that's right in front of me Colin is is
the most valuable chess set ever created
ever known to the universe and I am I
right in saying that the value of this
chess set comes in at just over 4
million US dollars is that right
it does come in at 4 million US dollars
a lot of value in the chess set but
there's a lot of things that make it
very valuable yeah well obviously I can
I can I can say that and um having
already looked at it we'll get into the
detail and it is it is an amazing piece
of art uh but this is a chess show and
you made a chess set so we have to start
right there and ask what got you into
chess who taught you the game how long
have you been playing and take us
through the start of your chess Journey
uh but really as a child I love playing
chess with my cousins and my friends you
know probably around about the age of
six or seven I guess when I first was
introduced to chess
um and my parents bought me a beautiful
storm and chess set and I never forgot
that and um yeah I grew up in the 60s
and 70s and and you know there was no
internet around so we played games you
know we play with toy soldiers and we
played you know all the typical board
games but chess was one that I really
loved as a kid
um yeah absolutely a great test player I
mean I'm in awe when I see what you guys
are doing here with the World Chess
championships let's just play me away
um but yeah so my history with chess
really just through my childhood and
growing up
my friends
that's amazing well I'm not the greatest
chess player either with the company
that I keep so don't worry about that
surrounded by Fabiano and Robert hess uh
but that doesn't matter because we all
have fond memories of Chess and we all
enjoy the game and let me ask you what
is your so you play as a childhood share
with us what's up what's one of your
Fondest Memories of Chess and what do
you enjoy about the game of chefs
what do I probably love about it most is
the unity of it like it brings people
together
um you know and through like looking
back on it now um as a child it was just
fun you know we we all just got together
and played our games listen but as I
look deeper into it now as an artist and
artists I I've sort of had a better
appreciation for what chess does and how
it brings together people from all over
the planet
so we're here watching this world
championship you know every every all
the eyes from all over the world are
here watching chess and I think that in
itself is the most amazing
I love that and that's exactly one of
the things we love most about what we do
at just.com so I love that just bringing
people together and and couldn't agree
more well let let's talk about so
I want to ask you what went into
building this and I'm sure it was it was
crazy and amazing and very difficult but
what what inspired you you're a Jewelry
Artist right you're an alchemist what
inspired you to bring your skills to
making a chess set and what were some of
the goals you had in making it for for
the chess community so tell us what
inspired you to do this and what were
some of the things you really wanted to
make sure you did in creating such an
amazing and beautiful chess set
you know I suppose it really has started
it was 2007 when I first put pen to
paper um but it come from an idea I was
making another piece of jewelry that
looked a little chess-like it's like
looked like a pawn this particular
jewelry piece that I was making
and and then I was working in a town
called Broome which is um the purling
capital of the world so there's a lot of
beautiful South Sea pearls come from
that part of the world
so all these Inspirations were coming to
me and I created this piece I thought
this really should do a chess set
because I had these fond memories of
Chess
um so that's kind of where it really
started and I never set out to make the
most expensive chess set in the world
that wasn't my goal my goal was
potentially to make the most beautiful
so it's it's been a long journey and it
started with looking at chess and what
chess meant to me
um and how it you know the whole idea of
that unity and everything and and I
thought well if I'm going to do this I
have to start with
the Staunton chess set because that was
my memory as a child being given one and
how these pieces that we all know all
over the world they're the sanded the
that is used so I wanted to keep my
chest set very much within that standard
but I wanted to bring it to life yeah so
that's sort of how it all started for me
I'll say you achieve that's amazing I
mean I as someone who's seen a lot of uh
chess boards and chest sets that are
that are meant to be are artistic uh in
nature or you know to sit on a dinner
table or a fancy table that you don't
touch or look at not exactly the type of
chest that they use every every day but
I've seen many of them uh but for a lot
of them are are kind of all over the map
right the you know the pieces look weird
and different they're designed to make
big statements this chess set is
beautiful and the detail is is literally
I mean it's it's ridiculous as I'm as
I'm holding this Pawn that I hope I
don't drop because I have no idea how
valuable that the pawn actually is or
the night it it is a real chess set I
mean it looks exactly like the type of
chess set you could play you could play
maybe a fast game with maybe not too
fast uh you wouldn't want to drop one of
the pieces so you said that was your
goal right you really wanted this to to
be something that a chess player uh
would look at and and and really
appreciate
yeah I felt that if I if I'm going to go
into this territory I have to honor the
game of chess and and but and and the
people that play chess um in the chess
community so so really in in making the
chess set I was fixated on this idea of
the Staunton
um design and from 1849 I thought
there's been other other artists that
have created you know dragons and
wizards and all different types of
cartoon style
um yeah I didn't want to do that I
wanted to be a traditionalist with this
and I wanted to make sure that in my own
artistic way I could build off the
building blocks of Chess and create
something that would be appreciated by
chess lovers
um so I stuck with the original store
and concept but then the elements I
added I I used black and white South Sea
pearls so that we've got either side of
the board um depicted by the pearls and
then I thought well these could be the
heads of each piece and that could bring
life
particularly the king and the queen
so these are the building blocks and my
son my oldest son was a pearl diver very
dangerous job you know they're 20 30
meters under the ocean diving for pearls
so I had all this really intense
inspiration and working with these
beautiful gems the pearls and the
Diamonds so and you know wanting to on a
chest so that's that's sort of how it
really started to build
well it it definitely it definitely uh
the pearls and and the choice of the the
black pearls and the white pearls it's
it's really amazing and uh just
beautiful let me let me ask
is this going to be the only one of its
kind ever are you planning to do more of
of these types of chess sets or were you
inspired to do any other type of Chess
art
that one I've actually made a limited
edition of three so there's three and
three in the Edition
um as an art Edition each piece is
individually numbered um the piece you
have there is actually my set that's uh
what I call the artist proof so my
original set and then there'll be three
editions so um you know if people are
inspired to like the art and want to
want to purchase it there are there
three editions available
um yeah so it's it took a long time I
think it was 2007. so 2007 was when you
started right so it took it took 14
years
yeah and then um 2018 is when we start I
actually started then casting the gold
and setting the stones and and that was
a journey in itself like just from 2007
to a lot of jury projects in the middle
of all of that I wasn't sitting idle
um but it was always at the back of my
mind you know um I've been in jury for
about 40 years
and it was time in my life I thought you
know stop making just you know
conventional jury and really focus on
the art which is the part of jewelry
making I love
and the chess set was the highest on my
priority so we we really
um you know I assembled a small team of
the best Setters in the world for the
diamonds because there's 20 000 diamonds
in it and
it's a lot of settings so and everyone
is going to be fit beautifully so
so it was quite the project yeah and and
uh it turned out it turned out amazing
so much so many years of work how much
how much does it mean to you to have
completed it today Fabiano caruana made
made the first move on the chessboard
how much does that mean to you
and you got no idea it's it's just such
an unbelievable feeling
um you know like my dream when I when I
first conceived this in 2007 as I was
developing it
the dream that I had was to create the
most beautiful chess set in the world
and to have the finest players in the
world play on it so to have Fabiano play
on that board it's just phenomenal like
if you've got no idea how that feels to
me it's it's amazing very honored
well yeah it's uh I'm glad I'm glad he
didn't break anything or you know drop
any pieces because Fabiana can be a
little clumsy I'll tell you okay well
I'm good to know because when I was uh
when I was holding the pieces earlier
today I was like wow this is incredible
and I was I was afraid I was afraid I
was gonna I was gonna drop it luckily
nothing bad happened well uh Colin tell
everybody where they can go to find out
uh more you said there's there's a few
more Megan this is your personal set and
tell everybody where they can go to find
out more about the artwork not just this
set and the others you're making but the
the artwork you're doing uh in chess
yeah well uh the artwork I'm doing it
chess I've I've got this particular
um set but I'm also looking at doing a
silver and a gold set
um so I want to really develop with a
few more pieces in the in the world of
Chess so if you go to
firstclasschess.com
um it's a new site that I've just
established and you can see the Pearl
real set on there and um you'll see
further chess art that I create in the
in the coming months
okay well amazing go to
firstclasschess.com for more info Colin
this has been it's been quite the
experience to have our have our our
chess board normally the house of stunt
board there and now uh the the most
beautiful and valuable chess set modeled
after the house of Staunton took over
took over our our coverage of the feeder
World Chess Championship today this has
been this has been really exciting and
and very interesting to learn more about
so thank you so much for your time and
uh we we really appreciate uh really
appreciate what you've created here
thank you Denny thank you very much and
thanks to everybody involved chess.com
and
all the great Champions on watching play
and I'm really inspired and yeah very
humbled to actually have the set played
on by
these amazing people thank you
thank you Colin
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what a historic day this was if you're
still with us first of all thank you and
for being up being a part of this moment
with us the longest game in World Chess
Championship history occurred today on
do I even know the day December 3rd 2021
and Magnus Carlson scores his first
victory in more than five years in the
classical portion amazing stuff amazing
chess if you happen to be just tuning in
take the time to back this thing up this
weekend and check it out even with you
tuning in for our live coverage tomorrow
uh before we go any further I want to as
usual thank our sponsors House of
Staunton this beautiful board brought To
Us by them in our coinbase critical
moment of the game displayed on the
board our coinbase critical moment was
the move Queen to E4 by yawn
unfortunately the critical moment going
to a moment that the Challenger will not
remember fondly when it doesn't seem
clear why he didn't just keep the
position where it was holding on to the
eighth three Pawn but when he played
Queen E4 and Magnus had the opportunity
to simplify the game into a position
where only the rook and Knight could
outplay the queen one thing we learned
is that Magnus does know how the Knight
moves given how well he played for the
rest of the game so again thank you to
House of Staunton for report here
remember you can get 10 percent off
actually I think it's 15 off in fact if
you order a house of something bored
they have all kinds of amazing
handcrafted chess sets and Boards all
you got to do is go to House of Staunton
use the promo code chess.com to do some
holiday shopping get someone in your
life an amazing chessboard this holiday
season
while we have you of course let's remind
you again just like today no matter how
long the day is we are going to bring it
to you in the post game show tomorrow we
have more amazing guests we start out
with Labon aronian another Super Grand
Master bringing us the chest takes right
at the top we also will have Eric Hansen
the streamer and also very strong Grand
Master we will have Hammer of course we
always do he joins us from Norway no
matter how late he gets for him and then
we will have Ludwig agarin tomorrow uh
we'll catch up with Ludwig again he will
give his first live interview since
leaving twitch for YouTube gaming for
live streaming we can't wait to dive
into things with him ask him some
interesting questions and really get
really get uh deep with him on on his
future where things are going with
YouTube gaming and just talk to him in
general about the World Chess
Championship we know he's a chess fan
and he's also a Hess fan so we'll ask
him to give our Hess Champion a little
bit of a ranking in terms of how Robert
has been performing with us this has
been an amazing day my voice is sore I
I'm exhausted like everybody else is but
I think it was worth the wait super glad
to have shared this moment with you
thank you so much so no matter what
you're about to do from here whether
it's about to be a good day you're
having a good night this is goodbye
goodbye
when the world comes together to create
a better tomorrow it's going to be magic
oh
[Music]
magic magic
with music with architecture with colors
magic with celebration with your safety
From Here There and Everywhere for six
homos day and night join the making of a
new world starting October 1st
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]